[Music]
hello guys welcome to this complete
cloud computing course by simply learn
in this video we will be covering some
of the most important concepts related
to cloud computing
samuel our multi-platform cloud
architect with over 15 years of
experience in the cloud domain will take
you through the fundamentals of cloud
computing we will talk about the cloud
lifecycle important topics of aws
microsoft azure and google cloud
platform we will also take a look at how
to become an aws cloud architect we will
also look at the differences between the
three platforms finally we will take you
through the most important interview
questions that you might face in your
cloud interview first off we will have
an introduction to cloud computing by
our instructor samuel hi there i'm sam
from simply learn and i work as a
multi-platform cloud architect and
trainer and let me welcome you to this
learning video called what is cloud
computing as we learn what is cloud
computing we will also be learning about
how things were before cloud computing
and benefits of cloud computing
different types of cloud computing
available and some of the famous
companies that are using cloud computing
and they're getting benefited out of it
we're going to learn all that before
cloud computing existed if we need any
it servers or application let's say a
basic web server it does not come easy
now here is an owner of a business and i
know you would have guessed it already
that he's running and successful
business by looking at the hot and fresh
brewed coffee in his desk and lots and
lots of paperwork to review and approve
now he had a smart not only smart
looking but a really smart worker in his
office called mark and on one fine day
he called mark and said that he would
like to do business online in other
words he would like to take his business
online and for that he needed his own
website as the first thing and mark puts
all his knowledge together and comes up
with this requirement that his boss
would need lots of servers databases and
softwares to get his business online
which means a lot of investment and mark
also adds that his boss will need to
invest on acquiring technical expertise
to manage the hardware and software that
they will be purchasing and also to
monitor the infrastructure and after
hearing all this his boss was close to
dropping his plan to go online but
before he made a decision he chose to
check if there are any alternatives
where he don't have to spend a lot of
money and don't have to spend acquiring
technical expertise now that's when mark
opened this discussion with his boss and
he explained his boss about cloud
computing and he explained his boss the
same thing that i'm going to explain to
you in some time now about what is cloud
computing what is cloud computing cloud
computing is the use of a network of
remote servers hosted on the internet to
store manage and process data rather
than having all that locally and using
local server for that cloud computing is
also storing our data in the internet
from anywhere and accessing our data
from anywhere throughout the internet
and the companies that offer those
services are called cloud providers
cloud computing is also being able to
deploy and manage our applications
services and network throughout the
globe and manage them through the web
management or configuration portal in
other words cloud computing service
providers give us the ability to manage
our applications and services through a
global network or internet example of
such providers are amazon web servers
and microsoft azure now that we have
known what cloud computing is let's talk
about the benefits of cloud computing
now i need to tell you the cloud
benefits is what is driving cloud
adoption like anything in the recent
days if you want an it resource or a
service now with cloud it's available
for me almost instantaneously and it's
ready for production almost the same
time now this reduces the go live date
and the product and the service hit the
market almost instantaneously compared
to the legacy environment and because of
this the companies have started to
generate revenue almost the next day if
not the same day planning and buying the
right size hardware has always been a
challenge in legacy environment and if
you're not careful when doing this we
might need to live with the hardware
that's undersized for the rest of our
lives with cloud we do not buy any
hardware but we use the hardware and pay
for the time we use it if that hardware
does not fit our requirement release it
and start using a better configuration
and pay only for the time you use that
new and better configuration in legacy
environments forecasting demand is an
full-time job but with cloud you can let
the monitoring and automation tool to
work for you and to rapidly scale up and
down the resources based on the need of
that r not only that the resources
services data can be accessed from
anywhere as long as we are connected to
the internet and even there are tools
and techniques now available which will
let you to work offline and will sync
whenever the internet is available
making sure the data is stored in
durable storage and in a secure fashion
is the talk of the business and cloud
answers that million dollar question
with cloud the data can be stored in a
highly durable storage and replicated to
multiple regions if you want and the
data that we store is encrypted and
secured in a fashion that's beyond what
we can imagine in local data centers now
let's bleed into the discussion about
the types of cloud computing very lately
there are multiple ways to categorize
cloud computing because it's ever
growing now we have more categories out
of all these six sort of stand out you
know categorizing cloud based on
deployments and categorizing cloud based
on services and again under deployments
categorizing them based on how they have
been implemented you know is it private
is it public or is it hybrid and again
categorizing them based on the servers
it provides is it infrastructure as a
service or is it platform as a service
or is it software as a service let's
look at them one by one let's talk about
the different types of cloud based on
the deployment models first in public
cloud everything is stored and accessed
in and through the internet and any
internet users with proper permissions
can be given access to some of the
applications and resources and in public
cloud we literally own nothing beat the
hardware or software everything is
managed by the provider aws azure and
google are some examples of public cloud
private cloud on the other hand with
private cloud the infrastructure is
exclusively for an single organization
the organizations can choose to run
their own cloud locally or choose to
outsource it to a public cloud provider
as managed services and when this is
done the service the infrastructure will
be maintained on a private network some
examples are vmware cloud and some of
the aws products are very good example
for private cloud hybrid cloud has taken
things to the whole new level with
hybrid cloud we get the benefit of both
public and private cloud organizations
will choose to keep some of their
applications locally and some of the
application will be present in the cloud
one good example is nasa it uses hybrid
cloud it uses private cloud to store
sensitive data and uses public cloud to
store and share data which are not
sensitive or confidential let's now
discuss about cloud based on service
model
the first and the broader category is
infrastructure as a service here we
would rent the servers network storage
and will pay for them in an hourly basis
but we will have access to the resources
we provision and for some we will have
root level access as well ec2 in aws is
a very good example it's a vm for which
we have root level access to the os and
admin access to the hardware the next
type of service model would be platform
as a service now in this model the
providers will give me a pre-built
platform where we can deploy our codes
and our applications and they will be up
and running we only need to manage the
codes and not the infrastructure here in
software as a service the cloud
providers sell the end product which is
a software or an application and we
directly buy the software on an
subscription basis it's not the infra or
the platform but the end product or the
software or a functioning application
and we pay for the hours we use the
software and in here the client
maintains full control of the software
and does not maintain any equipment
amazon and azure also sell products that
are software as service this chart sort
of explains the difference between the
four models starting from on-premises to
infrastructure as a service to platform
as a service to software as a service
this is self-explanatory that the
resource managed by us are huge in on
premises that towards your left as you
watch and it's little less in
infrastructure as a service as we move
further towards the right and further
reduced in platform as a service and
there's really nothing to manage when it
comes to software as a service because
we buy the software not any
infrastructure component attached to it
now let's talk about the life cycle of
the cloud computing solution the very
first thing in the life cycle of a
solution or a cloud solution is to get a
proper understanding of the requirement
i didn't say get the requirement but
said get a proper understanding of the
requirement it is very vital because
only then we will be able to properly
pick the right service offered by the
provider getting a sound understanding
the next thing would be to define the
hardware meaning choose the compute
servers that will provide the right
support where you can resize the compute
capacity in the cloud to run application
programs getting a sound understanding
of the requirement helps in picking the
right hardware one size does not fit all
there are different services and
hardwares for different needs you might
have like ec2 if you're looking for is
and lambda if you're looking for
serverless computing and ecs that
provides containerized service so there
are a lot of hardware's available pick
the right hardware that suits your
requirement the third thing is to define
the storage choose the appropriate
storage service where you can backup
your data and a separate storage service
where you can archive your data locally
within the cloud or from the internet
and choose the appropriate storage there
is one separately for backup called s3
and there is one separately for archival
that's for glaciers so you know you
knowing the difference between them
really helps in picking the right
service for the right kind of need
define the network define the network
that securely delivers data video and
applications define and identify the
network services properly for example
vpc for network route 53 for dns and
direct connection for private p2p line
from your office to the aws data center
set up the right security services im
for authentication and authorization and
kms for data encryption at rest so there
are variety of security products
available we got to pick the right one
that suits our need and there are a
variety of deployment and automation and
monitoring tools that you can pick from
for example cloud watch is for
monitoring auto scaling is for being
elastic and cloud formation is define
the management process and tools you can
have complete control of your cloud
environment if you define the management
tools which monitors your aws resources
and or the custom applications running
on aws platform there are variety of
deployment automation and monitoring
tools you can pick from like cloud watch
for monitoring auto scaling for
automation and the cloud formation for a
deployment so knowing them will help you
in defining the life cycle of the cloud
computing solution properly and
similarly there are a lot of tools for
testing a process like code star and
code build and code pipeline these are
tools with which you can build test and
deploy your code quickly and finally
once everything is set and done click
the analytic service for analyzing and
visualizing the data using the analytics
services where we can start querying the
data instantly and get a result now if
you want to visually view the happenings
in your environment you can pick antenna
and other tools for analytics or emr and
which is elastic mapreduce and cloud
search thanks guys now we have samuel
and rahul to take us through the full
course in which they will explain basic
framework of amazon web services and
explore all of its important services
like ec2 lambda s3 iam and
cloudformation we'll also talk about
azure and some of its popular services
hello everyone let me introduce myself
as sam a multi-platform cloud architect
and trainer and i'm so glad and i'm
equally excited to talk and walk you
through the session about what aws is
and talk to you about some services and
offerings and about how companies get
benefited by migrating their
applications and infra into aws so
what's aws let's talk about that now
before that let's talk about how life
was without any cloud provider and in
this case how life was without aws so
let's walk back and picture how things
were back in 2000 which is not so long
ago but a lot of changes a lot of
changes for better had happened since
that time now back in 2000 a request for
a new server is not an happy thing at
all because a lot of
money a lot of validations a lot of
planning are involved in getting a
server online or up and running and even
after we've finally got the server it's
not all said and done a lot of
optimization that needs to be done on
that server to make it worth it and get
a good return on investment from that
server and even after we have optimized
for a good return on investment the work
is still not done there will often be a
frequent increase and decrease in the
capacity and you know even news about
our website getting popular and getting
more hits it's still an bittersweet
experience because now i need to add
more servers to the environment which
means that it's going to cost me even
more but thanks to the present day cloud
technology if the same situation were to
happen today my new server it's almost
ready and it's ready instantaneously and
with the swift tools and technologies
that amazon is providing uh in
provisioning my server instantaneously
and adding any type of workload on top
of it and making my storage and server
secure you know creating a durable
storage where data that i store in the
cloud never gets lost with all that
features amazon has got our back so
let's talk about what is aws there are a
lot of definitions for it but i'm going
to put together a simple and a precise
definition as much as possible now let
me iron that out cloud still runs on and
hardware all right and
there are certain features in that
infrastructure in that cloud
infrastructure that makes cloud cloud or
that makes aws a cloud provider now we
get all the services all the
technologies all the features and all
the benefits that we get in our local
data center like you know security and
compute capacity and databases and in
fact you know we get even more cool
features like content caching in various
global locations around the planet but
again out of all the features the best
part is that i get or we get everything
on a pay as we go model the less i use
the less i pay and the more i use the
less i pay per unit very attractive
isn't it right and that's not all the
applications that we provision in aws
are very reliable because they run on a
reliable infrastructure and it's very
scalable because it runs on an on-demand
infrastructure and it's very flexible
because of the designs and because of
the design options available for me in
the cloud let's talk about how all this
happened aws was launched in 2002 after
the amazon we know as the online retail
store wanted to sell their remaining or
unused infrastructure as a service or as
an offering for customers to buy and use
it from them you know sell
infrastructure as a service the idea
sort of clicked and aws launched their
first product first product in 2006
that's like four years after the idea
launch and in 2012 they held a big sized
customer even to gather inputs and
concerns from customers and they were
very dedicated in making those requests
happen and that habit is still being
followed it's still being followed as a
reinvent by aws and at 2015 amazon
announced its revenue to be 4.6 billion
and in 2015 through 2016 aws launched
products and services that help migrate
customer services into aws well there
were products even before but this is
when a lot of focus was given on
developing migrating services and in the
same year that's in 2016 amazon's
revenue was 10 billion and not but not
the least as we speak amazon has more
than 100 products and services available
for customers and get benefited from all
right let's talk about the
services that are available in amazon
let's start with this product called s3
now s3 is a great tool for internet
backup and it's it's the cheapest
storage option in the object storage
category and not only that the data that
we put in s3 is retrievable from the
internet s3 is really cool and we have
other products like migration and data
collection and data transfer products
and here we can not only collect data
seamlessly but also in a real-time way
monitor the data or analyze the data
that's being received that they're cool
products like aws data transfers
available that helps achieve that and
then we have products like ec2 elastic
compute cloud that's an resizable
computer where we can anytime anytime
after the size of the computer based on
the need or based on the forecast then
we have simple notification services
systems and tools available in amazon to
update us with notifications through
email or through sms now anything
anything can be sent through email or
through sms if we use that service it
could be alarms or it could be service
notifications if you want stuff like
that and then we have some security
tools like kms key management system
which uses aes 256 bit encryption to
encrypt our data at rest then we have
lambda a service for which we pay only
for the time in seconds seconds it takes
to execute our code and we're not paying
for the infrastructure here it's just
the seconds the program is going to take
to execute the code for the short
program we'll be paying in milliseconds
if it's a bit bigger program we'll be
probably paying in 60 seconds or 120
seconds but that's not cheap lot simple
and lots cost effective as against
paying for service on an ugly basis
which a lot of other services are well
that's cheap but using lambda is a lot
cheaper than that and then we have
services like route 53 a dns service in
the cloud and now i do not have to
maintain a dns account somewhere else
and my cloud environment with aws i can
get both in the same place all right let
me talk to you about um how aws makes
life easier or how companies got
benefited by using aws as their i.t
provider for their applications or for
the infrastructure now uniliver is a
company and they had a problem right and
they had a problem and they picked aws
as a solution to their problem right now
this company was sort of spread across
190 countries and they were relying on a
lot of digital marketing for promoting
their products and their existing
environment their legacy local
environment proved not to support their
changing id demands and they could not
standardize their old environment now
they chose to move part of their
applications to aws because they were
not getting what they wanted in their
local environment and since then you
know rollouts were easy provisioning new
applications became easy and even
provisioning infrastructure became easy
and they were able to do all that in
push button scaling and needless to talk
about
backups that are safe and backups that
can be securely accessed from the cloud
as needed now that company is growing
along with aws because of their swift
speed in rolling out deployments and
being able to access secure backups from
various places and generate reports and
in fact useful reports out of it that
helps their business now on the same
lines let me also talk to you about
kellogg's and how they got benefited by
using amazon now kellogg's had a
different problem it's one of its kind
now their business model was very
dependent on an infrared that will help
to analyze data really fast right
because they were running promotions
based on the analyzed data that they get
so they're being able to respond to the
analyzed data as soon as possible was
critical or vital in their environment
and luckily sap running on hana
environment is what they needed and you
know they picked that service in the
cloud and that's sort of solved the
problem now the company does not
have to deal with uh maintaining their
legacy infra and maintaining their heavy
compute capacity and maintaining their
database locally all that is now moved
to the cloud or they are using cloud as
their i.t service provider and and now
they have a greater and powerful it
environment that very much complements
their business hi there i'm samuel a
multi-platform cloud architect and i'm
very excited and honored to walk you
through this learning series about aws
let me start the session with this
scenario let's imagine how life would
have been without spotify for those who
are hearing about spotify for the first
time spotify is an online music service
offering and it offers instant access to
over 16 million licensed songs spotify
now uses aws cloud to store the data and
share it with their customers but prior
to aws they had some issues
imagine using spotify before aws let's
talk about that back then users were
often getting errors because spotify
could not keep up with the increased
demand for storage every new day and
that led to users getting upset and
users cancelling the subscription the
problem spotify was facing at that time
was their users were present globally
and were accessing it from everywhere
and they had different latency in their
applications and spotify had a demanding
situation where they need to frequently
catalogue the songs released yesterday
today and in the future and this was
changing every new day and the songs
coming in rate was about 20 000 a day
and back then they could not keep up
with this requirement and needless to
say they were badly looking for a way to
solve this problem and that's when they
got introduced to aws and it was a
perfect fit and match for their problem
aws offered at dynamically increasing
storage and that's what they needed aws
also offered tools and techniques like
storage lifecycle management and trusted
advisor to properly utilize the resource
so we always get the best out of the
resource used aws addressed their
concerns about easily being able to
scale yes you can scale the aws
environment very easily how easily one
might ask it's just a few button clicks
and aws solved spotify's problem let's
talk about how it can help you with your
organization's problem let's talk about
what is aws first and then let's bleed
into how aws became so successful and
the different types of services that aws
provides and what's the future of cloud
and aws in specific let's talk about
that and finally we'll talk about a use
case where you will see how easy it is
to create a web application with aws all
right let's talk about what is aws aws
or amazon web services is a secure cloud
service platform it is also pay as you
go type billing model where there is no
upfront or capital cost we'll talk about
how soon the service will be available
well the service will be available in a
matter of seconds with aws you can also
do identity and access management that
is authenticating and authorizing a user
or a program on the fly and almost all
the services are available on demand and
most of them are available
instantaneously and as we speak amazon
offers 100 plus services and this list
is growing every new week now that would
make you wonder how aws became so
successful of course it's their
customers let's talk about the list of
well-known companies that has their idea
environment in aws adobe adobe uses aws
to provide multi-terabyte operating
environments for its customers by
integrating its system with aws cloud
adobe can focus on deploying and
operating its own software instead of
trying to you know deploy and manage the
infrastructure airbnb is another company
it's an community marketplace that
allows property owners and travelers to
connect each other for the purpose of
renting unique vacation spaces around
the world and the airbnb community users
activities are conducted on the website
and through iphones and android
applications airbnb has a huge
infrastructure in aws and they are
almost using all the services in aws and
are getting benefited from it another
example would be autodesk autodesk
develops software for engineering
designing and entertainment industries
using services like amazon rds or
rational database service and amazon s3
or amazon simple storage servers
autodesk can focus on deploying or
developing its machine learning tools
instead of spending that time on
managing the infrastructure aol or
american online uses aws and using aws
they have been able to close data
centers and decommission about 14 000
in-house and co-located servers and move
mission critical workload to the cloud
and extend its global reach and save
millions of dollars on energy resources
bitdefender is an internet security
software firm and their portfolio of
softwares include antivirus and
anti-spyware products bitdefender uses
ec2 and they are currently running few
hundred instances that handle about five
terabytes of data and they also use
elastic load balancer to load balance
the connection coming in to those
instances across availability zones and
they provide seamless global delivery of
servers because of that the bmw group it
uses aws for its new connected car
application that collects sensor data
from bmw 7 series cars to give drivers
dynamically updated map information
canon's office imaging products division
benefits from faster deployment times
lower cost and global reach by using aws
to deliver cloud-based services such as
mobile print the office imaging products
division uses aws such as amazon s3 and
amazon route 53 amazon cloudfront and
amazon im for their testing development
and production services comcast it's the
world's largest cable company and the
leading provider of internet service in
the united states comcast uses aws in a
hybrid environment out of all the other
cloud providers comcast chose aws for
its flexibility and scalable hybrid
infrastructure docker is a company
that's helping redefine the way
developers build ship and run
applications this company focuses on
making use of containers for this
purpose and in aws the service called
the amazon ec2 container service is
helping them achieve it the esa or
european space agency although much of
esa's work is done by satellites some of
the programs data storage and computing
infrastructure is built on amazon web
services esa chose aws because of its
economical pay as ego system as well as
its quick startup time the guardian
newspaper uses aws and it uses a wide
range of aws services including amazon
kinesis amazon redshift that power an
analytic dashboard which editors used to
see how stories are trending in real
time financial times ft is one of the
world's largest leading business news
organization and they used amazon
redshift to perform their analysis a
funny thing happened amazon redshirt
performed so quickly that some analysis
thought it was malfunctioning they were
used to running queries overnight and
they found that the results were indeed
correct just as much faster by using
amazon redshift fd is supporting the
same business functions with costs that
are 80 percentage lower than what was
before general electric ge is at the
moment as we speak migrating more than
9000 workloads including 300 desperate
erp systems to aws while reducing its
data center footprint from 34 to 4 over
the next three years similarly howard
medical school htc imdb mcdonald's nasa
kellogg's and lot more are using the
services amazon provides and are getting
benefited from it and this huge success
and customer portfolio is just the tip
of the iceberg and if we think why so
many adapt aws and if we let aws answer
that question this is what aws would say
people are adapting aws because of the
security and durability of the data an
end-to-end privacy and encryption of the
data and storage experience we can also
rely on aws way of doing things by using
the aws tools and techniques and
suggested best practices built upon the
years of experience it has gained
flexibility there is a greater
flexibility in aws that allows us to
select the os language and database easy
to use swiftness in deploying we can
host our applications quickly in aws be
it a new application or migrating an
existing application into aws
scalability the application can be
easily scaled up or scaled down
depending on the user requirement cost
saving we only pay for the compute power
storage and other resources you use and
that too without any long-term
commitments now let's talk about the
different types of services that aws
provides the services that we talk about
fall in any of the following categories
you see like you know compute storage
database security customer engagement
desktop and streaming machine learning
developers tools stuff like that and if
you do not see the service that you're
looking for it's probably is because aws
is creating it as we speak now let's
look at some of them that are very
commonly used within computer services
we have amazon ec2 amazon elastic bean
stock amazon light sale and amazon
lambda amazon ec2 provides compute
capacity in the cloud now this capacity
is secure and it is resizable based on
the user's requirement now look at this
the requirement for the web traffic
keeps changing and behind the scenes in
the cloud ec2 can expand its environment
to three instances and during no load it
can shrink its environment to just one
resource elastic beanstalk it helps us
to scale and deploy web applications and
it's made with a number of programming
languages elastic beanstalk is also an
easy to use service for deploying and
scaling web applications and services
deployed a bit in java.net php nodejs
python ruby docker and lot other
familiar services such as apache
passenger and iis we can simply upload
our code and elastic beanstalk
automatically handles the deployment
from capacity provisioning to load
balancing to auto scaling to application
health monitoring and amazon lightsail
is a virtual private server which is
easy to launch and easy to manage amazon
lightsail is the easiest way to get
started with aws for developers who just
need a virtual private server lightsail
includes everything you need to launch
your project quickly on a virtual
machine like ssd based storage a virtual
machine tools for data transfer dns
management and a static ip and that too
for a very low and predictable price aws
lambda has taken cloud computing
services to a whole new level it allows
us to pay only for the compute time no
need for provisioning and managing
servers and aws lambda is a compute
service that lets us run code without
provisioning or managing servers lambda
executes your code only when needed and
scales automatically from few requests
per day to thousands per second you pay
only for the compute time you consume
there is no charge when your code is not
running let's look at some storage
services that amazon provides like
amazon s3 amazon glacier amazon abs and
amazon elastic file system amazon s3 is
an object storage that can store and
retrieve data from anywhere websites
mobile apps iot sensors and so on can
easily use amazon s3 to store and
retrieve data it's an object storage
built to store and retrieve any amount
of data from anywhere with its features
like flexibility and managing data and
the durability it provides and the
security that it provides amazon simple
storage service or s3 is a storage for
the internet and glacier glacier is a
cloud storage service that's used for
archiving data and long-term backups and
this glacier is an secure durable and
extremely low-cost cloud storage service
for data archiving and long-term backups
amazon ebs amazon elastic block store
provides block store volumes for the
instances of ec2 and this elastic block
store is highly available and a reliable
storage volume that can be attached to
any running instance that is in the same
availability zone abs volumes that are
attached to the ec2 instances are
exposed as storage volumes that
persistent independently from the
lifetime of the instance an amazon
elastic file system or efs provides an
elastic file storage which can be used
with aws cloud service and resources
that are on premises an amazon elastic
file system it's an simple it's scalable
it's an elastic file storage for use
with amazon cloud services and for
on-premises resources it's easy to use
and offers a simple interface that
allows you to create and configure file
systems quickly and easily amazon file
system is built to elastically scale on
demand without disturbing the
application growing and shrinking
automatically as you add and remove
files your application have the storage
they need and when they need it now
let's talk about databases the two major
database flavors are amazon rds and
amazon redshift amazon rds it really
eases the process involved in setting up
operating and scaling a relational
database in the cloud amazon rds
provides cost efficient and resizable
capacity while automating time-consuming
administrative tasks such as hardware
provisioning database setup patching and
backups it sort of frees us from
managing the hardware and sort of helps
us to focus on the application it's also
cost effective and resizable and it's
also optimized for memory performance
and input and output operations not only
that it also automates most of the
services like taking backups you know
monitoring stuff like that it automates
most of those services amazon redshift
amazon redshift is a data warehousing
service that enables users to analyze
the data using sql and other business
intelligent tools amazon redshift is an
fast and fully managed data warehouse
that makes it simple and cost effective
analyze all your data using standard sql
and your existing business intelligent
tools it also allows you to run complex
analytic queries against petabyte of
structured data using sophisticated
query optimizations and most of the
results they generally come back in
seconds all right let's quickly talk
about some more services that aws offers
there are a lot more services that aws
provides but are we going to look at
some more services that are widely used
aws application discovery services help
enterprise customers plan migration
projects by gathering information about
their on-premises data centers in a
planning a data center migration can
involve thousands of workloads they are
often deeply interdependent server
utilization data and dependency mapping
are important early first step in
migration process and this aws
application discovery service collects
and presents configuration usage and
behavior data from your servers to help
you better understand your workloads
route 53 it's a network and content
delivery service it's an highly
available and scalable cloud domain name
system or dns service and amazon route
53 is fully compliant with ipv6 as well
elastic load balancing it's also a
network and content delivery service
elastic load balancing automatically
distributes incoming application traffic
across multiple targets such as amazon
ec2 instance containers and ip addresses
it can handle the varying load of your
application traffic in a single
available zones and also across
availability zones away auto scaling it
monitors your application and
automatically adjusts the capacity to
maintain steady and predictable
performance at a lowest possible cost
using aws auto scaling it's easy to set
up application scaling for multiple
resources across multiple services in
minutes autoscaling can be applied to
web services and also for db services
aws identity and access management it
enables you to manage access to aws
services and resources securely using im
you can create and manage aws users and
groups and use permissions to allow and
deny their access to aws resources and
moreover it's a free service now let's
talk about the future of aws well let me
tell you something cloud is here to stay
here's what in store for aws in the
future as years pass by we're gonna have
a variety of cloud applications born
like iot artificial intelligence
business intelligence serverless
computing and so on cloud will also
expand into other markets like
healthcare banking space automated cars
and so on as i was mentioning some time
back a lot or greater focus will be
given to artificial intelligence and
eventually because of the flexibility
and advantage that cloud provides we're
going to see a lot of companies moving
into the cloud all right let's now talk
about how easy it is to deploy and web
application in the cloud so the scenario
here is that our users like a product
and we need to have a mechanism to
receive input from them about their
likes and dislikes and you know give
them the appropriate product as per
their need all right though the setup
and the environment it sort of looks
complicated we don't have to worry
because aws has tools and technologies
which can help us to achieve it now
we're going to use services like route
53 services like cloud watch ec2 s3 and
lot more and all these put together are
going to give an application that's
fully functionable and an application
that's going to receive the information
like using the services like route 53
cloudwatch ec2 and s3 we're going to
create an application and that's going
to meet our need so back to our original
requirement all i want is to deploy a
web application for a product that keeps
our users updated about the happenings
and the new comings in the market and to
fulfill this requirement here is all the
services we would need ec2 here is used
for provisioning the computational power
needed for this application
and ec2 has a vast variety of family and
types that we can pick from for the
types of workloads and also for the
intents of the workloads we're also
going to use s3 for storage and s3
provides any additional storage
requirement for the resources or any
additional storage requirement for the
web applications and we are also going
to use cloudwatch for monitoring the
environment and cloudwatch monitors the
application and the environment and it
provides trigger for scaling in and
scaling out the infrastructure and we're
also going to use route 53 for dns and
route 53 helps us to register the domain
name for our web application and with
all the tools and technologies together
all of them put together we're going to
make an application a perfect
application that caters our need all
right so i'm going to use elastic bean
stock for this project and the name of
the application is going to be as you
see gsg sign up and the environment name
is gsg signup environment one let me
also pick a name let me see if this name
is available yes that's available that's
the domain name so let me pick that and
the application that i have is going to
run on node.js so let me pick that
platform and launch now as you see
elastic bean stock this is going to
launch an instance it's going to launch
the monitoring setup or the monitoring
environment it's going to create a load
balancer as well and it's going to take
care of all the security features needed
for this application
all right look at that i was able to go
to that url which is what we gave and
it's now having an default page shown up
meaning all the dependencies for the
software is installed and it's just
waiting for me to upload the code or in
specific the page required so let's do
that
let me upload the code i already have
the code saved here
that's my code
and that's going to take some time all
right it has done its thing and now if i
go to the same url look at that i'm
being thrown an advertisement page all
right so if i sign up with my name email
and stuff like that you know it's going
to receive the information and it's
going to send an email to the owner
saying that somebody had subscribed to
your service that's the default feature
of this app look at that email to the
owner saying that somebody had
subscribed to your app and this is their
email address stuff like that not only
that it's also going to create an entry
in the database and dynamodb is the
service that this application uses to
store data there's my dynamodb and if i
go to tables
right and go to items i'm going to see
that a user with name samuel and email
address so and so has said okay or has
shown interest in the preview of my site
or product so this is where this is how
i collect those information right and
some more things about the
infrastructure itself is
it is running behind and load balancer
look at that it had created a load
balancer it had also created an auto
scaling group now that's the feature of
elastic load balancer that we have
chosen it has created an auto scaling
group and now let's put this url you see
this it's it's not a fancy url right
it's an amazon given url a dynamic url
so let's put this url behind our dns
let's do that
so go to services go to route 53
go to hosted zone and there we can find
the
dns name right so that's a dns name all
right
all right let's create an entry
and map that url
to our load balancer right
and create now technically if i
go to this url it should take me
to that application all right look at
that i went to my custom url and now
that's pointed to my application
previously my application was having a
random url and now it's having a custom
url
so what did we learn we started the
session with what is aws we looked at
features and tools technologies products
that aws provides and we also looked at
the how aws became very successful again
we looked into the benefits and features
of aws in-depth and we also looked at
some of the services that aws provides
in random and then we picked particular
services and we talked about them like
ec2 elastic bean stock light sale lambda
storage stuff like that then we also
looked at the future of aws what aws
holds in the store for us we looked at
that and then finally we looked at a lab
in which we created an application using
elastic beanstalk and all that we had to
do was a couple of clicks and boom an
application was there available that was
connected to
the database and that was connected to
the simple notification system that was
connected to cloudwatch that was
connected to storage stuff like that
what is azure what's the big cloud
service provider all about so azure is a
cloud computing platform provided by
microsoft now it's basically an online
portal through which you can access and
manage resources and services
now resources and services are nothing
but you know you can store your data and
you can transform the data using
services that microsoft provides again
all you need is the internet and being
able to connect to the azure portal then
you get access to all of the resources
and their services in case you want to
know more about how it's different from
its rival which is aws i suggest you
click on the top right corner and watch
the aws versus azure video so that you
can clearly tell how both these cloud
service providers are different from
each other now here are some things that
you need to know about azure it was
launched in february 1st 2010 which is
significantly later than when aws was
launched it's free to start and has a
pay-per-use model which means like i
said before you need to pay for the
services you use through azure and one
of the most important selling points is
that 80 percent of fortune 500 companies
use as your services which means that
most of the bigger companies of the
world actually recommend using azure and
then azure supports a wide variety of
programming languages the c-sharp
node.js java and so much more another
very important selling point of azure is
the amount of data centers it has across
the world now it's important for a cloud
service provider to have many data
centers around the world because it
means that they can provide their
services to a wider audience now azure
has 42 which is more than any cloud
service provider has at the moment it
expects to have 12 more in a period of
time which brings its total number of
regions it covers to 54. now let's talk
about azure services now azure services
have 18 categories and more than 200
services so we clearly can't go through
all of them it has services that cover
compute and machine learning integration
management tools identity devops web and
so much more you're going to have a hard
time trying to find a domain that azure
doesn't cover and if it doesn't cover it
now you can be certain they're working
on it as we speak so first let's start
with the compute services first virtual
machine with this service what you're
getting to do is to create a virtual
machine of linux or windows operating
system it's easily configurable you can
add ram you can decrease ram you can add
storage remove it all of it is possible
in a match of seconds now let's talk
about the second service cloud service
now with this you can create a
application within the cloud and all of
the work after you deploy it deploying
the application that is is taken care of
by azure which includes you know
provisioning the application load
balancing ensuring that the application
is in good health and all the other
things are handled by azure next up
let's talk about service fabric now with
service fabric the process of developing
a micro service is greatly simplified so
you might be wondering what exactly is a
micro service now a micro service is
basically an application that consists
of smaller applications coupled together
next up functions now with functions you
can create applications in any
programming language that you want
another very important part is that you
don't have to worry about any hardware
components you don't have to worry what
ram you require or how much storage you
require all of that is taken care of by
azure all you need is to provide the
code to azure and it will execute it and
you don't have to worry about anything
else now let's talk about some
networking services first up we have
azure cdn or the content delivery
network now the azure cdn service is
basically for delivering web content to
users now this content is of high
bandwidth and can be transferred or can
be delivered to any person across the
world now these are actually a network
of servers that are placed in strategic
positions across the world so that the
customers can obtain this data as fast
as possible next up we have express
route now with this you can actually
connect your on-premise network onto the
microsoft cloud or any of the services
that you want through a private
connection so the only communication
that happens is between your on-premise
network and the service that you want
then you have virtual network now with
virtual network you can have any of the
azure services communicate with each
other in a secure manner in a private
manner next we have azure dns so azure
dns is a hosting service which allows
you to host their dns or domain name
system domains in azure so you can host
your application using azure dns now for
the storage services first up we have
disk storage with this storage you are
given a cost effective option of
choosing hdd or solid state drives to go
along with your virtual machines based
on your requirements then you have blob
storage now this is actually optimized
to ensure that they can store massive
amounts of unstructured data which can
include text data or even binary data
next you have file storage which is a
managed file storage and can be
accessible via the smb protocol or the
server message block protocol and
finally you have queue storage now with
queue storage you can provide durable
message queuing for an extremely large
workload and the most important part is
that this can be accessed from anywhere
in the world now let's talk about how
azure can be used firstly for
application development it could be any
application mostly web applications then
you can test the application see how
well it works you can host the
application on the internet you can
create virtual machines like i mentioned
before with the service you can create
these virtual machines of any size or
ram that you want you can integrate in
sync features you can collect and store
matrices for example how the data works
how the current data is how you can
improve upon it all of that is possible
with these services and you have virtual
hard drives which is an extension of the
virtual machines where these services
are able to provide you a large amount
of storage where data can be stored talk
about azure in great length and breadth
and if you're looking for a video that
talks and walks you through all the
services in azure then this could be one
of the best video you could find in the
internet and without any further delay
let's get started
everybody like story is it so let's get
started with the story in a city not so
far away a ceo had plans to expand his
company globally and called one of his
id personal for an i.t opinion and this
guy has been in the company for a long
time and is very seasoned with the
company's infra and he nicely answered
the questions with what he foresaw and
he said i have a good news and a bad
news for us to go global and he starts
with the good news he said sir we're
well on our way to become one of the
world's largest shipping company and the
bad news is however our data centers
have almost run out of space and setting
up new ones around the world would be
too expensive and very time consuming
now the i.t personnel let's call him
mike now he explains the situation from
how he saw it but the ceo had done some
homework about how he was going to do it
and he answered mike saying don't worry
about that mic i've come up with a
solution for a problem and it's called
microsoft azure well mike is an
hard-working and honest id professional
working for that company but he did not
spend time on learning the latest
technologies and he asked this question
very honestly oh how does it solve a
problem and the ceo begins to explain
azure to mike and he starts with what is
cloud computing and then he goes on and
talks about azure and the service is
offered by azure and why azure is better
than the other cloud providers and what
are the great companies that uses azure
and how they got benefited out of it and
then he winds it all up with the use
cases of azure so he begins his
explanation saying microsoft azure is
known as the cloud service provider and
it works on the basis of cloud computing
now microsoft azure is formerly known as
windows azure and it's a microsoft's
public cloud computing platform it also
provides a range of cloud services
including some of them are compute
analytics storage and networking we can
always pick and choose from these
services to develop and scale our
applications or even plan on running
existing applications in the public
cloud microsoft azure is both a platform
as a service and infrastructure as a
service let's now fit their conversation
out and let's talk about what is cloud
computing azure services offered by
azure how is azure leading when compared
to other cloud service providers and
what are the companies that are using
azure let's talk about that in simple
terms cloud computing is being able to
access compute services like servers
storage database networking
software analytics intelligence and lot
more over the internet which is the
cloud with the
flexibility of the resources that we use
like anytime i want a results i can use
one and it becomes available immediately
and anytime if i want to retire and
results i can simply retire as a service
and not pay for it and we also
typically pay only for the services that
we use and this helps greatly with our
operating cost to run our infrastructure
more efficiently and scale our
environment up or down depending on the
business needs and changes
and all the servers and storages and
databases and networking all that are
accessed through the network of remote
systems or remote computers hosted in
the internet typically in the providers
data center which is azure in this case
now we don't use any physical server or
an on-premises server here well we still
use physical servers and vms you know
hosted on a hardware or a physical
server but they're all in the provider's
environment and none of them sit on
premises or in our data center we only
access them remotely it looks and feels
the same except for the fact that they
are in a remote location we access them
remotely do all the work remotely and
when we're done we can shut it down and
not pay for them so some of the use
cases some of the use cases of cloud
computing are creating applications and
services the other use cases are storing
or using cloud for storage alone
if there is one thing that ever grows in
our organization is the storage every
new day there is a new storage
requirement and it's very dynamic it's
very hard to predict and if we go out
and buy a big storage capacity up front
until we use the storage capacity fully
the empty storages you know we're
wasting money on them so instead i can
go for a storage with scales dynamically
that's in the cloud put storage or put
data in the cloud and pay only for what
you're storing and for the next month if
you have deleted or flushed out some
files or data pay less for it so it's a
very dynamic storage in the cloud and a
lot of companies are getting benefited
from storing data in the cloud because
of its uh dynamic in nature and the cost
that comes along with it the cheap cost
that comes along with it and also they
give a lot of the providers like azure
they give a data replication for free
they promise an sla along with the data
we store in the cloud so there's an sla
attached to it and they also provide
data recoveries as well if in case
something goes wrong with the physical
disk where our data is stored azure
automatically makes our data available
from the redundant or other places where
it had stored our data because of the
sla they wanted to keep the other use
case for azure is hosting websites and
running blogs using the compute service
be it storing music and letting your
users stream the music azure is a good
place to store music and stream the
music with the benefit of
cdn content delivery network which
allows us to stream a video or audio
files with great speed you know with
that with azure our audio or video
application works seamlessly because
they are provided to the client with
very low latency and that improves the
customer experience for our application
azure compute service is a good place
for delivering software on demand there
are a lot of software's embedded
softwares that we can buy using azure
and everything on a pay-as-you-go
service model so anytime we need a
software we can go out and immediately
buy the software for the next one or 2r
let's say and use them and then return
it back
we're not bound to any yearly licensing
cost by that azure computing services
has analytic available for us with which
we can analyze get a good visualization
of what's going on in a network be it
logs be the performance be the metrics
you know instead of looking at logs and
searching logs and trying to do manual
things over the heaps and heaps of logs
that we have saved azure analytics
services helps us to get a good visual
of what's going on in the network where
have we dropped where have we increased
or what's causing what's the major
driver what is the top 10 errors that we
get in the server in the application
stuff like that those can be easily
gathered from the azure analytic
services
now cloud is really a very cool term for
the internet a good analogy would be
looking back anytime we look at a
diagram when we do not know how things
are transferred we simply draw a cloud
right for example a mail gets sent from
a person in one country to a person in
the other country a lot of things
happening in between from the time you
hit the send button and the time the
other person hits the real button right
and we the the simple and the easiest
way of putting it in a picture is simply
draw a cloud and on the one end one
person will be sending the email and on
the other end the other person will be
reading the email so a cloud is a really
cool term for the internet now that's
some basics about cloud computing now
that we've understood about cloud
computing in general let's talk about
microsoft azure as a cloud service
now microsoft azure is a set of cloud
services to build
manage and deploy applications on a
network with the help of microsoft
azure's frameworks now microsoft azure
is a computing service created by
microsoft basically for building testing
deploying and managing applications and
services through a global network of
microsoft managed data centers
now microsoft azure provides sas which
is software as a service and pass which
is platform as a service and iaas
infrastructure as a service and they
support many different programming
languages tools and framework and those
tools and framework include both
microsoft specific and third-party
software now let me pick and talk about
a specific service for example
management azure automation provides a
way for us to automate the manual long
running and frequently repeated tasks
that are commonly performed tasks both
in cloud and enterprise environment it
saves us a lot of time and increases the
reliability and it kind of gives a good
administrative control and even
schedules the task automatically to be
performed on a regular basis
to give you a quick history of microsoft
azure it was launched on first february
and it was awarded or it was called
an industry leader for infrastructure
and platform as a service by a gartner
now gartner is the world's leading
research and advisory company this
microsoft azure supports a number of
programming languages like c sharp java
and python all these cool services we
get to use and pay only for how much we
use for example if we use for an r we
only get to pay for an r even the
costliest system available if you use
them for an r we only pay for that
particular r and then we're done no more
billing on the resource that we have
used a microsoft azure has spread itself
more than 50 regions around the world so
it's quite easy for us to pick a region
and it will start provisioning and
running our applications probably from
day one because the infrastructure and
the tools and technologies needed to run
our application are already available
all that we have to do is commit the
code in that particular region or build
an application and launch it in that
particular region and they become live
starting day one now because we have 50
regions around the world we can very
carefully design our environment to
provide low latency services to our
customers all right instead of in
traditional data center let's say you
know customers will have to or their
request will have to travel all the way
around the globe to reach a data center
which lives in the other side of the
planet and this adds more latency to it
and it is really not feasible to build a
data center
near
each customer location because of the
cost involved but with azure it's
possible azure already has data centers
around the world and all that we have to
do is just pick a data center build an
environment there they are available
starting day one number one and also the
cost is considerably saved because we
are using a public cloud instead of an
physical infrastructure to serve those
customers from a very local location and
these services that azure is offering is
ever increasing as of now as we speak we
have like 200 plus services offered and
they span through different domain or
different platform or different
technologies available within the azure
console portal now we're going to talk
about that later in this section so hold
your breath till we talk about it but
for now just know that we have like 200
plus services offered
by azure
let's now talk about different services
and azure starting with artificial
intelligence plus machine learning where
we have a lot of tools and technologies
so the wide variety of services
available on azure includes artificial
intelligence plus machine learning plus
analytic services to get and or to give
us a good visual of how the data or how
the application is performing or the
type of the category of data stored and
to read from the logs and variety of
compute services different vms with
different size and different operating
systems different containers available
different type of databases available a
lot of developer tools that are
available for us
and identity service to
manage our users in the azure cloud and
those users can be integrated or
federated with let's say google facebook
you know linkedin so there are some
external federation services they can be
used to integrate with our identity
system iots iot services iot tools and
technologies available and management
tools to manage the users creating
identity is one and then managing them
on top of it is a totally different
thing and we have tools technologies to
manage the users
cool services for data migration data
migration is now made simple tools and
technologies available for mobile
application development and i can plan
my own network in the cloud with the
networking services i can implement my
own security both azure provider and
third-party security services on azure
cloud that's now possible and a lot of
storage options available in the cloud
so these are just a glimpse of the big
list of services available in azure
cloud so that was a glimpse of what's
available in the cloud let's talk about
the services in a specific let's take
compute for example you know whenever
we're building a new application or
deploying existing ones
the azure compute service provides the
infrastructure we need to run and
maintain our application we can easily
tap in the capacity that azure cloud
service has and we can scale our compute
requirement on demand we can also
containerize our application we have the
option of choosing windows or linux via
machine and take the advantage of the
flexible options azure provides for us
to migrate our vms to azure and lot more
and these compute services also include
a full-fledged identity solution meaning
integration with active directory in the
cloud or an on-premises and lot more
let's look at some of the services that
this compute domain provides
some of the services the compute domain
provides are virtual machines and this
azure virtual machines gives us the
ability to develop and manage a virtual
computer environment or a virtualized
environment inside azure's cloud
environment that too in a virtual
private network now we will talk about
virtual private network at a later point
but as of now just uh know that there
are a lot of services available in azure
compute servers that we can get
benefited from we can always choose from
a very wide range of compute options
for example you know we have an option
to choose the operating system we have
the option to choose whether the system
should be in on premises or in the cloud
or do we want to maintain the
environment both in on premises and in
the cloud we have the option of choosing
the operating system whether we want to
use our own operating system with some
software attached to it or do you want
to go and buy the operating system from
the cloud from azure marketplace and
these are just a few of the options
available for us when we want to buy the
compute environment and these compute
environments are easily scalable meaning
we can easily scale our vm instances
from one instance to thousands of
virtual machines in a matter of minutes
or simply put in a couple of button
clicks and all these services are
available on a pay for what we use model
meaning there is no upfront cost we use
the service and then pay for the
services that we have used there is no
literal a long-term commitment when it
comes to using virtual machines in the
cloud and these most of the services are
built on a pay-per-minute billing basis
all right and at no point because of the
pay-per-minute billing model at no point
we will be overpaying for any of the
services that's that's attractive isn't
it now let's talk about batch service
now bad service is always independent
regardless of whether you choose windows
or linux it's going to run fairly well
and with batch servers we can take
advantage of the environment's unique
features and not only that in short the
batch service helps us to manage the
whole batch environment and also it
helps to schedule the jobs now this
azure batch service is actually runs on
a large scale parallel and high
performance computing because of that
batch jobs are highly efficient in azure
and when we run bad services this azure
batch creates a pool of computer nodes
and installs the needed applications
that we want to run and then it
schedules jobs to those individual nodes
in those pools as a customer there is no
need for us to install a cluster or
there is no need for us to install a
software that actually can use the jobs
or even to manage or even to scale those
infrastructure are the software because
everything is managed by azure and this
batch service is a platform as a service
there is no additional charge for using
this batch service except for i mean the
only charges that we'll be paying is for
the virtual machines that the service
uses and the storage that we will be
using of course and the networking
services that we would be using for this
batch service let's summarize this bad
service we have a choice of operating
system that we can pick and use and it
scales by itself now the alternative for
the batch would be queues but in queues
we'll have to pre-provision and pay for
the infrastructure even if we're not
using it but with a batch
we only pay for what we use and this bad
service helps us to manage the
application manage the scheduling as a
whole as if they are just one thing as
next thing in the compute domain let's
talk about this fabric service now this
fabric service is actually a distributed
system platform that helps us to package
deploy and manage a scalable and a very
reliable microservice and containers and
what does it help this azure fabric
service helps us or it helps the
developers and administrators so they
can avoid the complex infrastructure
problems and they can focus only on
implementing workloads or taking care of
their development taking care of their
application instead of spending time on
infrastructure so what service fabric
service fabric it provides runtime
capabilities and life cycle management
two applications that are composed of
micro services no infrastructure
management at all and with service
fabric we can easily scale the
application to tens or hundreds or even
to thousands of machines here machines
represent containers as next thing in
compute domain let's talk about virtual
machine scale set now this virtual
machine scale that it lets us to create
a group of identical load balanced vms i
just want to mention it again it helps
us to manage a group identical and load
balanced vms the number of instances or
the number of vm instances in an in a
scale set can increase or decrease
in response to
the demand or in response to a schedule
that we define you know the resources
needed on a monday morning is not the
same as that would be required on a
saturday or a sunday morning all right
and even within the day the resources
that would be needed in the beginning of
the business hour is not the resources
that would be needed at noon or you know
after eight or nine in the evening so
the demands could actually vary in the
environment and the skill set helps us
to take care of the varying demand or
take care of the different
infrastructure requirement at a
different schedule throughout the day
throughout the week throughout the month
or could be throughout the year as well
the skill set also allows us to provide
high availability to our applications
and it helps us to centrally manage
configure and update a large number of
vms as if they they are just one thing
now you might ask well virtual machines
are enough why would we need a virtual
machine skill set just like i said this
virtual machine skill set helps us with
a greater redundancy and improved
performance for our applications and
those applications can be accessed
through a load balancer that actually
distributes the request to the
application instances so in a nutshell
this virtual machine scale set uh it
helps us to create a large number of
identical virtual machines number one
and with skill set we can increase or
decrease the virtual machines with
virtual machine scale set we can
centrally manage and configure and
update a big group of vms and it's a
great use case when it comes to big data
or container workloads as next thing in
compute domain let's talk about cloud
services now this azure cloud service is
actually a platform as a service and
it's very friendly in fact it is
designed for applications that support
scalability or an application that
requires scalability or reliability and
and on top of it you want them to be
very inexpensive to operate so azure
cloud service provides all these so
where would this cloud service run well
it runs on a vm but it's a platform as a
service vms are infrastructure as a
service and when we run applications on
vm through cloud service it becomes
platform as a service so here is how you
got to be thinking with infrastructure
as a service like vms we first create
and configure the environment and then
we run applications on top of it let's
look at the responsibility the
responsibility for us in vm is that we
manage everything end to end like uh you
know deploying new patches picking the
versions of the operating system and
making sure they are intact and all that
stuff it's all managed by us but on the
contrary with platform as a service it's
i mean it's as if the environment is
already ready all that you have to do is
deploy your application in it and manage
the platform i mean manage the platform
not as an administrator because all the
administration is taken care by azure
like you know deploying new versions of
the operating system it's all handled by
the azure so we deploy the application
and we manage the application that's it
infrastructure management is handled by
azure so what does cloud service provide
this cloud service provides a platform
uh where we can uh
write the uh application code and we
don't have to worry about hardware
simply hand over the code and cloud
service takes care of it so no worry on
the hardware at all so responsibilities
like patching what do we do if something
crashes how do i update the
infrastructure how do i manage
the maintenance or the downtime in the
underlying infrastructure all that is
handled by azure it also provides a good
testing environment for us you know we
can simply run the code test it before
it's actually released to the production
i want to expand a bit on these testing
applications so this azure cloud service
it actually gives us a staging
environment for testing a new release
without it affecting the existing
release which actually reduces the
customer downtime so we can run the
application tested and anytime that's
ready for production all that's needed
for us to do to move it to production is
simply to swap the staging environment
into the production environment and the
old production environment will now
become the new staging environment where
we can
add more to it and then swap it back at
a later point so it kind of gives us
unswappable environment for testing our
applications and not only that it gives
us health monitoring alerts it helps us
to monitor the health and availability
of our application and there is a
dashboard we can benefit from when we
use azure cloud services and that shows
the key statistics all in one place and
we can also set up real-time alerts to
one when a service availability or a
certain metrics that we are concerned
about degrades as next thing in compute
domain let's talk about functions now
functions are serverless computing many
time if you heard about azure being
serverless a lot of time they are
referencing or the person who's talking
to you is referencing to serverless
computing or azure functions which is a
serverless computing service hosted on
microsoft azure the main motive of
a function is to accelerate and simplify
application development functions helps
us to run code on demand without
we need to pre-provision or manage any
azure infrastructure so azure functions
are script or a piece of code that gets
run in response to an event that you
want to handle so in short we can just
write a code that you need for a problem
at hand without actually worrying about
the whole application or the
infrastructure that will be running that
code and the best of all the best is
when we use functions we only pay for
the time that our code runs
so what does functions provide or what
does azure functions provide azure
functions allow users to build
applications using serverless
simple functions with the programming
language of our choice so the current
programming languages that are supported
is c sharp f sharp node.js java and php
so here we really don't have to worry
about provisioning or maintaining
servers if a code requires more resource
yes azure functions handles or it
provides the additional resources needed
by the code and the best part is we only
pay for the amount of time the functions
are running not the resources but the
amount of time the function is running
as next thing and moving to the new
domain let's talk about the container
domain in azure now the container domain
or the container service it allows us to
quickly deploy a production ready
kubernetes or a docker swamp cluster now
what's a container a container is a
standard unit of software that packages
of code and all its dependencies so the
applications run quickly and reliably
from one computing environment to
another it could be a testing uh to
staging to developing development
environment to staging to production or
from one production to another
production are on premises to cloud or
one cloud to another cloud vice versa
now imagine we had an option not to
worry about the vm and just focus on the
application well that's exactly what
containers helps us achieve so these
container instances enable us to focus
on applications and not worrying about
managing vms or not worrying about the
learning the new tools required to
manage the vms or even the deployment
and our applications that we create they
run in a container running in a
container is what helps us to achieve
all these not being able to manage or
not needing to manage the virtual
machines so these containers uh they can
be deployed into the cloud using a
single command if you're using a command
line interface and a couple of button
clicks if we are using the azure portal
and these containers are kept
lightweight but they are equally secure
as virtual machines let's talk about
container services next thing the
container service or
sometimes called as azure kubernetes
service it helps us to manage the
containers container is one thing and a
service that's used to manage the
container is another thing now this
kubernetes service or acs it helps us to
manage the containers so let's expand on
this a bit so this azure container
service or acs it it actually provides a
way to simplify the creation
configuration and management of a
cluster of virtual machines that are
pre-configured to run containerized
applications on top of them and
deploying them deploying these
containers might take like 15 to 20
minutes or deploying the virtual
machines that run containers in it might
take 15 to 20 minutes and once they are
provisioned we can actually manage them
by using simple ssh tunnel into them and
this acs when it runs application it
runs applications from docker images
what does that mean a docker images
makes sure that the applications the
container runs are fully portable images
are portable and
acs also helps us to orchestrate the
container environment not only that it
also helps us to ensure that these
applications that we run in containers
can be scaled to thousands or even tens
of thousands of containers so in a
nutshell managing an existing
application into a container and running
it using aks or acs is really easy or
that's what it is all about to make the
application management or migration easy
now managing the container based
architecture and we discussed that
containers could be tens or even tens of
thousands of containers so managing them
is made
simple using this container services and
even training of model using a large
data set in a complex and resource
intensive environment this aks helps us
to simplify
that environment all right as next thing
in container domain let's talk about
container registry we spoke about
registry a little bit when we spoke
about docker images so container
registry is a single place where we can
store our images which are docker images
when we use when we use containers it's
it's docker images that we use for our
image purposes so these container images
are a central registry that can be used
to ease container development by easing
the storage and management of container
images so there we can store all kinds
of images like
docker swamp or the images used in
docker swarm are in kubernetes
everything can be stored in container
registry in azure now anytime we store a
container image it provides us an option
for jio replication what that means is
that we can efficiently manage a single
registry replicated across multiple
regions
now these jio replication it actually
enables us to manage global deployments
assuming we are having an environment
that
requires a global deployment so it helps
us to manage global deployments as one
entity because we are geo-replicating we
would be updating we would be editing
one image and that image gets replicated
throughout
the global replication centers we would
have set up and so just one editing
would have actually edited the global
images and those global images would
have provisioned at the global
application so one edit replication and
then provisioning of the applications
global wide and this replication also
helps us to
helps us network latency because you
know anytime an application needs to
deploy it does not have to rely on a
single source which which can be reached
only through high latency network
because we have global replications
around the world anytime the application
wants to check back it would check back
uh the application which is in a very
nearby location for the application
itself
global replication means that we are
managing it as a single entity that's
being replicated across the multiple
regions in the globe as next thing in
our learning let's talk about
azure databases now these azure
databases are
rational in fact they have many flavors
in them we're going to look at different
flavors or sql nosql cache type of
database that has your offer so we're
going to learn one at a time or we're
going to learn one by one so this azure
sql database is a relational database in
fact it's a regional database as a
service it's managed by azure we don't
get to do a lot of management in it so
it's a rational database as a service uh
based on microsoft
sql server database engine and this
database is a high performance database
it's very reliable and it's very secure
as well and this high reliability high
performance and for this high security
really don't have to do anything it
comes along with it and it's managed by
azure and there are two things that i
definitely need to mention about azure
sql database that is it's an intelligent
service number one it's fully managed by
azure and it also has this one good
thing which is it has built-in
intelligence that learns app patterns
and adapts to maximize performance and
reliability and data protection of the
application that's something that's not
found in
many of the other cloud providers that
i'm aware of so i thought i'll mention
it so it uses built-in intelligence to
learn about the user's database patterns
and helps improve performance and
protection and migration or importing
data is very easy when it comes to azure
sql database so it can be readily or
immediately
used for analytic reporting and
intelligent applications in azure as
next thing let's talk about azure cosmo
db now azure cosmodb is a database
service that is for nosql type and
it's it's created to provide low latency
and
an application that scales dynamically
or that scales rapidly
now this azure cosmodb is an a globally
distributed service
and it's a multi-model
database this can be provisioned in a
click of a button that's all we got to
do if we need to provision and azure
cosmodb in the azure it helps with
scaling the database now we can
elastically and independently scale
throughput and storage across this
database and in any of the azure
geographic regions it provides a good
throughput it provides good latency it
provides good availability and
it provides or
azure promises a comprehensive sla that
no other database can offer that's the
best part about cosmodb so this cosmodb
was built with a global distribution in
mind and it's built
with the horizontal scale in mind and
all this we can use by only paying for
what we have used and remember the
difference between azure cosmodb and the
sql database is that azure cosmodb
supports nosql whereas sql doesn't
alright few other things about azure
cosmodb is it allows users to use key
value graph a column family and document
data it also gives users a number of ap
options like sql javascript mongodb and
and few others that you might want to
check the document at the time of
reading and the best part here is that
all that we mentioned we get to use only
by paying for the amount of storage and
throughput that are required and the
storage and the throughput can be
elastically scaled based on the
requirement of that r all right let's
talk about
that is cache discussion about azure
database won't be complete without we
talking about redis cache now redis
cache is a secure data cache it's also
called it's also sometimes called as
messaging broker that provides high
throughput and low latency access to
data for the applications now that is
cash is based on an a popular open
source caching product which is what is
sometimes called as that is cash now
what's the use case it's typically used
to cache to improve the performance and
scalability of a system that rely
heavily on backend data stores now
performance when we use zach is improved
by temporarily copying the frequently
accessed data to a fast storage located
very close to the application now with
redis cache this fast storage is located
in memory with redis cache instead of
being loaded from the actual disk in the
database itself now this redis cache can
also be used as an in-memory data
structure store not only that it can be
used as a distributed non-relational
database and a message broker so there
are a variety of use cases for this
redis cache and by using redis cache the
application performance is improved by
taking advantage of the low latency and
the height throughput performance that
this redis cache engine provides so to
summarize this redis cache when we use
redis cache data is stored in the memory
instead of the disk to ensure that there
is high throughput and low latency when
the application needs to read the data
it provides various levels of scaling
without any downtime or interference now
this redis cache is actually backed by
reduce server and it supports
a string hashes linked list and various
other data structures now let's talk
about security and identity services now
identity management in specific is a
process of authenticating first and then
authorizing using security principles
and not only that identity management
involves controlling information about
those principle identities you might ask
now what's a principle identity now
identity or principle identity are
services applications users groups and a
lot more the speciality about this
identity management is that it not only
helps authenticate and authorize
principles in cloud it also helps
authenticate and authorize principles or
resources on premises especially when
you run an hybrid cloud environment so
all these services and features that
this identity management helps us to get
additional level of validation like
identity management can provide
multi-factor authentication it can
provide access policies based on
condition a permit or deny based on
condition it can also monitor suspicious
activity and not only that he can also
report it it can also help generate
alerts for potential security issues and
in a way to mitigate it can send us an
alert so we can get involved and prevent
and a security accident from happening
so let's talk more about identity
management so some of the services under
security and identity management are
azure security center now this azure
security center provides
security management and threat
protection across the workloads in both
cloud and in the hybrid environment it
helps control user access and
application control to stop any
malicious activity if present it helps
us to find and fix vulnerabilities
before they can be even exploited it
integrates very well with analytic
methods that helps us to identify or it
gives us the intelligent to identify or
detect attacks and prevent them before
it can actually happen and it also works
seamlessly with hybrid environments so
you don't have to have one policy for
on-premises and one policy for the cloud
it's now a unified service both for
on-premises and the cloud the next
service and security and identity would
be key vault now a key vault is a
service or a feature that helps
safeguard the cryptographic keys and any
other secrets used by the cloud
applications and the services in other
words this azure keyword is a tool for
securely storing and accessing the
secrets of the environment i mean the
secret keys now a secret is anything
that you really want to have a very
tight control access like the
certificates like the passwords stuff
like that now if i tell you what keyword
actually solves that would actually
explain what keyword is now key vault is
used in secrets management it's helped
in securely storing the tokens the
passwords the certificates it helps in
key management and it really helps in
creating and controlling the encryption
keys that we would use to encrypt data
it helps in certificate management
talking about certification management
it helps us to easily provision manage
and deploy public and private ssl tls
certificates in azure and lot more so in
a nutshell this keyword it provides
users the ability to provision new walls
and keys in just a matter of minutes all
that in a single command or all that in
a couple of button clicks it also helps
users to centrally manage their keys
secrets and policies
next in the list let's talk about azure
active directory now azure active
directory it helps us to create
intelligent driven access policies to
limit resource usage and manage user
identities but what does that mean now
this azure active directory is a cloud
based active directory and identity
management service now azure active
directory combines and it's actually a
combination of the core directory
services plus application access
management plus identity protection
and one good thing about this azure in
fact there are a lot of good things but
especially when you're running hybrid
environments you might wonder well how
this azure active directory is going to
behave now this azure active directory
is built to work on on-premises and
cloud environment as well not only that
it also works seamlessly with mobile
applications as well
so in a nutshell this azure active
directory it acts as a central point of
identity and access management for our
cloud environment it also provides good
security solutions that protect against
unauthorized access of our app and the
data
now that we've discussed about security
and identity let's talk about the
management tools that azure has to offer
azure provides built-in management and
account governance tools that helps
administrators and
developers that helps them to keep the
resources secure and very compliant and
again it helps both in on premises and
in the cloud environment and these
management tools help us to monitor the
infrastructure monitor the applications
it also helps in provisioning and
configuring resources it also helps in
updating apps it helps in analyzing
threats taking backup of the resources
build
disaster recoveries
it also helps in applying policies and
conditions to automate our environment
we use azure management tools and it's
also used in cost control methods so
this azure management plays a wide role
across the azure services
and in the management tools first comes
the azure advisor now this azure advisor
it acts as a guide to educate us about
azure best practices it throws
recommendations that we can select on
the basis of the category of service and
it also provides the impact it can have
or the impact that would happen in our
environment if we follow the
recommendations given and
recommendations are
first one is the recommendations are
kind of templatized and it throws the
templatized recommendations not only
that it also provides customized
recommendations on the basis of the
configuration on the basis of our usage
patterns and these recommendations are
not hard it's not like something that it
recommends and then just leaves us
hanging there these recommendations
provided are very easy to follow very
easy to implement and see results you
can think of as your advisor as an a
very personalized cloud consultant that
helps you to follow best practices to
optimize our deployments it kind of
analyzes our resources our
configurations our usage and then it
recommends a solution for us that really
helps in improving the cost
effectiveness improving the performance
improving high availability and
improving security in our azure
environment so with this azure advisor
we can get a proactive
actionable and personalized best
practice recommendation now you don't
have to be an expert just follow the
azure advisor and your environment is
going to be good it also helps in
improve the performance security high
availability of our environment and also
it helps in bringing down the overall
azure spend and the best part is it's a
free service that analyzes our azure
usage and provides recommendations how
we can optimize our azure resource to
reduce cost and reduce cost at the same
time boost the performance helps in
strengthening the security and improve
the overall reliability of our
environment
next in the list would be network
watcher now this network watcher helps
users identify and gain insights in the
overall network performance and the
health of the overall environment now
these azure watchers provides enough
tools to monitor to diagnose to view the
metrics and to enable or disable logs
which means regenerate and collect the
logs for resources in the azure virtual
network so with network watcher you can
monitor and diagnose issues in
networking without even logging into the
virtual machines with just the logs
which are real time we can actually come
to a conclusion what could be wrong in a
certain resource in a vm or in a
database you know by just looking at the
logs and not only that it's used for
analytic or to gain some intelligence of
what's happening in our network we can
gain a lot of insight to the current
network traffic pattern using the
security group flow logs that this
network watcher offers it also helps in
investigating vpn connectivity issues
using detailed logs now you might or
might not know that you know vpn
troubleshooting requires both parties or
it involves two parties another person
the network administrator on this side
and the network administrator on the
other side and they will have to check
logs in their end and we'll have to
check logs and hour and stuff like that
but with the network watcher it kind of
takes it to the next level the logs
itself we could easily identify which
side is having the issue and suggest an
appropriate fix
and the next in the list would be
microsoft azure portal now this
microsoft azure portal it provides a
single unified console to perform
various number of activities like
building not only building managing and
monitoring the web applications that we
build now this portal can be used to
organize our environment or the
appearance of the environment or the
visual of the environment based on our
work style and using azure portal users
can control who gets to manage or access
the resources all from the azure portal
and this azure portal gives a very good
visibility on the spends that happen on
each resource right and if we can
customize it we can also identify spends
based on team spends based on days
spends based on department stuff like
that so it kind of gives us a good
visual of
where the money is spending or where is
the bill consumed within the azure
environment
next in the list would be azure resource
manager now azure resource manager
enables us to manage
the usage of the application resources
now we use resource manager to deploy
monitor and manage solution resources as
a group as if it's one single entity now
the infrastructure of our application is
typically made of various components
which includes virtual machine storage
virtual network
web app database servers some other
third-party services that we might use
in our environment and they are by
nature separate services but with azure
resource manager we don't see them as
different components or different
entities instead we see them as
related services in a group that
supports an application now we kind of
get the relation between them instead of
you know letting them spread azure
resource manager identifies the relation
between them and helps us to visually
see them all as one or single entity not
only that azure resource manager helps
or it ensures that the resources that we
provision are deployed at a constant
rate along with the other application
it also helps users to visually see
their resources and how they are
connected and that helps in managing the
resources lot better
resource group also is used to control
who can access the resources within the
users organization kind of gives you the
fine grained control over who gets to
access and who does not get access and
the last one in the management tools
would be automation and this automation
gives us the ability to automate
configure and install upgrades across
hybrid environments
it provides a cloud-based automation and
configuration service not only that this
can be applied for non-azure
environments as well which is
on-premises so some of the automation we
could do is process automation update
management automation configuration
features automation stuff like that and
this azure automation provides complete
control during the deployment operation
and also during the decommissioning of
the workloads and resources
with automation we can actually automate
a time consuming or
mundane or any task that's error prone
because of human errors those things can
be automated so irrespective of how many
times you run it it's gonna run the same
way and that really helps in reducing
the overall time and also the overhead
cost because a lot of the things are
automated which means it's human error
free which means the application is not
going to break and keep running for a
longer time with automation we can
actually build a good inventory of
operating system resources and
configuration items all in one place
with ease and this really helps in
tracking the changes and investigating
the issue let's say something happened
because we have automation because it's
logging the configuration changes it's
easy to track easy to identify easy to
identify what has changed lately that
has broken the environment go back and
fix it or kind of roll it back that
solves the problem and that actually
summarizes the azure management tools or
management services now let's talk about
the networking tools or the networking
services available in azure there are
variety of services especially
networking services that azure offers
and i'm sure it's going to be an
interesting one let's begin our
discussion with content delivery network
now the content delivery network in
short cdn it allows us to perform secure
and a very reliable content delivery not
only that it also helps in accelerating
the delivery time or in other words
reducing the delivery time also called
as low times it also helps in saving
bandwidth and increases in
responsiveness to the application let's
expand on this the content delivery
network is actually a distributed
network of servers that can efficiently
deliver web content to users now cdns
we're going to use the word cdn here
cdns store cached content on global edge
servers also called as
pops point of presence locations that
are very close to the end users so the
latency is minimized it's like taking a
copy of the data or taking a multiple
copy of the data and storing it in
different parts of the world and whoever
is requesting it the data gets delivered
to them from a server which is very
locally to them so this cdn offers
developers a global solution for
rapidly delivering high bandwidth
content to users by caching the content
in a strategically placed location which
is very near to them so these content
delivery networks it really helps in
handling that's one advantage you get
for content delivery network that's we
can handle spikes and heavy loads very
efficiently and we can also run analytic
against the locks that gets generated in
content delivery network which helps in
gaining good insight on the workflow and
what would be the future business need
for that application and this just like
a lot of other services this is on a pay
as you go type so you use the results
first and then you only pay for what you
have used
the next one in networking would be
express route now express route is
actually a circuit or a link that
provides an a direct private connection
to azure and because it's direct it
gives low latency link to azure it gives
good speed and reliability for the azure
data transfer it could be on premises to
azure so it gives very good speed it
gives increased reliability and low
latency for that connection let's expand
on this a bit
now this express route is an service
that actually provides and private
connection between microsoft data center
and infrastructure in our premises or in
a different collocation facility that we
might have now these express routes do
not go over the public internet and
because they don't go over the public
internet they offer a high security
reliability and speed and low latency
compared to the connections which are in
the internet because it's fast because
it's reliable because it has low latency
it can be used as an extension of our
existing data center you know users are
not going to feel the difference whether
they are accessing services from an
on-premises or in the cloud environment
because latency is minimized as much as
possible users are really not going to
see the difference and because it's a
private line and not an public internet
line it can be used to build hybrid
applications without compromising a
privacy or the performance now these
virtual private cloud these express
routes can be used for taking backups if
assume a backup going through the
internet that would be a nightmare if
you use express route for backups that's
going to be fast and imagine recovering
a data through the internet from the
cloud through the internet to the on
premises in a time of disaster that
would be the worst nightmare so these
express routes can be used not only to
backup but also to recover the data
because it provides good speed low
latency recovering the data is going to
be a lot sooner the next product or
service we're gonna discuss in
networking is azure dns
now azure dns allows us to host domain
name in azure and these domain names
come with an exceptional performance and
availability now azure dns is used to
set up and manage dns zones and records
for our domain name in the cloud now
this azure dns is a service for dns just
like the name says and it provides name
resolution by using azure's
infrastructure and by using this domain
we can actually manage the dns ourselves
through the azure portal with the same
credential imagine having a dns provider
which does not even belong in rit
imagine that environment you know we
would have a separate portal to manage
the dns environment now those are gone
and now we can actually manage the dns
in the very same azure portal where we
use the rest of the other services and
this azure dns very much integrates with
other dna service providers it uses a
global network of name servers to
provide fast response to dns queries and
these domains are having additional
availability compared to the other
domain service providers availability
promises these are going to have more
availability than the rest because most
of the servers are maintained by a
microsoft and it helps resolve sooner it
helps re-syncing let's say a server
fails it kind of helps re-syncing with
the rest of the servers so all the
microsoft's environment all the
microsoft global network of name servers
kind of ensures that our domain names
are resolved properly not only properly
but also are available most of the time
all right next in the list in networking
services is virtual network i'm sure
this is going to be very interesting and
i'm sure you're going to like it so this
networking or virtual networking in
azure it actually allows us to set up
our own private cloud in the public
cloud it gives us an isolated and highly
secure environment for our application
let's expand on this on this azure
virtual network helps us to provision
azure virtual machines and it helps us
to securely communicate with other
on-premises and internet networks it
also helps in controlling the traffic
that flows through or flows in and out
of this virtual network to other virtual
networks and to the internet now this
azure a virtual network sometimes called
as v-net is actually a representation of
our own network in the cloud it's
actually a logical isolation of the
azure cloud dedicated to our
subscription all our environments are
provisioned in a v-net that is separate
from another customers we nets that way
we have that logical separation there so
this virtual network can also be used to
provision a vpns in the cloud so we can
connect the cloud and the on-premises
infrastructure and lot more especially
in a environment where we have hybrid
environment surely we will be using
virtual network because that's going to
require a vpn for secure data transfer
in and out of the cloud and in and out
of the on-premises environment
all right so it kind of gives us an
boundary for all the resources so all
the traffic between the azure resources
they kind of logically stay in between
or logically stay within the azure
virtual network and here we can design
the network it's given over to us you
know you can pick the ip you can pick
the routing you can pick the subnet and
a lot of freedom is given or i would say
a lot of control on how the network is
designed it's not like something that's
already cooked and we only get to use it
no we can actually build the network
from the scratch we can pick the ip
address that we like we can pick you
know which subnet needs to communicate
with the other subnet stuff like that
and like i said if you are using hybrid
environment you definitely would be
requiring a virtual network because it
helps connect the on-premises and the
cloud in a secure fashion using vpn the
last product we're going to discuss in
networking is a load balancer this load
balancer actually provides application a
good availability and a good network
performance so how does it work it
actually works by load balancing the
traffic to and from the virtual machine
and the cloud resources not only that it
also load balances between cloud and
across premises virtual networks with
azure load balancer we can actually
scale our application and create high
availability for our services which
means our application will be available
most of the time if any of the server
goes dead the server does not get
traffic what happens if the server gets
traffic user is going to experience
downtime what happens if the server does
not get traffic user won't experience
any downtime the connection is shifted
to an healthy service so the user
experiences uptime all the time so this
load balancer supports inbound and
outbound scenarios and it provides low
latency it gives high throughput of the
data transfer and we can actually scale
up the flow of the tcp and udp
connections from hundreds to thousands
to even millions because we have a load
balancer now in between the user and the
application so how does it operate this
load balancer actually receives the
traffic and it load balances the traffic
to the back end pool of instances
connected to it according to the rule
and the health probe that we set that's
how it maintains high availability so
what does load balancer help it helps in
creation of high available scalable
application in the cloud in minutes it
can be used to automatically scale the
environment with the increasing
application traffic and one feature of
load balancer is to check the health of
the user's application instance and it
removes or it stops sending the request
to the unhealthy instance and kind of
shifts that connection to the healthy
instance that way a user or a connection
does not get stuck with an instance
that's not healthy that's all that you
need to know about the networking
services now let's talk about the
storage services or the storage domain
in azure now azure storage in general is
a microsoft manage service providing
cloud storage which basically is highly
available secure durable scalable and
redundant because it's all managed by
azure we don't get to manage a lot of it
and these azure storages are a group of
storage services they capture different
needs and the storage products include
azure blobs which is actually an object
storage it includes
azure data lake it includes azure files
as you see it in it includes azure
queues it includes azure tables and lot
more but let's start our discussion with
azure store simple azure store simple is
an hybrid cloud storage solution that
actually lowers the cost of storage to
nearly 60 percent of how much you'd be
actually spending without using it so
azure simple storage or store simple is
an integrated storage solution that
manages the storage task between
on-premises and the cloud storage what i
really like about azure is that it's
built around a hybrid environment in
might there are a lot of other cloud
providers that are there where running
and hybrid environment is a big
challenge you know it has some
compatibility you won't be able to find
an hybrid or a on-premises and cloud
solution for your need stuff like that
but with azure especially when it comes
to storage a lot of the things that
we're gonna see it clearly is designed
with hybrid environment in mind all
right so let's come back and talk about
store simple so store simple is a very
efficient cost effective and a very
easily manageable san storage area
networking solution in the cloud i
thought i'll throw in this information
the reason why it got store simple is
really because it uses store simple 8000
series devices which are used in azure
data center and this stores simple or
simple storage it comes along with
storage steering to manage the stored
data across the various storage media so
the current the very current data is
actually stored in on-premises on
solid-state drives and data that is used
less frequently is stored in hdds or
hard disk drives and the data that
requires archived or that needs to be
archived very old data let's say less
frequently used data candidate for
archive they are actually pushed to the
cloud so you see how this storage
steering automatically happens in store
simple and one another cool feature of
store simple is that it enables us to
create an on-demand and scheduled
backups of data and then store the data
locally or in the cloud and these
backups are actually taken in the form
of incremental snapshot which means that
they can be created and restored quickly
it's not a complete backup it's an
incremental backup and these cloud
snapshots they can be critically
important when there is a disaster and
when there is a disaster recovery
scenario because these snapshots can be
called in and they can be put on storage
systems and then they become the actual
data so recovering is faster if you have
proper scheduled backups or if you have
frequent backups and this storage simple
it really helps in easing our backup
mechanism which means it kind of eases
our disaster recovery steps or
procedures as well so this is so simple
it can be used to automate data
management data migration data movement
data turing across the enterprise both
in cloud and on-premises it actually
improves the compliance and accelerates
the disaster recovery for our
environment and if there is one thing
that's increasing every new day in our
environment that would be storage and
this store simple addresses that need
and we really don't have to pre-plan or
think in deep or having a proper storage
because now we have a simple storage
available in the cloud and moreover it's
on a pay-as-you-go type so not much
pre-planning on storage is needed yes
there will be a need but not as much as
i would without the cloud or without the
simple storage and the next service
under storage that we would like to
discuss is the data lake store this data
lake store or storage it's a cost
effective solution for big data
analytics in specific so let's expand
this so this data lake storage is an
enterprise-wide repository for big data
analytic workload now that's the major
service that's dependent on this data
lake store and this data lake enables us
to capture data of any size of any type
and of any injection speed and it kind
of collects them in one single space or
in one single place for operational
efficiency i mean operational efficiency
and for analytic purpose hadoop in azure
is very dependent on this data lake
storage and this
data lake store is designed with
performance for analytics in mind so
anytime you think of or anytime you're
using analytic in the cloud or anytime
you're using hadoop in the cloud in
azure we are definitely using or we will
be to the most part or the normal
procedure or the right storage to pick
would be data lake store in azure it's
designed with security in mind so
anytime we use azure storage we can be
rest assured that we are using storage
from within a data center which has or
which was built with security in mind so
this data store also uses azure blob
storage behind the scenes for global
scale durability and for performance
let's talk about blob storage now blob
storage provides large amount of storage
and scalability now this blob storage is
the object storage solution for azure
cloud let's expand a bit on blob storage
azure blob storage is microsoft offering
for object storage now this blob storage
is optimized for storing massive amount
of unstructured data which could be text
or binary data it's designed and it's
optimized for rapid reads if i explain
to you on what scenarios we would be
using blob storage that might help you
get a good understanding of what blob
storage is so it's help or its design as
of now it's being used in many idea
environments to serve images or
documents directly to the browser it
helps in storing files for distributed
access a lot of features can fetch data
from azure blob storage and it currently
helping users stream video and audio
it's currently being used for writing
log files it's currently being used to
store data as backup and restore at a
later point in times of disaster
recovery it also is used as an archiving
storage in a lot of cloud id
environments it's widely used in storing
analytic data not only storing but also
running analytic query against the data
stored in it so that's a wide use case
for blob storage not only that in
addition to all that we mentioned it
also supports versioning so anytime
somebody updates and data a new version
gets created which means at any point i
can roll back as in when needed and it
provides a lot of flexibility on
optimizing the user's storage need it
also supports tiering of the data so
based on need when i actually explore i
would find a lot of options i can pick
from that uh you know suits to my unique
storage environment or unique storage
need and like i said it stores
unstructured data and this unstructured
data is available for customers through
rest based object storage environment
the next product and storage service
would be queue storage now queue storage
provides durable cues for large volume
cloud services it's a very simple and a
cost effective durable messaging queue
for large workers let's expand this
queue storage for a moment now this
queue storage is a service for storing
large amount of messages that can be
accessed from anywhere in the world
through http and https calls a single
queue or a single cube message can be up
to like 24 kb in size and a single queue
can contain millions of such 24 kb in
size messages and how much can it hold
it can hold up to the total capacity of
the storage account itself so that's
kind of easy to translate how much would
it hold and this azure queue storage it
provides an messaging solution between
applications and components in the cloud
what does it help it helps in designing
an application for scale it helps in
decoupling the application so you know
it's not very dependent or sometimes
it's not at all dependent on the other
application because now we have a queue
in between which kind of translates or
which kind of connects or which kind of
decouples both the environment now we
have a queue in between both the
environment can scale up or scale down
independently the next in the storage
service would be file storage let's talk
about file storage now these azure files
provide secure simple and managed cloud
file shares now with file share in the
cloud it actually extends the user
servers on premises performance and
capacity and lot of familiar tools for
the cloud file share management can be
used along with the file storage that
we're talking about so let's expand a
bit on file storage now this azure files
or azure file storage offers a fully
managed file shares in the cloud that
can be accessed via the smb protocol
server message block protocol now this
azure file shares can be mounted
concurrently by cloud or in on-premises
deployments a lot of operating systems
are compatible with it windows are
compatible linux is compatible mac os is
compatible in addition to all this being
able to run on premises and on the cloud
or being able to access from on premises
and on the cloud it can also offer cache
for caching the data and keeping it
locally so it's immediately available
when needed so that's some additional
feature i would say that's an advanced
feature that it offers compared to the
other file shares available in the
market let's talk about table storage
let's talk about table storage now table
storage is a no sql key value pair
storage for quick deployments with the
large semi-structured data sets the
difference between one important thing
to note with table storage is that it
has a flexible data schema and also it's
highly available let's expand a bit on
table storage so anytime you want to
pick a schema less a nosql type table
storage is the one we'll end up picking
it provides an key pair attribute
storage with a schema-less design this
table storage is very fast and very cost
effective for many of the applications
and for the same amount of
data it's a lot cheaper when you compare
it with the traditional sql data or data
storage so some of the things that we
can store in the table storage are of
course they're going to be flexible data
sheets such as user data for web
application address books device
information and other types of metadata
for our service requirements and it can
have any number of tables up to the
capacity limit of the storage account
now this is not possible with sql this
is only possible with nosql especially
with table storage in azure explanation
of storage really concluded the length
and breadth of the explanation this ceo
was giving his id personal but this id
personal is not done with it yet he
still has a question even after this
lengthy discussion and his question was
well there are a lot of other cloud
providers available what made you
specifically choose azure i mean from
the kind of question that he asked we
can say that he is very curious and he
definitely had asked a very thoughtful
question so his ceo went on and started
to explain about the uh other
capabilities of azure or how it
kind of outruns the rest of the cloud
providers so he started or he again
started his discussion but from a
different angle now so he started to
explain what are the capabilities or how
azure is better than the competitors so
he started with explaining the platform
as a service capabilities and i'm going
to tell you what the ceo told his id
person so this platform as a service or
in platform as a service the
infrastructure management is completely
taken care by uh microsoft allowing
users to focus completely on the
innovation no more infrastructure
management responsibilities go and focus
on innovation that's that's a fancy way
of saying it when we buy platform as a
service that's what we get we can
contribute our time on innovation and
not just maintaining the infrastructure
and azure especially
is a dot-net friendly azure supports
dotnet programming language and it has
or it is built or designed or it is
optimized to work with old and the new
applications deployed using.net
programming framework so if your
application is a dotnet most of the time
you would end up picking azure i mean if
you try to compare most of the time you
would end up picking azure as your cloud
service provider and the security
offerings that azure offers is it's
designed based on the security
development uh life cycle which is an
industry leading assurance
process when we buy services from azure
it assures that the environment is
designed based on security development
life cycle and like i mentioned many
times in the past and i would like to
mention it again azure has well thought
about the hybrid environments which a
lot of other cloud providers have failed
so it's very easy to set up and hybrid
environment to migrate the data or not
to migrate the data and still run a
hybrid environment they work seamlessly
with the azure because azure provides
seamless connection across on-premises
data centers and the public cloud it
also has a very gentle learning curve if
you look at the documentation it's
picture rich and the documentations are
neat and clear would really it would
encourage you to learn more it would
encourage you to think and imagine and
try easily get a grasp of how services
work so it has a very gentle learning
curve azure allows the utilization of
technologies that several businesses
have used for years so there is a big
history behind it it has a very gentle
learning curve the certifications the
documentations at the stage by stage
certification levels it's all very
gentle learning curve which is generally
missing in other cloud service providers
now this would really impress the ctos
or people working in finance and
budgeting if an organization is already
using microsoft software they can
definitely go and avail or be bold and
ask for a discount that can reduce the
overall azure spending in other words
overall a pricing of the azure so that's
what helped or they are the information
that helped the ceo pick azure as his
cloud service provider and then the ceo
goes on and talks about the different
companies that are currently using azure
and they are definitely using azure for
a reason like pixar boeing samsung
easyjet xerox bmw 3m they are major
multinational multi-billion companies
they rely run
operate their id in azure and this ceo
has a thought that his id person is
still not very convinced unless and
until he shows him a visual of how easy
things are in azure so he goes on and
explains about a practical application
of azure which is what exactly i'm going
to show you as well all right a quick
project on building an azure app using
or building a dotnet application
in azure web app and making it connect
to an sql database will solidify all the
knowledge that we have gained so far so
this is what we're gonna do i have an
azure account open as you see logged in
and everything is fresh here let me go
to resource group there's nothing in
there it's it's kind of fresh all right
i'm logged in and this is what we're
gonna do so we're gonna create an
application like this which is nothing
but an to-do application a to-do list
application which is going to run from
the web app get information from us and
save it in the database that's connected
to it so you can already see it's a
two-tiered application web and db all
right so let me go back to my azure
account the first thing is to create an
resource group let's give it an a
meaningful name let's call it azure
simply learn all right and it's going to
be a free trial and the location
pick one that's nearest to you or you
know wherever you want to launch your
application now for this use case i'm
going to pick central us and create
it's going to take a while to get
created there you go it's created it's
called azure simply learn now what do we
need we need an web app and and a
separate sql database let's first get
our web app running so go to app
services and then click on add it's not
the web app plus sql that we want we
want web app alone for this
example so let's create and web app
give it a quick name let's call it
azure
simply learn
the subscription is free trial and i'm
going to use my existing resource group
a resource group that we created
sometime back it's going to run out of
windows and we're going to publish
the code all set we can create it all
right while this is running
let me create my database
right sql database
create a database
give it a name let's call it azure
simply learn db
put it in our existing resource group
that we created it's going to be a blank
database all right and it's going to
require some
settings like
the name of the server
and the admin login the password that
goes along and in which location this is
going to be created the server name is
going to be azure simply learn db that's
the server name and the admin login can
be
what can be the admin login name let's
see
so let's call it simply learn that's my
admin login name
and let me pick a password
click on create so what have we done so
far we have created an web app and we
have created an
a database in
the resource group that we have created
so if i go to resource group it's going
to take some time before things show up
so if i go to my resource group i only
have one resource group as of now azure
simply learn and there i have a bunch of
resources
being created and that's still being
created right in the meantime
i have my application right here that's
running out of uh or that's in visual
studio as of now right so once
the infrastructure is set and ready in
the azure console uh we're gonna go back
to visual studio feed these inputs in
the visual studio so the code knows what
the database is the the credentials to
log into the database stuff like that so
we're going to feed those information in
visual studio by that we're actually
feeding it into the application and then
we're going to run it from there
deploying this application takes quite a
while
we really got to be patient right now we
have all the resources that we need for
the application to run here is my
database and here is my app service
there's one more thing we need to do
that is
create and firewall exception rule so
one more thing needed is to create and
firewall exception
rule right so the application is going
to run from my local desktop and it's
going to connect to the
database right so let's add an exception
rule by simply adding the client id it's
going to pick my ip the ipf laptop i'm
using as of now and it's going to create
an exception to access the
database so that's done now we can go
back to our visual studio i already have
a couple of apps running or a couple of
configurations pushed from
a visual studio i'm going to clean that
up
if you're doing it for the first time
you may not need to do this
all right so let's start from the
scratch
this is very similar to
how you would be doing
in your environment all right so we're
going to
select an existing azure app service now
before that i have logged in as you can
see i have logged in
with my credentials so it's gonna pull
few things automatically from my azure
account so
in this case i'm gonna use an existing
azure app so select existing and then
click on publish
all right if you recall these are the
very same resources that we created a
while back
all right we have clicked on save and
it's
running kind of validating the code
and it's going to come up with an
url now initially the url is
not going to work because we haven't
mapped the application to the database
that would be the next thing
all right so the app has been
published and it's running from my
web app as of now
it's going to throw an error
like you see
it's throwing an error that's because we
haven't mapped
the app and the db together so let's do
that
all right let's do that so let's go to
server explorer
this is where
we're going to see our
databases that we have created now let's
quickly verify that
go back to
the resource group
all right appropriate service group
which is right here
and here i have my
database azure
simply learn
database
all right it has some issues connecting
to my database give me a quick moment
let's fix it
all right so
we'll have to map the database into this
application
all right so let's go to the solution
explorer click on
publish
and a page like this gets shown and from
here we can go to configure
here is our a web app all right with all
its credentials let's validate the
connection number one
all right and then click on next
this is my db connection string right
which the app is going to use to connect
to my db now if you recall rdb was uh
azure simply learn db and that's not
being shown here
so let's fix that
right so let's fix that
click on configure
and here
let's put our db servers
url now before that let's change this to
sql server
all right and then in here
put the
db's
url so go back to azure
here is my
db or
server's name
put that here
right the username to connect to the
server that's
right here
put that in
and the password
to connect to the server let's put that
in
all right it's trying to connect
to our azure
portal or the azure infrastructure and
here is my
database if you recall it's azure
sldb that's the name of the database
let's test the connection
connection is good click on ok
so now it's showing up correctly azure
simply learn db that's the name of the
database
that'll be created
now it's configured
all right let's modify the data
connections
right let's map it to the appropriate
database again
all right so our name of the database is
azure simply learn db
and then
it's going to be
sql
server that's the data source
the
username is simply learn
and the password is
what we have given in the beginning
all right let's validate
the connection it's good click ok
now we're all set
and ready to publish
our application
again now the application knows how to
connect uh to the database we have
educated it with the uh
the correct connection strings the dns
name
the username and the password for the
application to connect to the database
so visual studio is building this
project and once it is up and running
will be prompted with an url
to connect and
anytime
we put or we give inputs to the url
that's going to
receive the input and save it in the
database
all right so here is my to-do list app
and i can start
creating to-do list for myself all right
so i have items already listed
i can create an entry and these entries
get stored in
the
in the database i can create another
entry
you know take the doc for a walk that's
gonna get stored i can create another
entry
uh book tickets for
uh scientific
exhibition
and that's gonna receive and put that in
the database and that concludes our
session so through this session we saw
how i can use azure services to create a
web app and
connect that to the db instance and how
those two services which are
decoupled by default which are separate
by default how i can you know use the
connection strings to make connection
between the app server and the database
and be able to create an working app hi
guys i'm raul from simply learn and
today i'd like to welcome you all to the
greatest debate of the century today i
am joined by two giants of the cloud
computing industry they'll be going head
to head with each other to decide who
amongst them is better it's going to be
one hello fight now let's meet our
candidates on my left we have aws who's
voiced by a picture hi guys
and on my right we have microsoft azure
who's voiced by anjali hey there
so today we'll be deciding who's better
on the basis of their origin and the
features they provide their performance
on the present day and comparing them on
the basis of pricing market sharing
options free tier and instance
configuration
now let's listen to their opening
statements let's start with aws
launched in 2006 aws is one of the most
commonly used cloud computing platforms
across the world companies like adobe
netflix airbnb htc pinterest and spotify
have put their faith in aws for their
proper functioning it also dominates the
cloud computing domain with almost 40
percent of the entire market share so
far nobody's even gotten close to
beating that number aws also provides a
wide range of services that covers a
great number of domains domains like
compute networking storage migration and
so much more
now let's see what azure has to say
about that azure was launched in 2010
and is trusted by almost 80 percent of
all fortune 500 companies the best of
the best companies in the world choose
to work only with azure azure also
provides its services to more regions
than any other cloud service provider in
the world azure covers 42 regions
already and 12 more are being planned to
be made azure also provides more than
100 services spanning a variety of
domains now that the opening statements
are done let's have a look at the
current market status of each of our
competitors this is the performance
route here we have the stats for the
market share of aws azure and other
cloud service providers this is for the
early 2018 period amazon web services
takes up a whopping 40 percent of the
market share closely followed by hdr at
and other cloud services adding 30
this 40 indicates most organizations
clear interest in using aws we are
number one because of our years of
experience and trust we've created among
our users
sure you're the market leader but we are
not very far behind let me remind you
more than 80 percent of the fortune 500
companies trust azure with their cloud
computing needs so it's only a match of
time before azure takes the lead the
rest of the 30 percent that is in aws or
azure accounts to the other cloud
service providers like google cloud
platform rackspace ibm software and so
on now for our next round the comparison
round first we'll be comparing pricing
we'll be looking at the cost of a very
basic instance which is a virtual
machine of two virtual cpus and eight
gbs of ram for aws this will cost you
approximately
0.0928 us dollars per hour and for the
same instance in azure it will cost you
approximately 0.096 us dollars per hour
next up let's compare market share and
options as i mentioned before aws is the
undisputed market leader when it comes
to the cloud computing domain taking up
40 percent of the market share by 2020
aws is also expected to produce twice
its current revenue which comes close to
44 billion dollars not to mention aws is
constantly expanding its already strong
roaster of more than 100 services to
fulfill the shifting business
requirements of organizations all that
is great really good for you but the
research company gardner has released a
magic quadrant that you have to see you
see the competition is now neck-to-neck
between azure and aws it's only a matter
of time before azure can increase from
its 30 market share and surpass aws this
becomes more likely considering how all
companies are migrating from aws to
azure to help satisfy their business
needs azure is not far behind aws when
this comes to services as well azure
service offerings are constantly updated
and improved on to help users satisfy
their cloud computing requirement
now let's compare aws and azure's free
offerings aws provides a significant
number of services for free helping
users get hands-on experience with the
platform products and services the free
tier services fall under two categories
services that will remain free forever
and the others that are valid only for
one year the always free category offers
more than 20 services for example amazon
sns sqs cloud watch etc and the valid
fourier category offers approximately 20
services for example amazon s3 ec2
elastic cache etc
both types of services have limits on
the usage for example storage number of
requests compute time etc but users are
only charged for using services that
fall under the valid for a year category
after a year of their usage
a show provides a free tier as well it
also provides services that belong to
the categories of free for a year and
always free there are about 25 plus
always free services provided by azure
these include app service functions
container service active directory and
lots more and as of the valid for a year
there are eight services offered there's
linux or windows virtual machines blob
storage sql database and few more azure
also provides the users with credits of
200 us dollars to access all their
services for 30 days now this is a
unique feature that azure provides where
users can use their credits to utilize
any service of a choice for the entire
month now let's compare instance
configuration the largest instance that
aws offers is that of a whopping 256 gbs
of ram and 16 virtual cpus the largest
that azure offers isn't very far behind
either 224 gbs of ram and 16 virtual
cpus and now for the final round now
each of our contestants will be shown
facts and they have to give explanations
for these facts we call it the rapid
fire round first we have features in
which aws is good and azure is better
aws does not cut down on the features it
offers its users however it requires
slightly more management on the user's
part
azure goes slightly deeper with the
services that fall under certain
categories like platform as a service
and infrastructure as a service
next we have hybrid cloud where aws is
good and azure is better okay although
aws did not emphasize on hybrid cloud
earlier they are focusing more on
technology now azure has always
emphasized on hybrid cloud and has
features supporting it since the days of
its inception for developers aws is
better and azure is good of course it's
better because aws supports integration
with third-party applications well azure
provides access to data centers that
provide a scalable architecture for
pricing both aws and azure are at the
same level it's good for aws because it
provides a competitive and constantly
decreasing pricing model and in the case
of azure it provides offers that are
constantly experimented upon to provide
its users with the best experience and
that's it our contestants have finished
giving their statements now let's see
who won surprisingly nobody each cloud
computing platform has its own pros and
cons choosing the right one is based
entirely on your organization's
requirements hi guys today we've got
something very special in store for you
we're going to talk about the best cloud
computing platform available amazon web
services uh rahul i think you said
something wrong here the best cloud
computing platform is obviously google
cloud platform no it isn't aws has more
than 100 services that span a variety of
domains all right but google cloud
platform has cheaper instances what do
you have to say about that well i guess
there's only one place we can actually
discuss this a boxing ring so guys i'm
apeksha and i will be google cloud
platform and i'm rahul i'll be aws so
welcome to fight night this is aws
versus gcp the winner will be chosen on
the basis of their origin and the
features they provide their performance
in the present day and comparing them on
the basis of pricing market share and
options the things they give you for
free and instance configuration now
first let's talk about aws aws was
launched in 2004 and is a cloud service
platform that helps businesses grow and
scale by providing them services in a
number of different domains these
domains include compute database storage
migration networking and so on a very
important aspect about aws is its years
of experience now aws has been in the
market a lot longer than any other cloud
service platform which means they know
how businesses work and how they can
contribute to the business growing also
aws has over 5.1 billion dollars of
revenue in the last quarter this is a
clear indication of how much faith and
trust people have in aws they occupy
more than 40 percent of the market which
is a significant chunk of the cloud
computing market they have at least 100
services that are available at the
moment which means just about every
issue that you have can be solved with
an aws service now that was great but
now can we talk about gcp i hope you
know that gcp was launched very recently
in 2011 and it is already helping
businesses significantly with a suite of
intelligent secure and flexible cloud
computing services it lets you build
deploy and scale applications websites
services on the same infrastructure as
google the intuitive user experience
that gcp provides with dashboards
wizards is way better in all the aspects
tcp has just stepped in the market and
it is already offering a modest number
of services and the number is rapidly
increasing and the cost for a cpu
instance or regional storage that gcp
provides is a whole lot cheaper and you
also get a multi-regional cloud storage
now what do you have to say on that i'm
so glad you asked let's look at present
day in fact let's look at the cloud
market share of the fourth quarter of
2017. this will tell you once and for
all that aws is the leader when it comes
to cloud computing amazon web services
contributes 47
of the market share others like
rackspace or verizon cloud contribute 36
microsoft azure contributes 10 the
google cloud platform contributes four
percent and ibm software contributes
three percent forty seven percent of the
market share is contributed by aws you
need me to convince you any more wait
wait wait all that is fine but we only
started a few years back and have
already grown so much in such a less
span of time haven't you heard the
latest news our revenue is already a
billion dollars per quarter wait for a
few more years and the world shall see
and aws makes 5.3 billion dollars per
quarter it's going to take a good long
time before you can even get close to us
yes yes we'll see now let's compare a
few things for starters let's compare
prices for aws a compute instance of two
cpus in 8gb ram costs approximately 68
us dollars now a computer instance is a
virtual machine in which you can specify
what operating system ram or storage you
want to have for cloud storage it costs
2.3 cents per gb per month with aws you
really want to do that because gcp wins
this hands down let's take the same
compute instance of two cpus with 8 gb
ram it will cost approximately 50
dollars per month with gcp and as per my
calculations that's a 25
annual cost reduction when compared to
aws talking about cloud storage costs it
is only 2 cents per gb per month with
gcp what else do you want me to say
let's talk about market share and
options now aws is the current market
leader when it comes to cloud computing
now as you remember we contribute at
least 47 of the entire market share aws
also has at least 100 services available
at the moment which is a clear
indication of how well aws understands
businesses and helps them grow yeah
that's true but you should also know
that gcp is steadily growing we have
over 60 services that are up and running
as you can see here and a lot more to
come it's only a matter of time when we
will have as many services as you do
many companies have already started
adopting gcp as a cloud service provider
now let's talk about things you get for
free with aws you get access to almost
all the services for an entire year with
usage limits now these limits include an
hourly or by the minute basis for
example with amazon ec2 you get 750
hours per month you also have limits on
the number of requests to services for
example with aws lambda you have 1
million requests per month now after
these limits across you get charged
standard rates with gcp you get access
to all cloud platform products like
firebase the google maps api and so on
you also get 300 in credit to spend over
a 12-month period on all the cloud
platform products and interestingly
after the free trial ends you won't be
charged unless you manually upgrade to a
paid account now there is also the
always free version for which you will
need an upgraded billing account here
you get to use a small instance for free
and 5gb of cloud storage any usage above
this always free usage limits will be
automatically built at standard rates
now let's talk about how you can
configure instances with aws the largest
instance that's offered is of 128 cpus
and 4 tvs of ram now other than the on
demand method like i mentioned before
you can also use spot instances now
these are the situations where your
application is more fault tolerant and
can handle an interruption now you pay
for the spot price which is effective at
a particular r now these part prices do
fluctuate but are adjusted over a period
of time the largest instance offered
with google cloud is 160 cpus and 3.75
tbs ram like spot instances of aws
google cloud offers short-lived compute
instances suitable for bad jobs and
fault tolerant workloads they are called
as preemptable instances so these
instances are available at eighty
percent off on on demand price hence
they reduce your compute engine costs
significantly and unlike aws these come
at a fixed price google cloud platform
is a lot more flexible when it comes to
instance configuration you simply choose
your cpu and ram combination of course
you can even create your own instance
types this way before we wrap it up
let's compare on some other things as
well telemetry it's a process of
automatically collecting periodic
measurements from remote devices for
example gps gcp is obviously better
because they have superior telemetry
tools which help in analyzing services
and providing more opportunities for
improvement when it comes to application
support aws is obviously better since
they have years of experience under
their bed aws provides the best support
that can be given to the customers
containers are better with gcp a
container is a virtual process running
in user space as kubernetes was
originally developed by google gcp has
full native support for the tool other
cloud services are just fine tuning a
way to provide kubernetes as a service
also the containers help with
abstracting applications from their
environment they originally run it the
applications can be deployed easily
regardless of their environment when it
comes to geographies aws is better since
they have a head start of a few years
aws in this span of time has been able
to cover a larger market share and
geographical locations now it's time for
the big decision so who's it going to be
yeah who is it going to be gcp or aws i
think i'm going to go for
choosing the right cloud computing
platform is the decision that's made on
the basis of the user or the
organization's requirement aws azure and
gcp are three of the world's largest
cloud service providers but how are they
different from each other let's find out
hey guys i'm rahul and i'll be
representing amazon web services i'm
chinmayi and i'll be representing
microsoft azure and i am shruti and i'll
be representing google cloud platform so
welcome to this video on aws versus
azure vs gcp talking about market share
amazon web services leads with around 32
of the worldwide public cloud share
azure owns up to 16 of the worldwide
market share and gcp owns around 9 of
the world's market share let's talk
about each of these service providers in
detail aws provides services that enable
users to create and deploy applications
over the cloud these services are
accessible via the internet aws being
the oldest of the lot was launched in
the year 2006. azure launched in 2010 is
a computing platform that offers a wide
range of services to build manage and
deploy applications on the network using
tools and frameworks
launched in the year 2008 gcp offers
application development and integration
services for its end users in addition
to cloud management it also offers
services for big data machine learning
and iot now let's talk about
availability zones these are isolated
locations within data center regions
from which public cloud services
originate and operate talking about aws
they have 69 availability zones within
22 geographical regions this includes
regions in the united states south
america europe and asia pacific they are
also predicted to have 12 more editions
in the future azure available in 140
countries has over 54 regions worldwide
grouped into six geographies these
geographical locations have more than
100 data centers gcp is available in 200
plus countries across the world as of
today gcp is present in 61 zones and 20
regions with osaka and zurich being the
newly added regions now let's talk about
pricing these services follow the pay as
you go approach you pay only for the
individual services you need for as long
as you use them without requiring
long-term contracts or complex licensing
now on screen you can see the pricing
for each of these cloud service
providers with respect to various
instances like general purpose compute
optimized memory optimized and gpu now
let's talk about the compute services
offered first off we have virtual
servers for aws we have ec2 it is a web
service which eliminates the need to
invest in hardware so that you can
develop and deploy applications in a
faster manner it provides virtual
machines in which you can run your
applications azure's virtual machines is
one of the several types of computing
resources that azure offers azure gives
the user the flexibility to deploy and
manage a virtual environment inside a
virtual network gcp's vm service enables
users to build deploy and manage virtual
machines to run workloads on the cloud
now let's talk about the pricing of each
of these services aws cc2 is free to try
it is packaged as part of aws's free
tier that lasts for 12 months and
provides 750 hours per month of both
linux and windows virtual machines azure
virtual machine service is a part of the
free tier that offers this service for
about 750 hours per month for a year the
user gets access to windows and linux
virtual machines gcp's vm service is a
part of a free tier that includes micro
instance per month for up to 12 months
now let's talk about platform as a
service or pass services for aws elastic
bean stock is an easy to use service for
deploying and scaling web applications
and services developed with java dot net
node.js python and much more it is used
for maintaining capacity provisioning
load balancing auto scaling and
application health monitoring the pass
backbone utilizes virtualization
techniques where the virtual machine is
independent of the actual hardware that
hosts it hence the user can write
application code without worrying about
the underlying hardware google app
engine is a cloud computing platform as
a service which is used by developers
for hosting and building apps in google
data centers the app engine requires the
apps to be written in java or python and
store data in google bigtable and use
the google query language for this next
let's talk about virtual private server
services aws provides light sale it
provides everything you need to build an
application or a website along with the
cost effective monthly plan and minimum
number of configurations in simple words
vm image is a more comprehensive image
for microsoft azure virtual machines it
helps the user create many identical
virtual machines in a matter of minutes
unfortunately gcp does not offer any
similar service next up we have
serverless computing services aws has
lambda it is a serverless compute
service that lets you run your code
without facilitating and managing
servers you only pay for the compute
time you use it is used to execute
backend code and scales automatically
when required azure functions is a
serverless compute service that lets you
run even triggered code without having
to explicitly provision or manage
infrastructure this allows the users to
build applications using serverless
simple functions with the programming
language of their choice gcp cloud
functions make it easy for developers to
run and scale code in the cloud and
build image driven serverless
applications it is highly available and
fault tolerant now let's talk about
storage services offered by each of
these service providers first off we
have object storage aws provides s3 it
is an object storage that provides
industry standard scalability data
availability and performance it is
extremely durable and can be used for
storing as well as recovering
information or data from anywhere over
the internet blob storage is an azure
feature that lets developers store
unstructured data in microsoft's cloud
platform along with storage it also
offers scalability it stores the data in
the form of tears depending on how often
data is being accessed google cloud
storage is an online storage web service
for storing and accessing data on google
cloud platform infrastructure unlike the
google drive google cloud storage is
more suitable for enterprises it also
stores objects that are organized into
buckets amazon provides ebs or elastic
block store it provides high performance
block storage and is used along with ec2
instances for workloads that are
transaction or throughput intensive
azure managed disk is a virtual hard
disk you can think of it like a physical
disk in an on-premises server but
virtualized these managed disks allow
the users to create up to 10 000 vm
disks in a single subscription
persistent storage is a data storage
device that retains data after power to
the device is shut off google persistent
disk is durable and high performance
block storage for gcp persistent disk
provides storage which can be attached
to instances running in either google
compute engine or kubernetes engine next
up we have disaster recovery services
aws provides a cloud-based recovery
service that ensures that your it
infrastructure and data are recovered
while minimizing the amount of downtime
that could be experienced site recovery
helps ensure business continuity by
keeping business apps and workloads
running during outages it allows
recovery by orchestrating and automating
the replication process of azure virtual
machines between regions unfortunately
gcp has no disaster recovery service
next let's talk about database services
first off for aws we have rds or
relational database service it is web
service that's cost effective and
automates administration tasks basically
it simplifies the setup operation and
scaling of a relational database
microsoft azure sql database is a
software as a service platform that
includes built-in intelligence that
learns app patterns and adapts to
maximize performance reliability and
data protection it also eases the
migration of sql server databases
without changing the user's applications
cloud sql is a fully managed database
service which is easy to set up maintain
and administer relational postgresql
mysql and sql server databases in the
cloud hosted on gcp cloud sql provides a
database infrastructure for applications
running anywhere next we have nosql
database services aws provides dynamodb
which is a managed durable database that
provides security backup and restore and
in-memory caching for applications it is
well known for its low latency and
scalable performance azure cosmos db is
microsoft's globally distributed
multi-model database service it natively
supports nosql it natively supports
nosql created for low latency and
scalable applications gcp cloud data
store is a nosql database service
offered by google on the gcp it handles
replication and scales automatically to
your application's load with cloud data
stores interface data can easily be
accessed by any deployment target now
let's talk about the key cloud tools for
each of these service providers for aws
in networking and content delivery we
have aws route 53 and aws cloud front
for management we have aws cloud watch
and aws cloud formation for development
we have aws code start and aws code
build for security we have iam and key
management service for microsoft azure
networking and content delivery we have
content delivery network and express
root for management tools we have azure
advisor and network watcher for
development tools for management we have
azure advisor and network watcher for
development we have visual studio ide
and azure blob studio for security we
have azure security center and azure
active directory for gcp we have the
following tools for networking and
content delivery we have cloud cdn and
cloud dns for management we have stack
driver and gcp monitoring for
development we have cloud build and
cloud sdk and finally for security we
have google cloud im and google and
cloud security scanner now let's talk
about the companies using these cloud
providers for aws we have netflix
unilever kellogg's nasa nokia and adobe
pixar samsung ebay fujitsu emc and bmw
among others use microsoft azure so as
seen on your screens the companies that
use gcp are spotify hsbc snapchat
twitter paypal and 20th century fox
let's talk about the advantages of each
of these services amazon provides
enterprise friendly services you can
leverage amazon's 15 years of experience
delivering large-scale global
infrastructure and it still continues to
hone and innovate its infrastructure
management skills and capabilities
secondly it provides instant access to
resources aws is designed to allow
application providers isvs and vendors
to quickly and securely host your
applications whether an existing
application or a new sas based
application speed and agility aws
provides you access to its services
within minutes all you need to select is
what you require and you can proceed you
can access each of these applications
anytime you need them and finally it's
secure and reliable amazon enables you
to innovate and scale your application
in a secure environment it secures and
hardens your infrastructure more
importantly it provides security at a
cheaper cost than on-premise
environments now talking about some of
the advantages of azure microsoft azure
offers better development operations it
also provides strong security profile
azure has a strong focus on security
following the standard security model of
detect assess diagnose stabilize and
close azure also provides a
cost-effective solution the cloud
environment allows businesses to launch
both customer applications and internal
apps in the cloud which saves an id
infrastructure costs hence it's opex
friendly let's now look at the
advantages of gcp google builds in
minute level increments so you only pay
for the compute time you use they also
provide discounted prices for
long-running workloads for example you
use the vm for a month and get a
discount gcp also provides live
migration of virtual machines live
migration is the process of moving a
running vm from one physical server to
another without disrupting its
availability to the users this is a very
important differentiator for google
cloud compared to other cloud providers
gcp provides automatic scalability this
allows a size container scale to as many
cpus as needed google cloud storage is
designed for 99.9 durability it creates
server backup and stores them in an user
configure location let's talk about the
disadvantages of each of these services
for aws there's a limitation of the ec2
service aws provides limitations on
resources that vary from region to
region there may be a limit to the
number of instances that can be created
however you can request for these limits
to be increased secondly they have a
technical support fee aws charges you
for immediate support and you can opt
for any of these packages developer
which costs 29 per month business which
costs more than hundred dollars an
enterprise that costs more than fifteen
thousand dollars it has certain network
connectivity issues it also has general
issues when you move to the cloud like
downtime limited control backup
protection and so on however most of
these are temporary issues and can be
handled over time talking about some of
the disadvantages of microsoft azure
codebase is different when working
offline and it requires modification
when working on the cloud pass echo
system is not as efficient as iaas azure
management console is frustrating to
work with it is slow to respond and
update and requires far too many clicks
to achieve simple tasks azure backup is
intended for backing up and restoring
data located on your on-premises servers
to the cloud that's a great feature but
it's not really useful for doing bare
metal three stores of servers in a
remote data center let's now look into
the disadvantages of gcp so when it
comes to cloud providers the support fee
is very minimal but in the case of gcp
it is quite costly it is around 150
dollars per month for the most basic
service similar to aws s3 gcp has a
complex pricing schema also it is not
very budget friendly when it comes to
downloading data from google cloud
storage now let us see the
certifications that are available for
aws and azure and how you can become a
cloud engineer and an aws solutions
architect rahul will talk about these
topics we'll also cover some important
aws and azure interview questions right
now we're in the aws certification
website whose link will be in the
description and now we're going to talk
about the types of aws certification as
you can see here there are three levels
of aw certification there's the
foundational level associate level and
professional level certification now the
foundational level certification only
requires you to have a basic
understanding of how the aws cloud works
the aws certified dot practitioner is
optional for the architect path
developer path and operations path it is
mandatory for the specialty
certifications like the advanced
networking big data and security
certifications now the associate level
certifications are mid-level
certifications for a technical role now
a professional certification is the
highest level of certification that you
can have for a technical role now you
have the solutions architect for the
architect path and the devops engineer
certification for both the developer and
operations path so how do you decide
which of these certifications is
suitable for you so you've seen here
that aws provides various certifications
for a number of job roles exisops
administrator solution architect
developer so you need to make the right
choice taking into consideration the
areas of your interest and the
experience level that you have now we're
going to talk about each of these
certifications in detail so first let's
talk about the aw certified cloud
practitioner now we all understand that
aws is a widely recognized product in
the market so this certification helps
you validate how well you know the aws
cloud so this is just the basic
understanding now it is optional for the
developer path and the operations path i
would suggest it's a good idea to start
here because it forms a solid bedrock on
all the other things that you're going
to learn soon now more importantly it
does not require any technical knowledge
of other roles such as development
architecture administration and so on so
it's a great place to start for
newcomers now you have the architect
role certifications now this is for you
if you are interested in becoming a
solutions architect or a solution design
engineer or someone who just works with
designing applications or systems on the
aws platform now first we have the aw
certified solutions architect associate
level certification now this
certification is for you if you want to
show off how well you can architect and
deploy applications on the aws platform
now it is recommended that you have at
least a year of experience working with
distributed systems on the aws platform
at the same time it's also required that
you understand the aws services and be
able to recommend a service based on
requirements you need to be able to use
architectural best practices and you
need to estimate the aws costs and how
you can reduce them next up you have the
aws certified solutions architect
professional level certification now you
will not get the certification unless
you're done with the aw certified
solutions architect associate level
certification this is the show of your
technical skills and experience in
designing distributed applications on
the aws platform now this does require
you to have two years of experience
working with cloud architecture on aws
at the same time it also requires you to
be able to evaluate requirements and
then make architectural recommendations
you also need to provide guidance on the
best practices on architectural design
across a number of different platforms
the developer level certifications are
for you if you're interested in becoming
a software developer now the aws
certified developer associate
certification is to test how well you
know how to develop and maintain
applications on the aws platform it does
require you to have a year or more of
hands-on experience to design and
maintain aws based applications like any
software developer role it is necessary
that you know in-depth at least one
high-level programming language it's
also necessary that you understand the
core of aws services uses and basic
architectural best practices you need to
be able to design develop and deploy
cloud-based solutions on aws platform
and you need to understand how
applications can be created you need to
have experience in developing and
maintaining applications for a number of
aws services like amazon sns dynamodb
sqs and so on now for the aw certified
devops engineer professional level
certification note here that this
certification is exactly the same as the
one you have under the operations role
so both of them are the same thing so
here it tests your ability to create
operate and manage distributed
applications on the aws platform now it
is necessary or it is mandatory to have
the aw certified developer associate
certification or the aws certified
sysops administrator certification with
two or more years of hands-on experience
in doing the same in aws environments it
requires you to be able to develop code
in at least one high-level language you
need to be able to automate and test
applications via scripting and
programming and to understand agile or
other development processes the
operation certifications are for you if
you want to become a sysops
administrator systems administrator or
someone in devops role who wants to
deploy applications networks and systems
in an automatable and beatable way the
aw certified sysops administrator
associate certification tests your
knowledge in deployment management and
operations on the aws platform now you
need to have one or more years of
hands-on experience in aws based
applications you need to be able to
identify and gather requirements then
define a solution to be operated on aws
you need to be able to provide guidance
for the best practices through the life
cycle of a project as well now the
specialty certifications are for you if
you're well-versed in aws and want to
showcase your expertise in other
technical areas the aw certified big
data certification showcases your
ability to design and implement aws
services which can help derive value
from a large amount of complex data you
are however required to have completed
the foundational or associate level
certification before you can attempt
this you need a minimum of five years of
hands-on experience in the data
analytics field as well next we have the
aw certified advanced networking
certification this validates your
ability to design and implement aws
solutions as well as other hybrid id
network architectures at scale this also
requires you to have completed the
foundational or associate level
certification you need to have a minimum
of five years of hands-on experience
architecting and implementing network
solutions and lastly we have the awa
certified security certification it
helps showcase your ability to secure
the aws platform you're required to have
an associate or cloud practitioner level
of certification a minimum of five years
of it security experience and two years
of hands-on experience securing aws
workloads now say i wanted to schedule
an examination so for example i want to
do the solutions architect certification
so first i would go there now here i can
click on register now and the process
continues or i can click on learn more
by doing this again i can show you the
examination here i can also get access
to other data like the number of
questions available the cost of an
examination the portions i need to study
and so on now let's talk about solutions
architect certification with a little
more detail now this certification exam
cost 150 us dollars and the practice
exam cost 20 us dollars now here i can
schedule the examination or download the
exam guide i've already downloaded the
exam guide and here it is now this exam
guide tells you about what you need to
learn and what is expected from you here
they want you to define a solution based
on requirements and provide guidance in
its implementation it is also
recommended that you know about how the
aws services work 1 years of hands-on
experience with distributed systems on
aws to identify and define technical
requirements and so on the rest is
available in the exam guide and most
importantly they tell you the main
content domains and their weightages now
we have five domains first domain is to
design resilient architectures which
holds 34 percent of weightage at depend
two you have to define performant
architectures three is to specify secure
applications and architectures cost
optimized architectures and five to
define operationally excellent
architectures now like you've seen here
you've selected one certification and
learnt it in detail you can do the same
for any of these other certifications
you can press learn more and download
their exam guide and learn everything
that you need to know hi guys i'm rahul
from simply learn and today we will be
talking about azure certifications now
before we go into a little bit of detail
let's first talk about what exactly is
an azure certification so the azure
certifications are actually examinations
that are provided by microsoft these
help you validate how well you
understand the concepts of azure and how
well you can work with it these are
basically badges of honor that you can
show off these also play a very
important role when it comes to hiring a
promotion you're obviously more likely
to be selected if you are a certified
professional now these certifications
cover a wide range of domains and these
certifications also work towards a
specified role for example you have
certifications that help you become a
solutions architect or an as your
administrator or an azure developer now
if you need a little more convincing as
to why you should be taking up an azure
certification here are a few more azir
provides powerful data and artificial
intelligence services that help create
intelligent applications azure has more
than 100 services that span a wide range
of domains they also help satisfy a
great number of requirements more than
80 percent of the fortune 500 companies
use microsoft azure for their cloud
computing requirements not to mention
these organizations that use microsoft
products can actually avail an
enterprise agreement that gives them
discounts on azure services and finally
azir provides services across 42 regions
in the world which is more than any
other cloud service provider does in the
market right now now let's talk about
azure certifications so it's highly
likely that you've heard of microsoft
more popular certifications the 70532
70533 and 70535 but microsoft is
changing its approach towards
certifications microsoft's new
certifications aim to make the
individual fall into a particular role
for example as your administrator
associate as your developer associate as
your solutions architect and the azure
devops engineer expert this is what
microsoft introduced in the ignite
conference that took place on september
24th there microsoft introduced new
certifications that fall under the az
category now to become an azure
administrator associate you need to have
the az 100 certification or the
microsoft as your infrastructure and
deployment and the az101 or microsoft as
your integration and security to become
an azure developer you need the az200
which is the microsoft azure developer
core solution certification and az201 or
the microsoft azure developer advanced
solution certification finally to become
a solutions architect you'll need the
asa 300 or the microsoft as your
architect technologies and the az-301 or
the microsoft azure architect design now
these were all introduced on september
24th when the ignite conference took
place now the old certifications the 532
533 and 535 will be discontinued from
the 31st of december 2018. so what
happens to the people who've actually
done it that's why microsoft introduced
the az102 202 and 302 transition
certifications now we'll talk about that
in a little bit so now let's go into all
of the new certifications in detail so
now let's talk about exam az 100 or the
microsoft as your infrastructure and
deployment certification so this is
basically part one of two when it comes
to becoming an azure administrator this
costs 165 us dollars now let's have a
look at the syllabus for this exam some
of the domains that you need to prepare
for and their approximate weightages so
first off you need to know how you can
manage azure subscriptions and resources
this involves managing subscriptions
analyzing how resources are being used
and how they're consumed and managing
other resource groups secondly you have
implementing and managing storage you
need to know how you can create and
configure storage accounts how you can
import and export data to azure
configures your files and how you can
implement as your backup then you have
deploying and managing virtual machines
you need to know how you can create and
configure virtual machines for windows
or linux you need to know how you can
automate deployment of virtual machines
you need to know how you can manage
azure virtual machines and manage
virtual machine backups then you need to
know how you can configure and manage
virtual networks you need to be able to
create connectivity between virtual
networks how you can implement and
manage virtual networking configure name
resolution to groups finally you need to
know how you can manage identities you
need to be able to manage as your active
directories and you need to know how you
can implement and manage hybrid
identities the next step in becoming an
azure administrator is to do the az101
or the microsoft azure integration and
security certification the az101 or the
microsoft azure integration and security
certification goes into a little more
detail when it comes to becoming an
azure administrator the certification
cost 165 us dollars now let's have a
look at some of the important topics
that you need to know for this
examination so let's have a look at some
of the portions that you need to be well
versed with to perform well in this
examination first up we have evaluating
and performing server migrations to
azure then we have implementing and
managing application services which
involves configuring serverless
computing managing app service plans and
managing app services then you have
implementing advanced virtual networking
that involves implementing application
load balancing implementing azure load
balancer monitoring and managing
networking integrating the on-premise
network with the azure network and so on
and finally securing identities you need
to be able to implement a multi-factor
authentication manage a role-based
control system implementing as your
active directories and privilege
identity management so after you're done
with az100 and 101 you become a
microsoft certified as your
administrator associate but what happens
to the people who already done the
implementing microsoft azure
infrastructure solution certification or
the 70533 it's for these people that
microsoft has the az102 or the microsoft
azure administrator certification
transition now this examination that
costs 99 us dollars contains concepts
from both az 100 and a z101 and this
exam is only valid for people who've
already completed the 70533
certification now if you have completed
the 70533 i suggest you do this
transition certification immediately as
this will be discontinued by microsoft
by the 31st of march 2019. now let's
have a look at how you can become a
microsoft certified as your developer
associate to do this you need to
complete two certifications the az200 or
the microsoft azure developer core
solution certification and the az201 or
the microsoft azure developer advanced
solution certification so now let's have
a look at the az200 now this
certification is part one of two when it
comes to becoming an azure developer
associate it costs 165 us dollars now
this examination is in its beta phase
which means that unlike normal
examinations where you get your results
as soon as you finish the examination
this exam will take at least one or two
weeks before you can get your result the
questions are still being worked on and
improved upon there's also a limitation
to how many people can take the exam at
the moment now let's have a look at some
of the portions that you need to prepare
for for this examination you need to be
able to select an appropriate cloud
technology solution based on your
requirements this may involve a compute
solution integration or a storage
solution next you need to be able to
develop for cloud storage which involves
developing solutions that involve
storage tables file storage relational
databases and so much more you need to
be able to create platform as a service
solutions which involves creating web
applications mobile applications app
services serverless functions and so
much more and finally you need to be
able to secure cloud solutions you need
to implement authentication access
control and secure data solutions now
microsoft recommends that you have at
least a year of experience working with
microsoft azure creating applications
with azure tools and technologies while
at the same time having a solid
understanding of all the faces of
software development now let's have a
look at the next step to becoming a
microsoft azure developer you need to do
the az201 or the microsoft azure
developer advanced solution
certification now let's have a look at
that now this examination is also in its
beta phase and will move to its final
version in the next few months as of now
it costs 165 us dollars now let's have a
look at some of the portions that you
need to prepare for for this examination
you need to know how you can develop for
an azure cloud model you need to develop
for auto scaling develop for
long-running tasks distribute a
transaction and so much more you need to
know how you can implement cloud
integration solutions like managing apis
using api management configure a message
based integration architecture to
develop an application message model and
so much more and finally you need to
know how you can develop azure's
cognitive services bot and iot solutions
you need to be able to create and
integrate bots create and implement iot
solutions and to integrate the azure
cognitive services in an application
after you're done with all of this you
become a microsoft certified azure
developer associate now let's talk about
az202 now this is a transition
examination for anyone who's done 70532
or developing microsoft azure solution
certification now just like the other
transition certification this costs 99
us dollars and it is in its beta phase
now this is accessible for only people
who have done the 70532 and is available
only for a limited period of time this
will be discontinued from the 31st of
march 2019. now this has concepts that
have been included in both az 200 and as
201 concepts like developing for crowd
storage creating platform as a service
solutions securing cloud solutions
developing for an azure cloud model
implementing cloud integration solutions
developing ai machine learning and iot
solutions now after you're done with
this you can become a microsoft
certified as your developer associate
now let's find out how you can become a
microsoft certified as your solutions
architect expert for this you need to do
two certifications the aza 300 and the
azure 301 now let's have a look at az300
which is the microsoft azure architect
technology certification now the az 300
is still in its beta phase and costs 165
dollars this is part one of two for
becoming a microsoft certified as your
solutions architect expert now let's
talk about some of the topics that you
need to prepare for for this examination
you need to know how you can deploy and
configure infrastructure which involves
analyzing resource utilization
consumption creating and configuring
storage accounts creating and
configuring virtual machines for windows
and linux automating deployment of
virtual machines and so much more then
you need to know how you can implement
workloads and security like migrating
servers to assure configure serverless
computing implementing application load
balancing managing role-based access
control implementing multi-factor
authentication and so on then you need
to architect cloud technology solutions
you need to be able to select
appropriate compute solutions integrate
solutions storage solutions you need to
be able to create and deploy
applications like for example creating
web applications using pass create an
application or service that runs on
service fabric design and develop
applications that run in containers and
so on then you need to implement
authentications and secure data and
finally you need to develop for the
cloud which means you need to know how
you can develop long-running tasks
configure message-based integration
develop for auto scaling implement
distributed transactions and so on now
this certification does require you to
be having expert level skills in at
least as your administration as your
development or devops you also need to
have experience with the various steps
in it operations like networking
virtualization security and so on this
is because the azure solutions architect
play a very important role of advising
stakeholders to convert their
requirements into scalable secure and
reliable solutions so now the next step
is to do the az301 or the microsoft
azure architect design certification now
let's have a look at that now like all
the other certifications this costs 165
dollars and is still in its beta phase
this is the final step in becoming an
azure solutions architect expert now
let's have a look at some of the topics
that you need to prepare for for this
certification firstly you need to know
how you can determine workload
requirements you need to know how to
gather information and requirements to
optimize the consumption strategy and to
design a auditing and monitoring
strategy you need to design for identity
and security like design identity
management design authentication
authorization and a monitoring strategy
for identity and security then you need
to know how you can design a data
platform solution you need to design a
data management strategy a data
protection strategy document data flows
and so on then you need to design a
business continuity strategy for example
to design a site recovery strategy
ensure that there's high availability
design a disaster recovery strategy and
to design a data archiving strategy then
you need to design for deployment
migration and integration you need to
design deployments design migrations and
design an api integration strategy and
finally you need to know how you can
design a storage strategy a compute
strategy networking strategy and so on
after you're done with all of this you
become a microsoft certified as your
solutions architect expert so what about
those people who've already done the
70535 or the architecting microsoft as
your solution certification that's where
the asic 302 comes in now the az302 is a
transition certification which costs 99
us dollars this acts as a replacement
for anyone who's done the 70535
certification now this is again in its
beta phase but will last only till march
31st 2019. now if you finish the
certification you get to become an azure
solutions architect expert now this
consists of topics included in both az
300 and 301 concepts like determining
workload requirements designing for
identity and security designing a
business continuity strategy
implementing workloads in security
implementing authentication and securing
data and developing for the cloud
now what we've mentioned in this video
are the most important azure
certifications now there are older
certifications but we've not covered
them because we'll be focusing on the
more important role based examinations
that have been introduced recently the
cloud tech services market is expected
to grow 17.3 percent in the span of 2018
to 19 which means there's a growth from
175 175.8 billion dollars to a whopping
206 billion dollars in 2019 and as of
2020 it's expected that 90 of all
organizations in the world would be
using cloud services not to mention
several organizations around the world
suggest that using cloud computing
services has enabled their employees to
experiment a lot more with technologies
like machine learning and artificial
intelligence so here's what we'll be
going through today firstly we'll be
talking about who is a cloud computing
engineer the steps you need to take to
become a cloud computing engineer and
the cloud computing engineers salaries
so first off who is a cloud computing
engineer now a cloud computing engineer
is an id professional who takes care of
all the technical aspects of cloud
computing now be it design planning
maintenance and support now a cloud
computing engineer can take up a number
of different career paths this could be
that of a cloud developer security
engineer a full stack developer sysops
administrator solutions architect cloud
architect and so much more now let's
have a look at some of the major cloud
computing roles first off we have
solutions architect now these are
individuals who are responsible for
analyzing the technical environment in
which they are going to produce the
solutions the requirements and the
specifications secondly they are
required to select an appropriate
technology that satisfies set
requirements they need to estimate and
manage the usage and the operational
costs of the solutions they provide and
they need to support project management
as well as solution development next we
have sysops administrators they are
involved in deploying managing and
operating highly scalable and fault
tolerant systems they need to select an
appropriate service based on compute
security or data requirements they need
to estimate and manage usage and
operational costs and they need to be
able to migrate on-premises workloads
onto an appropriate cloud computing
platform so among both of these roles
there are certain requirements that are
remaining constant now let's have a look
at the steps you need to take to become
a cloud computing engineer your first
step is to gain proficiency in a cloud
computing platform now the first step is
to become proficient in at least one of
the three major cloud computing
platforms beat aws azure or the google
cloud platform now there are a huge
number of resources that you can find on
the internet it could be youtube videos
articles virtual or physical classrooms
and so much more now after you're done
learning you can get certified by
microsoft azure aws or the google cloud
platform now for aws you have a number
of different certifications which can be
divided into three categories which are
the foundational which is just the
basics the associate level
certifications the professional level
certifications and the specialty
certifications similarly with microsoft
azure you have certifications that
enable you to become an azure developer
associate an azure administrator
associate an azure architect
professional and a devops engineer now
most cloud computing platforms have a
free tier that you can take advantage of
these provide a number of free services
for a period of time some of which are
free forever so you can use these
platforms to your advantage and do as
much practice as you can on them now if
you want to learn more about cloud
computing you can also check out
simplylearn's youtube channel then you
can go on to the playlist section right
here and you can find comprehensive
videos on a number of different cloud
computing platforms aws and microsoft
azure our aws tutorial videos talk about
what exactly is aws how you can become
an aws solutions architect amazon ec2 s3
some of the other services and so much
more we also have detailed tutorials on
azure which talks about what exactly is
azure the certifications provided by
azure some of the services like machine
learning as your active directory and so
much more and now we're at step two
being experienced in at least one
programming language unlike general
purpose programming languages like c c
plus plus c sharp and so on cloud
computing requires ones that are a lot
more data oriented now some of the major
programming languages that are used in
cloud computing are go python clojure
and java now as i said before there is a
wealth of resources that you can learn
from there are free websites that you
can practice your code on like quick
code code academy and several others
there's also resources like youtube
videos as well as the option of online
or offline classes now we're at step 3
specialization you'll also need to be
well versed with a number of key
concepts these are storage and
networking now with storage you need to
know how data can be stored and where it
can be accessed from you need to know
how it can be accessed from multiple
different resources you'll also need to
have some experience with the services
provided by azure and aws like the
amazon s3 in aws and the appropriately
named azure storage from microsoft azure
with networking you need to have a
strong understanding of the networking
fundamentals as well as virtual networks
next up we have virtualization and
operating systems with virtualization
you need to know how virtual networks
which is just a combination of different
virtual machines can be used to emulate
different components in a particular
system with operating systems you need
to have a very strong understanding
operating systems like windows and linux
next up we have security and disaster
recovery now you need to understand how
data application as well as
infrastructure can be protected from
malicious attacks with disaster recovery
you need to be prepared for any
unexpected circumstance by making sure
your systems are always safe and are
regularly backed up to prevent any sort
of loss of data then we have web
services and devops now you need to have
a strong understanding of apis or
application program interfaces and web
services some amount of experience with
web design also can be of great help
with devops you need to have a strong
understanding of how cloud computing is
able to provide a centralized platform
on which you can perform testing
deployment and production for devops
automation moreover with devops you
understand the synergy that the
operations as well as the development
teams have with each other and for the
success of any project and finally
you're a cloud computing engineer now
let's have a look at the salaries of
cloud computing engineers in the united
states cloud computing engineers earn
around 116 000 per annum in india a
cloud computing engineer is paid
approximately 6 lakh 66 000 rupees per
annum now how can simply learn help you
become a cloud computing engineer so
let's head on to simply learn's website
here we have the cloud architect masters
program now this deals with a number of
different courses all of which that can
help you get started in your journey to
becoming a cloud computing engineer this
master's program covers a number of
different courses like aws technical
essentials microsoft azure fundamentals
aws developer associate and so much more
it provides you 40 plus in-demand skills
and 25-plus services provides you a
master's certification it has 16 plus
real life projects and helps you get a
salary that ranges between 15 to 25 lakh
rupees per annum it also covers a
variety of tools like amazon ec2 azure
data factory virtual machines and so
much more so why don't you head on to
simplylearn.com and get started on your
journey to getting certified and getting
ahead i'm here to walk you through some
of the aws interview questions which we
find are important and our hope is that
you would use this material in your
interview preparation and be able to
crack that cloud interview and step into
your dream cloud job by the way i'm and
cloud technical architect trainer and an
interview panelist for cloud network and
devops so as you progress in watching
you're going to see that these questions
are practical scenario based questions
that tests the depth of the knowledge of
a person in a particular aws product or
in a particular aws architecture so why
wait let's move on all right so in an
interview you would find yourself with a
question that might ask you define and
explain the three basic types of cloud
services and the aws products that are
built based on them see here it's a very
straightforward question just explain
three basic types of cloud service and
when we talk about basic type of cloud
service it's compute obviously that's a
very basic service storage obviously
because you need to store your data
somewhere and networking that actually
connects a couple of other services to
your application these basic will not
include monitoring these basic will not
include analytics because they are
considered as optional they are
considered as advanced services you
could choose a non-cloud service or a
product for monitoring of and for
analytics so they're not considered as
basic so when we talk about basics they
are compute storage and networking and
the second part of the questions is
explain some of the aws products that
are built based on them of course
compute ec2 is a major one that's that's
the major share of the compute resource
and then we have platform as a service
which is elastic bean stock and then
function as a service which is lambda
auto scaling and light cell are also
part of compute services
so the compute domain it really helps us
to run any application and the compute
service helps us in managing the scaling
and deployment of an application again
lambda is a compute server so the
compute service also helps in running
event initiated stateless applications
the next one was storage a lot of
emphasis is on storage these days
because if there's one thing that grows
in a network on a daily basis that
storage every new day we have new data
to store process manage so storage is
again a basic and an important cloud
service and the products that are built
based on the storage services are s3
object storage glacier for archiving ebs
elastic block storage as a drive
attachment for the ec2 instances and the
efs file share for the ec2 instances so
the storage domain helps in the
following aspects it holds all the
information that the application uses so
it's the application data and we can
also archive old data using storage
which would be glacier and any object
files and any requirement for block
storage can be met through elastic block
store and s3 which is again an object
storage talking about uh networks it's
just not important to answer the
question with the name of the services
and the name of the product it'll also
be good if you could go in depth and
explain how
they can be used right so that actually
proves you to be a person knowledgeable
enough in that particular service or
product so talking about networking
domain vpc networking can't imagine
networking without vpc in in the cloud
environment especially in aws cloud
environment and then we have route 53
for domain resolution or
for dns and then we have cloudfront
which is an edge caching service that
helps customers get our customers to
read their application with low latency
so networking domain helps with some of
the following use cases it controls and
manages the connectivity of the aws
services within our account and we can
also pick an ip address range
if you're a network engineer or if you
are somebody who works in networks or
are planning to work a network you will
soon realize the importance of choosing
your own ip address for easy remembering
so having an option to have your own ip
address in the cloud on range of ip
address in the cloud it really helps
really really helps in cloud networking
the other question that gets asked would
be the difference between the
availability zone and the region
actually the question generally gets
asked
so to test how well you can actually
differentiate and also correlate the
availability zone and the region
relationship right so a region is a
separate geographic area like the us2s1
i mean which represents uh north
california or the ap south which
represents mumbai so regions are a
separate geographic area on the contrary
availability zone resides
inside the region you shouldn't stop
there you should go further and explain
about availability zones and
availability zones are isolated from
each other and some of the services will
replicate themselves within the
availability zone so availability zone
does replication within them but regions
they don't generally do replication
between them the other question you
could be asked is what is auto scaling
what do we achieve by auto scaling so in
short auto scaling it helps us to
automatically provision and launch new
instances whenever there is an demand it
not only helps us meeting the increasing
demand it also helps in reducing the
resource usage when there is low demand
so auto scaling also allows us to
decrease the resources or resource
capacity as per the need of that
particular r now this helps business in
not worrying about putting more effort
in managing or continuously monitoring
the server to see if they have the
needed resource or not because auto
scaling is going to handle it for us so
business does not need to worry about it
and auto scaling is one big reason why
people would want to go and pick a cloud
service especially an awf service the
ability to increase and shrink based on
the need of that arc that's how powerful
is auto scaling
the other question you could get asked
is what's due targeting in cloud front
now we know that cloudfront is caching
and it caches content globally in the
amazon caching servers global wide the
whole point is to provide users
worldwide access to the data from a very
nearest server possible that's the whole
point in using or going for cloud front
then what do you mean by geo targeting
jio
is showing customer and specific content
based on language we can customize the
content based on what's popular in that
place we can actually customize the
content the url is the same but we could
actually change the content a little bit
not the whole content otherwise it would
be dynamic but we can change the content
a little bit a specific a file or a
picture or a particular link in a
website and show customized content to
users who will be in different parts of
the globe so how does it happen
cloudfront will detect the country where
the viewers are located and it will
forward the country code to the origin
server and once the origin server gets
the specialized or a specific country
code it will change the content and it
will send to the caching server and it
get cached there forever and the user
gets to view a content which is
personalized for them for the country
they are in the other question you could
get asked is the steps involved in using
cloud formation or creating a cloud
formation or backing up an environment
within cloud formation template we all
know that if there is a template we can
simply run it and it provisions the
environment but there is a lot more
going into it so the first step in
moving towards infrastructure as a code
is to create the cloud formation
template which as of now supports json
and yaml file format so first create the
cloud formation template and then save
the code in an x3 bucket history bucket
serves as the repository for our code
and then from the cloud formation call
the file in the s3 bucket and create a
stack and now cloud formation uses the
file reads the file understands services
that are being called understands the
order understands how they are connected
with each other cloud formation is
actually an intelligent service it
understands the relation based on the
code it would understand the
relationship between the different
services and it would set an order for
itself and then would provision the
services one after the other let's say a
service has a dependency and the
dependent service the other service
which this service let's say service a
and b service b is dependent on service
a let's say cloud formation is an
intelligent service it would provision
the resource a first and then would
provision resource b what happens if we
inverse the order if we inverse the
order resource b first gets provision
and because it does not have dependency
chances that the cloud formation's
default behavior is that if something is
not provisioned properly something is
not healthy it could roll back chances
that the environment provisioning will
roll back so to avoid that cloud
formation first provisions all the
services that has or that's dependent on
that's depended by another service so it
provisions those service first and then
provisions the services that has
dependencies and if you're being hired
for
a devops or you know if the interview
wanted to test your skill on
systems side this definitely would be a
question in his list how do you upgrade
or downgrade a system with near zero
downtime now everybody's moving towards
zero downtime or near zero downtime all
of them want their application to be
highly available so the question would
be how do you actually upgrade or
downgrade a system with near zero
downtime now we all know that i can
upgrade an ec2 instance to a better ec2
instance by changing the instance type
stopping and starting but stopping and
starting is going to cause a downtime
right so that's you should be answering
or you shouldn't be thinking in those
terms because that's the wrong answer
specifically the interviewer wants to
know how do you upgrade a system with
zero downtime so upgrading system with
zero downtime it includes launching
another system parallelly with the
bigger ec2 instance type over the bigger
capacity and install all that's needed
if you're going to use an ami of the old
machine well and good you don't have to
go through installing all the updates
and installing all the application from
the ami once you've launched it in a
bigger instance locally test the
application to see if it is working
don't put it on production yet test the
application to see if it is working and
if the application works we can actually
swap if your server is behind and
behind
route 53 let's say all that you could do
is go to dot 53 update the
information with the new ip address new
ip address of the new server and that's
going to send traffic to the new server
now so the cut over is handled or if
you're using static ip you can actually
remove the static ip from the old
machine and assign it to the new machine
that's one way of doing it or if you are
using elastic nic card you can actually
remove the new card from the old machine
and attach the new car to the new
machine so that way we would get near
zero downtime if you are hired for an
architect level
you should be worrying about cost as
well along with the technology and this
question would test how well you manage
cost so what are the tools and
techniques we can use in aws to identify
and correct identify and know that we
are paying the correct amount for the
resources that we are using or how do
you get a visibility of your aws
resources running one way is to check
the billing there is a place where you
can check the top services that were
utilized it could be free and it could
be paid service as well top services
that can be utilized it's actually in
the dashboard of the cost management
console so that table here shows the top
five most used services so looking at it
you can get it all right so i'm using a
lot of storage i'm using a lot of ec2
why is storage high you can go and try
to justify that and you will find if you
are storing things that should be
storing and then clean it up why is
compute capacity so high why is data
transfer so high so if you start
thinking in those levels you'll be able
to dig in and clean up unnecessary and
be able to save your bill and there are
cost explorer services available which
will help you to view your usage pattern
or view your spending for the past 13
months or so and it will also forecast
for the next three months now how much
will you be using if your pattern is
like this that will actually help and
will give you a visibility on how much
you have spent how much you will be
spending if the trend continues budgets
are another excellent a way to control
cost you can actually set up budget
alright this is how much i am willing to
spend for this application for this team
or for this month for this particular
resource so you can actually put a
budget mark and anytime it exceeds any
time it's nearing you would get an alarm
saying that well we're about to reach
the allocated budget amount stuff like
that that way you can go back and know
and you know that how much the bill is
going to be for that month or you can
take steps to control bill amount for
that particular month so aws budget is
another very good tool that you could
use cost allocation tags helps in
identifying which team or which resource
has spent more in that particular month
instead of looking at the bill as one
list with no specifications into it and
looking at it as an expenditure list you
can actually break it down and tag the
expenditure to the teams with cost
allocation tax the dev team has spent so
much the production team has spent so
much the training team has spent more
than the dev and the production team why
is that now you'll be able to you know
think in those levels only if you have
cost allocation tax now cost allocation
tags are nothing but the tags that you
would put when you create a resource so
for production services you would put as
a production tag you would create a
production tag and you would associate
that resources to it and at a later
point when you actually pull up your
bill that's going to show a detailed a
list of this is the owner this is the
group and this is how much they have
used in the last month and you can move
forward with your investigation and
encourage or stop users using more
services with the cost allocation tax
the other famous question is are there
any other tools or is there any other
way of accessing aws resource other than
the console console is gui right so in
other words other than gui how would you
use the aws resource and how familiar
are you with those tools and
technologies the other tools that are
available that we can leverage and
access the aws resource are of course
putty you can configure puti to access
the aws resources like log into an ec2
instance and ec2 instance does not
always have to be logged in through the
console you could use putty to log into
an ec2 instance like the jump box like
the proxy machine and like the gateway
machine and from there you can actually
access the rest of the resources so this
is an alternative to the console and of
course we have the aws cli in any of the
linux machines or windows machines we
can install so that's point two three
and four we can install aws cli for
linux windows also for mac so we can
install them and from there from your
local machine we can access run aws
commands and access provision monitor
the aws resources the other ones are we
can access the aws resource
programmatically using aws sdk and
eclipse so these are bunch of options we
have to use the aws resource other than
the console if you're interviewed in a
company or by a company that focuses
more on security and want to use aws
native services for their security then
you would come across this question what
services can be used to create a
centralized logging solution the basic
services we could use our cloud watch
logs store them in s3 and then use
elasticsearch to visualize them and use
kinesis to move the data from s3 to
elasticsearch right so log management it
actually helps organizations to track
the relationship between operational and
security changes and the events that got
triggered based on those logs
instead of logging into an instance or
instead of logging into the environment
and checking the resources physically i
can come to a fair conclusion by just
looking at the logs every time there's a
change the system would scream and it
gets tracked in the cloud watch and then
cloud watch pushes it to s3 kinesis
pushes the data from s3 to elasticsearch
and i can do a time-based filter and i
would get an a fair understanding of
what was going on in the environment for
the past one or whatever the time window
that i wanted to look at so it helps in
getting a good understanding of the
infrastructure as a whole all the logs
are getting saved in one place so all
the infrastructure logs are getting
saved in one place so it's easy for me
to look at it in an infrastructure
perspective
so we know the services that can be used
and here are some of the services and
how they actually connect to each other
it could be logs that belongs to a one
account it could be logs that belongs to
multiple accounts it doesn't matter you
know those three services are gonna work
fairly good and they're gonna inject or
they're gonna like suck logs from the
other accounts put it in one place and
help us to monitor so as you see you
have cloud watch here that actually
tracks the metrics you can also use
cloud trail if you want to log api calls
as well push them in an s3 bucket so
there are different types of blog flow
logs are getting captured in an instance
application logs are getting captured
from the same vpc from a different vpc
from the same account from a different
account and all of them are analyzed
using elasticsearch using the kibana
client
so step one is to deploy the ecs cluster
step two is to restrict access to the
ecs cluster because it's valid data you
don't want anybody to put their hands
and access their data so rustic access
to the ecs dashboard and we could use
lambda also to push the uh data from
cloudwatch to
the elasticsearch domain and then kibana
is actually the graphical tool that
helps us to visualize the logs instead
of looking at log as just statements or
in a bunch of characters a bunch of
files kibana helps us to analyze the
logs in a graphical or a chart or a bar
diagram format
again in an interview the interviewer is
more concerned about testing your
knowledge on aw security products
especially on the logging monitoring
even management or incident management
then you could have a question like this
what are the native aws security logging
capabilities now most of the services
have their own logging in them like have
their own logging like s3 s3 has its own
login and cloudfront has its own logging
ds has its own logging vpc has its own
logging in additional there are account
level logins like a cloudtrail and aws
config services so there are variety of
logging options available in the aws
like cloud trail config cloudfront
redshift logging rds logging vpc flow
logs s3 object logging s3 access logging
stuff like that so we're going to look
at two servers in specific cloud trail
now this cloud trail the very first
product in that picture we just thought
the cloud trail provides an very high
level history of the api calls for all
the account and with that we can
actually perform a very good security
analysis
a security analysis of our account and
these logs are actually delivered to you
can configure it they can be delivered
to s3 for long time archivals and based
on a particular event it can also send
an email notification to us saying hey
just got this error thought i'll let you
know stuff like that the other one is
config service a config service helps us
to understand the configuration changes
that happened in our environment and we
can also set up notifications based on
the configuration changes so it records
the cumulative changes that are made in
a short period of time so if you want to
go through the lifetime of a particular
resource what are the things that happen
what are the things it went through they
can be looked at using aws config
all right the other question you could
get asked is if
you know your role includes taking care
of cloud security as well then the other
question you could get asked is the
native services that amazon provides or
to mitigate ddos which is denial of
service now not all companies would go
with amazon native services but there
are some companies which want to stick
with amazon native services just to save
them from the headache of managing the
other softwares or bringing in another
tool a third-party tool into managing
ddos they simply want to stick with
amazon proprietary amazon native
services and a lot of companies are
using amazon service to prevent ddos
denial of service now denial of service
is if you already know what denial of
service is well and good if you do not
know then let's know it now denial of
service is a user trying to or
maliciously making attempt to access a
website or an application the user would
actually create multiple sessions and he
would occupy all the sessions and he
would not let legitimate users access
the servers so he's in turn denying the
service for the user a quick picture
review of what denial of services now
look at it these users instead of making
one connection they are making multiple
connections and there are cheap software
programs available that would actually
trigger connections from different
computers in the internet with different
mac addresses so everything kind of
looks legitimate for the server and it
would accept those connections and it
will keep the sessions open the actual
users won't be able to use them so
that's denying the service for the
actual users denial of service all right
and distributed denial of service is uh
generating attacks from multiple places
you know from a distributed environment
so that's distributed denial of service
so the tools the native tools that helps
us to prevent the denial of service
attacks in aws is cloud shield
and web access firewall aw swap now they
are the major ones they are designed to
mitigate a denial of service if your
website is often bothered by denial of
service then we should be using aws
shield or aws vaf and there are a couple
of other tools that also does when i say
that also does denial of service is not
their primary job but you could use them
for denial of service route 53's purpose
is to provide dns cloudfront is to
provide caching elastic load balancer
elbs work is to provide load balancing
vpc is to create and secure a virtual
private environment but they also
support mitigating denial of service but
not to the extent you would get in aws
shield and aws web so aws shield and
waff are the primary ones but the rest
can also be used to mitigate distributed
denial of service the other tricky
question is
this actually will test your familiarity
with the region and the services
available in the region so when you're
trying to provision a service in a
particular region you're not seeing the
service in that region how do we go
about fixing it or how do we go about
using the service in the cloud it's a
tricky question and if you have not gone
through such situation you can totally
blow it away you really need to have a
good understanding on regions the
services available in those regions and
what if a particular service is not
available how to go about doing it the
answer is not all services are available
in all regions anytime amazon announces
a new service they don't immediately
publish them on all regions they start
small and as in when the traffic
increases as and when it becomes more
likeable to the customers they actually
move the service to different regions so
as you see in this picture within
america north virginia has more services
compared to ohio or compared to north
california so within not america itself
north virginia is the preferred one so
similarly there are preferred regions
within europe middle east and africa and
preferred regions within asia pacific so
anytime we don't see a service in a
particular region chances that the
service is not available in that region
yet we got to check the documentation
and find the nearest region that offers
that service and start using the service
from that region now you might think
well if i'm looking for a service in
asia let's say in mumbai and if it is
not available why not simply switch to
north virginia and start using it you
could but you know that's going to add
more latency to your application so
that's why we need to check for
application which is check for region
which is very near to the place where
you want to serve your customers and
find nearest region instead of always
going back to north virginia and
deploying an application in north
virginia again there's a place there's a
link in aws.com that you can go and look
for services available in different
region and that's exactly what you're
seeing here and if your service is not
available in a particular region switch
to the other region that provides your
service the nearest other region that
provides that service and start using
service from there
with the
coming up of cloud a lot of companies
have turned down their monitoring team
instead they want to go with the
monitorings that cloud provides you know
nobody wants to or at least many people
don't want to go through the hassle of
at least new startups and new companies
that are thinking of having a monitoring
environment now they don't want to go
with traditional knock monitoring
instead they would like to leverage aws
monitorings available because it
monitors a lot of stuff not just the
availability but it monitors a lot of
stuff like failures errors it also
triggers emails stuff like that so how
do you actually set up a monitor to
website how to set up a monitor to
monitor the website metrics in real time
in aws the simple way anytime you have a
question about monitoring cloudwatch
should strike your mind because
cloudwatch is meant for monitoring is
meant for collecting metrics is meant
for providing graphical representation
of what's going on in a particular
network at a particular point of time so
cloudwatch cloudwatch helps us to
monitor applications and using
cloudwatch we can monitor the state
changes not only the state changes the
auto scaling life cycle events anytime
there are there are more services added
there is a reduction in the number of
servers because of less usage and very
informative messages can be received
through cloud watch any cloud watch can
now support scheduled events if you want
to schedule anything cloudwatch has an
event that would schedule an action all
right schedule a trigger time based not
incident based you know anything
happening and then you get an action
happening that's incident based on the
other hand you can simply schedule few
things on time based so that's possible
with cloud watch so this cloud watch
integrates very well with a lot of other
services like notifications for
notifying the user or for notifying the
administrator about it and it can
integrate well with lambda so to trigger
an action anytime you are designing an
auto healing environment this cloud
watch can actually monitor and send an
email if we are integrating it with sns
simple notification service or this
cloud watch can monitor and
based on what's happening it can trigger
an event in lambda and that would in
turn run a function till the environment
comes back to normal so cloudwatch
integrates well with a lot of other aw
services
all right so cloudwatch has
three statuses green when everything is
going good yellow when the service is
degraded and red when the service is not
available green is good so we don't have
to do anything about it but anytime
there is an ello the picture that we're
looking at it's actually calling and
lambda function to debug the application
and to fix it and anytime there's a red
alert it immediately notifies the
owner of the application about well the
service is down and here is the report
that i have here is the metrics that
i've collected about the service stuff
like that if the job role requires you
to manage the servers as well there are
certain job roles which are on the
system side there are certain job roles
which is development plus system side
now you're responsible for the
application and the server as well so if
that's the case you might be tested with
some basic questions like the different
types of virtualization in aws and what
are the difference between them all
right the three major types of
virtualization are
hvm which is hardware virtual machine
the other one is pv para virtualization
and the third one is pv on hvm para
virtualization on hardware virtual
module
all right the difference between them or
actually describing them is actually the
difference between them hvm it's
actually a fully virtualized hardware
you know the whole hardware is
virtualized and all virtual machines act
separate from each other and these vms
are booted by executing master boot
record in the root block and when we
talk about para virtualization paragraph
is actually the special boot loader
which boots the pva mice and when we
talk about pv on hvm it's it's actually
the marriage between hvm and pv and this
para virtualization on hvm in other
words pv on hvm it actually helps
operating system take advantage in
storage and the network input output
available through the host
another good question is name some of
the services that are not region
specific now
you've been thought that all services
are within a region and some services
are within an availability zone for
example ec2 is within an availability
zone ebs is within an availability zone
s3 is region specific dynamodb is region
specific stuff like that vpc is both
availability and
region specific meaning you know subnets
are availability zone specific and vpc
is region specific stuff like that so
you might have thought you might have
learned in that combination but there
could be some tricky questions that
tests you how well you have understood
the region non-region and availability
non-availability services i should say
there are services that are not region
specific that would be iam so we can't
have im for every availability zone and
for every region which means you know
users will have to use one username and
password for one region and anytime they
switch to another region they will have
to use another username and password
that that's more work and that's not a
good design as well authentication has
to be global so im is a global service
and which means its not region specific
on the other hand route 53 is again a
regional specific so we can't have a
route 53 for every region route 53 is
not a region specific service it's a
global service and it's one application
users access from everywhere or from
every part of the world so we can't have
one url or one dns name for each region
if your application is a global
application and then web application
firewall works well with cloudfront then
cloudfront is a region based service so
the web application firewall it's not
region specific service it's a global
service and cloudfront is again a global
service though you can you know cache
content on a continent and country basis
it's still considered a global service
right it's not bound to any region so
when you activate cloud front you're
activating it away from region or
availability zone so when you're
activating a web application firewall
because it's not a region specific
service you're activating it away from
availability zone and regions
so a quick recap i am users groups roles
and accounts they are global services
they can be used globally route 53
services are offered at edge locations
and they are global as well web
application firewall a service that
protects our web application from common
web exploits they are global service as
well cloud front cloudfront is global
content delivery network cdn and they
are offered at edge locations which are
a global service in other words
non-region specific service or beyond
region service all right this is another
good question as well in the project
that you are being interviewed if they
really want to secure their environment
using nat or if they are already
securing their environment using nat by
any of these two methods like nat
gateway or nat instances you can expect
this question what are the difference
between an ad gateway and that instances
now they both saw the same thing all
right so they're not two different
services
trying to achieve two different things
they both serve the same thing but still
they do have differences in them right
on a high level they both achieve
providing netting for the service behind
it but the difference comes when we talk
about
the availability of it
that gateway is a managed service by
amazon whereas nat instance is managed
by us now i'm talking about the third
point maintenance here nat gateway is
managed by amazon that instance is
managed by us and availability of nat
gateway is very high and availability of
that instance is
less compared to the nat gateway because
it's managed by us you know it's on an
ec2 instance which could actually fail
and if it fails we'll have to relaunch
it but if it is not gateway if something
happens to that service amazon would
take care of reprovisioning it and
talking about bandwidth it can burst up
to 75 gigabits now traffic through the
net gateway can burst up to 75 gigabits
but for that instance it actually
depends on the server that we launched
and if we are launching a t2 micro it
barely gets any bandwidth so there's a
difference there and the performance
because it's highly available because of
the bigger pipe 75 gigabits now the
performance of the net gateway is very
high but the performance of the nat
instance is going to be average again it
depends on the size of the nat instance
that we pick and billing a billing for
nat gateway is the number of gateways
that we provision and the duration
for which we use the nat gateway but
billing for that instance is number of
instance and the type of instance that
we use of course number of instance
duration and the type of instance that
we use
security in that gateway cannot be uh
assigned meaning it already comes with
full packed security but in that
instance security is a bit customizable
i can go and change the security because
it's a server managed by me or managed
by us i can always change the security
well allow this allow don't allow this
stuff like that size and load of the
night gateway is uniform but the size
and the load of the
that instance changes as per add gateway
is a fixed product but not instance can
be small instance can be a big instance
so the size and the load through it
varies
right the other question you could get
asked is what are the difference between
stopping and terminating an ec2 instance
now you will be able to answer only if
you have worked on environments where
you have your instance stopped and where
you have your instance terminated if you
have only used lab and are attending the
interview chances are that you might you
always lost when answering this question
it might look like both are the same
well stopping and terminating both are
the same but there is a difference in it
so when you stop an instance it actually
performs a normal shutdown on the
instance and it simply moves the
instance to the stopped state but when
you actually terminate the instance the
instance is moved to this stop state the
evs volumes that are attached to it are
deleted and removed and we'll never be
able to recover them again so that's a
big difference between stopping and
terminating an instance if you're
thinking of using the instance again
along with the data in it you should
only be thinking of stopping the
instance but you should be terminating
the instance only if you want to get rid
of that instance forever
if you are being interviewed for an
architect level position or a junior
architect level position or even a cloud
consultant level position or even in an
engineering position this is a very
common question that gets asked what are
the different types of easy to instances
based on their cost or based on how we
pay them all right they're all compute
capacity for example the different types
are on demand instances spot instances
and reserved instances it kind of looks
the same they all provide the compute
capacity they all provide the same type
of hardwares for us but if you are
looking at cost saving or optimizing
cost in our environment we got to be
very careful about which one are we
picking now we might think that well
i'll go with on-demand instance because
i pay on a per hour basis which is cheap
you know i can use them anytime i want
and anytime i don't want i can simply
get rid of it by terminating it you're
right but if the requirement is to use
the service for one year the requirement
is to use the service for three years
then you'll be wasting a lot of money
buying on-demand instances you'll be
wasting a lot of money paying on an
hourly basis instead we should be going
for reserved instance where we can
reserve the capacity for the complete
one year or complete three years and
save huge amount in buying reserved
instances all right so under man is
cheap to start with if you're only
planning to use it for a short while but
if you're planning to run it for a long
while then we should be going for
reserved instance that is what is cost
efficient so spot instance is cheaper
than on-demand instance and there are
different use cases for spot instance as
well so let's look at one after the
other the on-demand instance the
on-demand instance is purchased at a
fixed rate per r this is very short term
and irregular workloads and for testing
for development on demand instance is a
very good use case we should be using on
demand for production spot instance spot
instance allows users to purchase ec2 at
a reduced price and any time we have
more instances we can always go and sell
it in spot instances i'm referring to
anytime we have more reserved instances
we can always sell them in spot instance
catalog and the way we buy spot instance
is we actually put a budget this is how
much i'm willing to pay all right would
you be able to give service within this
cost so anytime the price comes down and
meets the cost that we have put in will
be assigned an instance and anytime the
price shoots up the instance will be
taken away from us but in case of
on-demand instances we have bought that
instance for that particular r and it
stays with us but with spot instances it
varies based on the price if you meet
the price you get the instance if you
don't meet the price it goes away to
somebody else and the spot instance
availability is actually based on supply
and demand in the market there's no
guarantee that you will get spot
instance at all time all right so that's
a caveat there you should be familiar
with that's a caveat that you should be
aware when you are proposing somebody
that we can go for spot instance and
save money it's not always going to be
available if you want your spot instance
to be available to you then we need to
carefully watch the history of the price
of the spot instance now how much was it
last month and how much was it how much
is it this month so how can i code or
how much can i code stuff like that so
you got to look at those history before
you propose somebody that well we're
going to save money using spot instance
on the other hand reserved instance
provide cost savings for the company we
can opt for reserved instances for you
know one year or three years there are
actually three types of reserved
instances light medium and heavy
reserved instances they are based on the
amount that we would be paying and cost
benefit also depends with reserved
instance the cost benefit also depends
based on are we doing all upfront or no
upfront or partial payment then split
the rest as monthly payments so there
are many purchase options available but
overall if you're looking at using an
application for the next one year and
three years you should not be going for
on-demand instance you should be going
for reserved instance and that's what
gives you the cost benefit
and in an error-based interview
sometimes you might be asked you know
how you interact with the aws
environment are you using cli are you
using console and depending on your
answer whether console or a cli the
panelist put a score okay this person is
cli specific this person is console
specific or this person has used aws
environment through the sdk stuff like
that so this question tests whether you
are a cli person or an console person
and the question goes like this how do
you set up ssh agent forwarding so that
you do not have to copy the key every
time you log in if you have used puri
anytime if you want to log into an ec2
instance you will have to put the ip and
the port number along with that you will
have to map or we will have to map the
key in the puri and this has to be done
every time that's what we would have
done in our lab environments right but
in production environment using the same
key or mapping the same key again and
again every time it's actually an hassle
it's considered as a blocker so you
might want to cache it you might want to
permanently add it in your putty session
so you can immediately log in and start
using it so here in the place where you
would actually map the private key
there's a quick button that actually
fixes or that actually binds your ssh to
your putty instance so we can enable ssh
agent forwarding that will actually bind
our key to the ssh and next time when we
try to log in you don't have to always
go through mapping the key and trying to
log in all right this question what are
solaris and ax operating systems are
they available with aws that question
generally gets asked to test how
familiar are you with the
amis available how familiar are you with
ec2 how familiar are you with the ec2
hardwares available that basically test
that now the first question or the first
thought that comes to your mind is well
everything is available with aws i've
seen windows i've seen ubuntu i've seen
red hat i've seen amazon amis and if i
don't see my operating system there i
can always go to marketplace and try
them if i don't find a marketplace i can
always go to community and try them so a
lot of amis available that lot of
operating systems available i will be
able to find solaris and ax but that's
not the case solar s and ax are not
available with aws that's because
solaris uses a different and solaris
does not support the architecture does
not support public cloud currently the
same goes for ax as well and they run on
power cpu and not on intel and as of now
amazon does not provide power machines
this should not be confused with the hpc
which is a high performance computing
should not be confused with that now
these are different hardwares different
cpu itself that the cloud providers they
do not provide yet another question you
could get asked in organizations that
would want to automate their
infrastructure using amazon native
services would be how do you actually
recover an ec2 instance or auto recover
an ec2 instance when it fails well we
know that ec2 instances are considered
as immutable meaning irreparable we
don't spend time fixing
bugs in an os stuff like that you know
once an ec2 instance crashes like it
goes on a ospanic or there are various
reasons why it would fail so we don't
have to really worry about fixing it we
can always relaunch that instance and
that would fix it but what if it happens
at two o'clock in the night what if it
happens that during a weekend when
nobody's in office
looking or monitoring those instances so
you would want to automate that not only
on a weekend or during midnight but it's
general practice good to automate it so
you could face this question how do you
actually automate an ec2 instance once
it fails and the answer to that question
is using cloudwatch we can recover the
instance so as you see there is an alarm
threshold a set in cloudwatch and once
the threshold is met meaning if there is
an error if there is a failure if the
ec2 instance is not responding for a
certain while we can set an alarm and
once the alarm is met let's say the cpu
utilization stayed high for five minutes
right it's not taking any new
connections or the instance is not
pinging for five minutes or in this case
it's two minutes it's not pinging so
it's not going to respond connection so
in those cases you would want to
automatically recover that ec2 instance
by rebooting the instance all right now
look at this the take this action
section under the action so there we
have a bunch of options like recover
this instance meaning reboot the
instance so that's how we would recover
the other two options are beyond the
scope of the question but still you can
go ahead and apply just like i'm going
to do it so the other option is stop the
instance that's very useful when you
want to stop instances that are having
low utilizations nobody's using the
system as of now you don't want them to
be running and wasting the cloud
expenditure so you can actually set an
alarm that stops the ec2 instance that's
having low utilization so somebody was
working in an instance and they left it
without or they forgot to shut down that
instance and it gets i mean they will
only use it again the next day morning
so in between there could be like 12
hours that the system is running idle
nobody's using it and you're paying for
it so you can identify such instances
and actually stop them when the cpu
utilization is low meaning nobody is
using it the other one is to terminate
let's say you want to give system to
somebody temporarily and you don't want
them to hand the system back to you
right this is actually an idea in other
words this is actually the scenario so
you hand over a system to somebody and
when they're done they're done we can
actually terminate the system so you
could instruct the other person to
terminate the system when they're done
and they could forget then the instance
could be running forever or you can
monitor the system after the specified
time is over and you can terminate the
system or best part you can automate the
system termination so you assign a
system to somebody and then turn on this
cloud watch action to terminate the
instance when the cpu is low for like
two hours meaning they've already left
or cpu is low for 30 minutes meaning
they've already left stuff like that so
that's possible and if you're getting
hired for an system side architect or
even on the sysop site you could face
this question what are the common and
different types of ami designs there are
a lot of ami designs the question is the
common ones and the difference between
them so the common ones are the full
back a mice and the other one is just
enough os ami j e os ami and the other
one is hybrid type amis so let's look at
the difference between them the full
backed ami just like the name says it's
fully baked it's
ready to use ami and this is the
simplest ami to deploy can be a bit
expensive it can be a bit cumbersome
because you'll have to do a lot of work
beforehand you could use the ami so a
lot of planning a lot of thought process
will go into it and the ami is ready to
use right you hand over the ami to
somebody and it's ready to use or if you
want to reuse the ami it's already ready
for you to use so that's full baked ami
the other one is just enough operating
system ami just like the name says it
has
i mean as you can also see in the
diagram or in the picture it covers a
part of the os all bootstraps are
already packed properly and the security
monitoring logging and the other stuff
are configured at the time of deployment
or at the time you would be using it so
not much thought process will go in here
the only focus is on choosing the
operating system and what goes the
operating system specific agents or
bootstraps that goes into the operating
system that's all we worry about the
advantage of this is it's flexible
meaning you can choose to install
additional softwares at the time of
deploying but that's going to require an
additional expertise on the person who
will be using the ami so that's another
overhead there but the advantage is that
it's kind of flexible i can change the
configurations during the time of
deployment the other one is a hybrid ami
now the hybrid ami actually falls in
between the fully baked ami and just
enough operating system options so these
amis have some features of the big type
and some features of the just enough os
type so as you see the security
monitoring logging
are
packed in that ami and the runtime
environments are installed during the
time of a deployment so this is where
the strict company policies would go
into the ami company policies like you
gotta log this you gotta monitor this
these are the ports that generally gets
open in all the systems stuff like that
so they strictly go into the ami and
sits in an ami format and during
deployment you have the flexibility of
choosing the different runtime and the
application that sits in an ec2 instance
another very famous question you would
face in an interview is how can you
recover login to an ec2 instance to
which you lost the key well we know that
if the key is lost we can't recover it
there are some organizations that
integrate their ec2 instances with an 80
that's different all right so you can go
and reset the password and the 80 and
you will be able to log into the new
password but here the specific tricky
question is you are using a key to log
in and how do you recover if you have
lost the key generally companies would
have made a backup of the key so we can
pick from the backup but here the
specific question is we have lost the
key literally no backups on the key at
all so how can we log in and we know
that we can't log into the instance
without the key present with us so the
steps to recover is that make the
instance use another key and use that
key to log in once the key is lost it's
lost forever we won't be able to recover
it you can't raise the ticket with
amazon not possible they're not going to
help it's beyond the scope so make the
instance use another key it's only the
key that's the problem you still have
valid data in it you got to recover the
data it's just the key that's having the
problem so we can actually focus on the
key part alone and change the key and
that will allow us to log in so how do
we do it step by step procedure so first
verify the ec2 config service is running
in that instance if you want you can
actually beforehand install the easy to
config in that service or you can
actually make the easy to config run
through the console just a couple of
button clicks and that will make the
easy to configure run in that ec2
instance and then detach the root volume
for that instance of course it's going
to require a stop and start to detach
the root volume from the instance attach
the root volume to another instance as a
temporary volume or it could be a
temporary instance that you've launched
only to fix this issue and then log in
to that instance and to that particular
volume and modify the configuration file
configuration file modify it to use the
new key and then move the root volume
back to its original position and
restart the instance and now the
instance is going to have the new key
and you also have the new key with which
you can log in so that's how we go ahead
and fix it now let's move on to some
product specific or s3 product specific
questions a general perception is s3 and
ebs can be used interchangeably and the
interviewer would want to test your
knowledge on s3 and evs well ebs uses s3
that's true but they can't be
interchangeably used so you might face
this question what are some key
differences between aws s3 and ebs well
the differences are s3 is an object
store meaning you can't install anything
in it you can store drive files but you
can't actually install in it it's not a
file system but ebs is a file system you
can install services i mean install
applications in it and that's going to
run stuff like that and talking about
performance s3 is much faster and ebs is
super faster when accessing from the
instance because from the instance if
you need to access s3 you'll actually
have to go out through the internet and
access the s3 or s3 is an external
service very external service you'll
have to go through or you'll have to go
outside of your vpc to access s3 s3 does
not come under a vpc but ebs comes under
a vpc it's on the same vpc so you would
be able to use it kind of locally
compared to s3 ebs is very local
so that way it's going to be faster and
redundancy talking about redundancy of
s3 and ebs s3 is
replicated the data in s3 is replicated
across the data centers but ebs is
replicated within the data center
meaning s3 is replicated across
availability zones ebs is within an
availability zone so that way the
redundancy is a bit less in ebs in other
words redundancy is higher in s3 than
eps and talking about security of s3 is3
can be made private as well as public
meaning anybody can access s3 from
anywhere in the internet that's possible
with s3 but ebs can only only be
accessed when attached to an ec2
instance right just one instance can
access it whereas s3 is publicly
directly accessible the other question
related to s3 security is how do you
allow access to a user to assert in a
user to a certain bucket which means
this user is not having access to s3 at
all but this user needs to be given
access to a certain bucket how do we do
it the same case applies to servers as
well in few cases there could be an
instance where a person is new to the
team and you actually don't want them to
access the production service now he's
in the production group and by default
he or she is granted access to that
server but you specifically want to deny
access to that production server till
the time he or she is matured enough to
access or understand the process
understand the do's and don'ts before
they can put their hands on the
production server so how do we go about
doing it so first we would categorize
our instances well these are critical
instances these are normal instances and
we would actually uh put a tag on them
that's how we categorize right so you
put attack on them put attacks saying
well they are highly critical they are
medium critical and they are not
critical at all still there in
production stuff like that and then you
would pick the users who wants to or who
should be or should not be given access
to a certain server and you would
actually allow the user to access or not
access servers based on a specific tag
in other words you can use actually tags
in in the previous step we put tags on
the critical server right so you would
define that this user is not going to
use this tag all right this user is not
allowed to use the resources with this
stack so that's how you would make your
step forward so you would allow or deny
based on the tags that you have put so
in this case he or she will not be
allowed to servers which are tagged
critical servers so that's how you allow
deny access to them and the same goes
for bucket as well or if an organization
is excessively using s3 for their data
storage because of the benefit that it
provides the cost and the
durability you might get asked this
question which is organizations would
replicate the data from one region to
another region for additional data
durability and for having data
redundancy not only for that they would
also do that for dr purposes for
disaster recovery if the whole region is
down you still have the data available
somewhere else and you can pick and use
it some organizations would store data
in different regions for compliance
reasons to provide low latency access to
their users who are local to that region
stuff like that so when companies do
replication how do you make sure that
there is consistency in the replication
how do you make sure that the
replication is not failing and the data
gets transferred for sure and there are
logs for that replication this is
something that the companies would use
where they're excessively using s3 and
they're fully relying on the replication
in running their business
and the way we could do it is we can set
up a replication monitor it's actually a
set of tools that we could use together
to make sure that the cloud replication
a region level replication is happening
properly so this is how it happens now
on this side on the left hand side we
have the region 1 and on the right hand
side we have region 2 and region 1 is
the source bucket and region 2 is the
destination bucket all right so object
is put in the source bucket and it has
to go directly to the region to bucket
or or made a copy in the region to
bucket and the problem is sometimes it
fails and there is no consistency
between them so the way you would do it
is connect these services together and
create and cross replication or cross
region replication monitor that actually
monitors that actually monitors your
environment so there are cloud watch
that make sure that the data is
move no data is failing again there's
cloud watch on the other end make sure
that the data is moving and then we have
the logs generated through cloudtrail
and that's actually written in dynamodb
and if there is an error if something is
failing you get notified through an sms
or you get notified through an email
using the sns service so that's how we
could leverage these tools and set up
and cross region replication monitor
that actually monitors your data
replication
some common issues that company
companies face in vpc is that we all
know that i can use route 53 to resolve
an ip address externally from the
internet but by default the servers
won't connect to the other servers using
our custom dns name that it does not do
that by default so it's actually a
problem there are some additional things
that as an administrator or as an
architect or as a person who uses it you
will have to do and that's what we're
going to discuss so the question could
be a vpc is not resolving the server
through the dns you can access it
through the ip but not through the dns
name and what could be the issue and how
do you go about fixing it and you will
be able to answer this question only if
you have done it already it's a quick
and simple step by default vpc does not
allow that's the default feature and we
will have to enable the
dns hostname resolution before
now this is for the custom dns not for
the default dns that comes along this is
for the custom dns so we will have to
enable the dns host name resolution so
our will have to enable dns hostname
resolution so they actually resolve
let's say i want to connect to a
server1.simplylearn.com by default it's
not allowed but if i enable this option
then i will be able to connect to server
one simplylearn.com
if a company has vpcs in different
regions and they have a head office in a
central place and the rest of them are
branch offices and they are connecting
to the head office for access or you
know for saving data or for accessing
certain files or certain data or storing
data all right so they would actually
mimic the hub and spoke topology where
you have the vpc which is centrally in
an accessible region a centrally
accessible region and then you would
have a local vpcs or branch offices in
different other regions and they get
connected to the vpc in the central
location and the question is how do you
actually connect the multiple sites to a
vpc and make communication happen
between them by default it does not do
that we know that vpcs they need to be
paired between them in order to access
the resources let's look at this picture
right so i have like a customer network
or branch offices in different parts and
they get connected to a vpc that's fine
so what we have achieved is those
different offices
the remote offices they are connecting
to the vpc and they're talking but they
can't connect or they can't talk to each
other that's what we have built but the
requirement is the traffic
needs to or they should be able to talk
to each other but they should not have
direct connection between them which
means that they will have to come and
hit the vpc and then
reach the other customer network which
is in los angeles or which is in new
york right that's the requirement so
that's possible with some architecting
in the cloud so that's using vpn cloud
hub you look at this dotted lines which
actually allows customers or which
actually allows the
corporate networks to talk to each other
through the vpc again by default it
doesn't happen cloud hub is an
architecture that we should be using to
make this happen and what's the
advantage of it as a central office or
as the headquarters office which is in
the vpc or headquarters data center
which is in the vpc you have control or
the vpc has control on who talks to who
and what traffic can talk to i mean what
traffic can be routed to the other head
office stuff like that that centralized
control is on the vpc the other question
you could get asked is neiman explain
some security products and features
available in vpc well vpc itself is an
security service it provides security
service to the application but how do
you actually secure the vpc itself
that's the question and yes there are
products that can actually secure the
vpc or the vpc delivers those products
to secure the application
access to the vpc is restricted through
a network access control list all right
so that's and security product in vpc
and a vpc has security groups that
protects the instances from unwanted
inbound and outbound traffic and network
access control list protects the subnets
from unwanted inbound and outbound
access and there are flow logs we can
capture in vpc
that captures incoming and outgoing
traffic through a vpc which will be used
for later analysis as in what's the
traffic pattern what's the behavior of
the traffic pattern and stuff like that
so there are some security products and
features available in vpc now how do you
monitor vpc vpc is a very important
concept very important service as well
everything sits in a vpc most of the
service sits in a vpc except for lambda
and s3 and dynamodb and couple of other
services most of them sit in a vpc for
security reason so how do you monitor
your vpc how do you gain some visibility
on your vpc well we can gain visibility
on our vpc using vpc flow log that's the
basic service as you see it actually
captures what's allowed what's not
allowed stuff like that which ip is
allowed which ip is not allowed stuff
like that so we can gather it and we can
use that for analysis and the other one
is cloud watch and cloud watch logs the
data transfers that happen so this is
you know who gets allowed and who does
not get allowed i mean the flow logs is
who is allowed and who's not allowed
that kind of detail and cloud watch
gives information about the data
transfer how much data is getting
transferred we can actually pick unusual
data transfers if there is a certain
hike in the graph there's a sudden hike
and something happens at 12 on a regular
basis and you weren't expecting it
there's something suspicious it could be
valid backups it could be a malicious
activity as well so that's how you know
by looking at cloudwatch logs and
cloudwatch dashboard now let's talk
about multiple choice questions when
going for an interview you might
sometimes find yourself that the company
is conducting an online test based on
the score they can put you to a panelist
and then they would take it forward so
we thought it will also include multiple
choice questions to help you better
handle such situation if you come across
all right when you find yourself in such
situation the key to clear them is to
understand the question properly read
between the lines that's what they say
you know there can be like a big
paragraph with three lines or ten lines
you really got to understand what the
question is about and then try to find
answer for that question so that's a
thumb rule number one and then the
second rule is try to compare and
contrast the services
mentioned or try to compare and contrast
the answers you can easily read out one
or two answers and then you will be left
with only two answers to decide from you
know so that also helps you with time
and that's all that also helps you with
some precision in your answer so number
one read between the lines number two
compare and contrast the services and
you'll be able to easily weed out the
wrong ones so let's try answering this
question suppose you are a game designer
and you want to develop a game with a
single digit millisecond latency which
of the following database services would
you choose so we know that the following
are database services are good enough
all right and it talks about millisecond
latency that's a key point and the third
thing is it's a game could be a mobile
game it's a game that you are trying to
design and you need millisecond latency
and it has to be a database all right so
let's talk about the options available
rds rds is a database for sure is it
good for
a game design we'll come back to that
neptune uh neptune is a graph a database
service in amazon so that's kind of out
of the equation and snowball is actually
a storage right it's it's a transport
medium i would say so that's again out
of the equation so the tie is between
rds and dynamodb if we need to talk
about rds rds is an a platform as a
service it provides cost efficient
resizable capacity but it's an sql
database meaning the tables are kind of
strict you know it's good for banking
and other type of applications but not
really good for anything that has to do
with
gaming so the only option left is
dynamodb again it's the right answer
dynamodb is actually an fast and
flexible nosql database service and it
provides a single digit millisecond
latency at any scale and it's a database
at the same time it's a key value store
model database so the right answer is
dynamodb all right let's look at the
next question if you need to perform
real-time monitoring of aws services and
get actionable insights which service
would you use all right let's list the
services so it talks about real-time
monitoring firewall manager what does it
provide now firewall manager is not
really a monitor just like the name says
it's a manager it manages multiple
firewalls and aws guard duty is an
thread detection service it does
monitoring it does continuously monitor
our environment but it monitors for
threats all right only threats now let's
talk about cloud watch a cloud watch is
a service that helps to track metrics
it's a service that is used
to
monitor the environment and give us a
system-wide visibility and also it helps
us to store logs so at the moment it
kind of looks like that could be the
right answer we don't know that yet but
i mean we have one more option left
that's uh ebs so what's ebs ebs is a
block storage elastic block store if we
abbreviate ebs it's elastic block store
so all three of them are easily out of
the question the first one is to manage
second one is to find threats
of course it does monitoring so there's
i mean if there is one relation between
cloud watch and guard duty that's
monitoring so easily we can actually
find ourselves slipped towards picking
guard duty but know that guard duty is
only for gaining security inside but not
about gaining aws service
inside so cloudwatch is a service that
helps us to get a system wide or an aws
wide or an account wide it has number of
metrics we can monitor and get a very
good insight of how a service is
performing be it cpu be it ram beat
network utilization beat
connection failures cloudwatch is a
service that helps us perform a
real-time monitoring and get some
actionable insights on the services all
right let's talk about this 33rd
question as a web developer you are
developing an app especially for the
mobile platform all right there is a
mention that this is especially for the
mobile platform so a lot of services
gets filtered out mobile platform right
which of the following lets you add user
sign up sign in and access control to
your web and mobile app quickly and
easily all right so this is all about
signing in to your mobile app so if we
need to read between the lines that's
how we can read sign up or sign in into
a mobile platform all right so we have
like four options here uh shield aws
massey aws inspector amazon cognito so
let's try to weed out services which are
not relevant to it so what's aws shield
aws shield is actually a service that
provides a ddos mitigation or ddos
protection denial of service protection
it's a security feature let's talk about
the second option aws maxi is again a
security service that uses machine
learning to automatically discover and
classify the data it again talks about
security and this security is all about
encrypting or saving the data does not
come close with signing up and mobile
platform all right let's talk about the
other one aws inspector now aws
inspector has something to do with apps
it definitely has something to do with
apps so kind of looks like that's
relevant as of now so it actually helps
with the improving the security and
compliance of the apps that we deploy in
the cloud so kind of looks like it could
be because it has to do with apps the
last one cognito now cognito is a
service that actually lets the
administrator to have control access
over web and mobile apps and it's a
service that helps us to sign up and
assign in to an mobile and web app so
that very much looks like we found the
answer so cognito is a service that
helps web app and mobile app for sign up
and signing in and also gives the
administrator to have control over who
has access control over the web and the
mobile app pretty much we found it so
it's cognito cognito is a service that
helps us to set up sign up sign in and
have access control over the users who
would be using our mobile and web app
all right how about this question you
are an ml engineer or a machine learning
engineer who is on the lookout for a
solution that will discover sensitive
information that your enterprise stores
in aws and then uses nlp to classify
that data and provide business related
insights which among the following
services would you choose so we have a
bunch of services that's going to help
us achieve or one of it is going to help
us achieve the above requirement so it's
a service that deals with machine
learning you're a machine learning
engineer who's looking for a service
that
will help you to discover information at
your enterprise store so we're talking
about storage discover information in
store and then classify uh the data
depending on severity the sensitivity
classify the data so which service is
that so firewall manager just like the
name says it's a manager and the aws iam
if we abbreviate it it's a identity and
access management so it's identity and
access management nothing to do with
identifying sensitive data and managing
it so the first two is already out of
the equation then the aw is massy we
already had a quick definition
description for aws massey that it's
actually a security service that uses
machine learning it kind of looks like
it could be it it's a security service
that uses machine learning and it
discovers and classifies the sensitive
information not only that it does not
stop there it goes beyond and protects
the sensitive data aws massey kind of
looks like but we still have one more
option to look at which is cloud hms
cloud hms is also a security service
kind of looks like that could be the
answer as well and it enables us to
generate encryption keys and save the
data so kind of fifty percent of it it's
a security service it encrypts helps us
protect the data but aws maxi is right
on spot it's a machine learning service
it helps us to classify the data and
also to protect the data so the answer
for this question would be aws messy so
hope you kind of get it how this is
going so first we apply the thumb rule
identify the question that's being asked
read between the lines and then try to
find the service that meets your
requirement then finding the service is
by first weeding out the wrong ones
recollect everything that you've learned
about the service and see how well that
matches with those hints that you have
picked up and if that doesn't match weed
that out then you'll end up with two
just to to decide from at some point and
then it becomes easy for you to decide
click on the question submit it and then
move on to the other question in your
interview all right so how about this
one you are a system administrator in
your company which is running most of
its infrastructure on aws you are
required to
track your users and keep a look on how
your users are being authenticated all
right so this is where the problem
statement starts but you need to keep
track of how your users are being
authenticated and you wish to create and
manage aws users and use permissions to
allow and deny their access to the aws
resources right so you are to give them
permission number one and then i mean if
we put them in the right order first
giving them permissions and then
tracking their usage let's see which of
the service will help us achieve it iam
is a service that
helps us to
looking at the permissions we can
actually predict whether the user or the
group will have servers or not so that
helps us to get a track of who is able
to use who's not able to use certain
servers and all that stuff so it kind of
looks like but we have other three
options left let's look at aws firewall
manager just like the name says it's
actually a firewall manager it helps us
to manage multiple firewalls simple as
that and shield is a service it's a
service that's used to protect denial of
service or distributed denial of service
an api gateway is a service that makes
it easy for developers to create publish
maintain and monitor and secure api so i
mean it's completely on the api side
very less on user and how you
authenticate your user we can get that
by looking at the name itself right if
you abbreviate it or if you if you try
to find a definition for the name api
gateway you would get it it has to do
with api but if you aggregate aws iam
its identity and access management
pretty much meets the requirement for
the problem statement about its aws
identity and access management that's
the right answer all right let's look at
this one if you want to allocate various
private and public ip address in order
to make them communicate
with the internet and other instances
you will use this service which of the
following is this service so it talks
about using public and private ip
address so this service uses ip address
and then this service helps us to
allow and deny connections to the
internet and to the other instances so
you get the question is it let's pick
the service that helps us achieve it
route 53 route 53 is actually a dns
service right so it's not a service
that's used to allow or deny no it does
not do that vpc vpc uses public and
private ip address yes so kind of looks
like a vpc helps us
to allow i mean the security in vpc the
security group the network access
control list in a vpc that outing table
in a vpc that actually helps us to allow
or deny a connection to a particular ip
address or to a particular service
within the vpc or outside of the vpc so
as of now it kind of looks like it could
be but let's look at the other services
what if if we find a service that
closely matches to the above requirement
than the amazon vpc
gateway api gateway we know that it's a
managed service that makes it easy for
developers to create
publish maintain and monitor apis and
secure api so that has completely do
with api not with ib cloudfront we know
about cloudfront that it's a content
delivery network and it provides global
distribution of
servers where our content can be cached
it could be video or bulk media or
anything else they can be cached locally
so users can easily access them and
download them easily right so that's
cloud front now at this point after
looking at all four it looks like vpc is
the right answer and in fact vpc is the
right answer vpc has public ip address
vpc can help us with private ip address
vpc can be used to allow deny connection
based on the security group access
control list and routing table it has so
that's right answer is vpc all right how
about this one this platform as a
service or platform as a db service
provides us with the cost efficient and
resizable capacity while automating time
consuming administrative tasks so this
question is very clear it's a db service
we got to look for and it's a service
that can provide
automating some of the time consuming
tasks it has to be resizable at the same
time so let's talk about amazon rational
database it's a database
kind of matches the requirement we can
resize it as and when needed
all right looks like it's a fit as of
now it actually automates some of the
time consuming work looks like it's a
fit as of now let's move on to elastic
cache and then try to see if
that matches the definition that
we've figured out about elastic cache
it's actually a caching service it's
again an in-memory data store which
helps in achieving high throughput and
low latency in memory data store so it's
not a full-blown database and it does
not come with
any amazon provisioned automation in it
for automating any of the administration
tasks no it does not come up with
anything like that yeah we can resize
the capacity as and when needed but
automation
it's not there yet and moreover it's not
a database so that's out of the equation
vpc is
not a recessible one you know once we
have designed vpc it's fixed it can't be
resized so that's out of the equation
and
amazon glacier glacier is a storage but
not a database all right so that's again
of the equation so that tie is kind of
between amazon rational database service
and amazon elastic cache because they
both aid the database service but
elastic cache is not a full-blown
database it actually helps database but
it's not a full-blown database so it's
amazon relational database so that's the
one which is a platform as a service
it's the one which can be resized it's
the one which
can be used to automate the
time consuming administrative tasks all
right let's talk about this one which of
the following is a means for accessing
human researchers or consultants to help
solve a problem on a contractual or a
temporary basis all right let's read the
question again which of the following is
a means for accessing human researchers
or consultant to help solve problems on
a contractual or a temporary basis it's
like a signing task or hiring aws
experts for a temporary job so let's try
to find that kind of service in the four
services that are listed amazon elastic
mapreduce mapreduce is actually an
framework service that makes it easy and
cost effective to analyze large amount
of data but that has
nothing to do with accessing human
researchers all right let's talk about
mechanical term it's a web service that
provides
a human workforce that's the definition
for it for example automation is good
but not everything can be automated for
something to qualify for automation it
has to be an repetitive task one time
task can't be automated or the time and
money that you would be spending in
automation is not worth it instead you
could have done it manually so that does
not qualify for automation and anything
that requires intelligence right
anything that's a special case right
automation can do repetitive task
automation can do precise work but it
has to be a repetitive task the scenario
you know it should have been there
already only then that can be executed
but if it's a new scenario and it
requires uh appropriate addressing then
it requires human thought so we could
hire researchers and consultants who can
help solve a problem using amazon
mechanical turk the other two are
already out of the equation now dev pay
is actually a payment system through
amazon and multi-factor authentication
as it says it's an authentication system
so the right answer is amazon mechanical
turk all right this sounds interesting
let's look at this one this service is
used to
make it easy to deploy manage and scale
containerized applications using
kubernetes on aws which of the following
is this aws service so it's a service to
deploy manage and scale containerized
applications so it deals with containers
it also should have the ability to use
kubernetes which is an container
orchestration service all right the
first one amazon elastic container
service kind of looks like it's the one
the name itself has the word and the
relation we're looking for elastic
container service so this container
service is an highly scalable high
performance container orchestration
service let's look at the other one aws
batch it's a service that enables id
professionals to schedule and execute
batch processing i mean the name itself
says that that's meant for batch
processing elastic bean stock that's
another service that helps us to deploy
manage and scale
but it helps us with easy two instances
not with containerized uh instances so
that's again out of the equation would
light scale be a good time for elastic
container service what's light sale now
light scale is a service it's called as
a virtual private server without a vpc
it's called as a virtual private
server it comes with a predefined
compute storage networking capacity it's
actually a server not a container right
so at this point that also becomes out
of the equation so it's amazon elastic
container service that's the one that
helps us to easily deploy manage scale
container services and it helps us
orchestrate the containers using
kubernetes all right how about this one
all right this service lets us to run
code without provisioning or managing
servers no servers run code select the
correct service from the below option
all right so no servers but we should be
able to run code amazon easy to auto
scaling easy to auto scaling ec2 is
elastic compute cloud which is a server
and auto scaling is a service that helps
us to achieve scaling the server so
that's the definition for it could be
that's out of the equation aw is lambda
now lambda is a service it's actually an
event driven serverless computing
platform and lambda runs code in
response to the event that it receives
and it automatically manages the compute
resource that's required for that code
as long as we have uploaded a code
that's correct and set up events
correctly to map to that code it's going
to run seamlessly so that's about lambda
it kind of looks like it could be the
answer because lambda runs code we don't
have to manage servers it manages
servers by itself but we can't conclude
as of now we have other two servers to
talk about aws batch all right batches
service that
enables id professionals to run batch
job we know that and about inspector
amazon inspector it's actually a service
that helps us to increase and identify
any security issues and align our
application with compliance well that's
not the requirement of the question the
requirement in the question was run code
without provisioning your server and
without any more space for confusion aws
lambda is a service or is the service
that runs code without provisioning and
managing services right the right one
would be aws lambda the second part in
aws interview questions if you haven't
watched the first part yet please go
back and watch the first part we have a
lot of interesting questions there which
will better prepare you for the
interview all right let's get started so
in an environment where there's a lot of
automation infrastructure automation
you'll be posted with this question how
can you add an existing instance to a
new auto scaling group now this is when
you are taking an instance away from the
auto scaling group to
troubleshoot to fix a problem you know
to look at logs or if you have suspended
the auto scaling you know you might need
to re-add that instance to the auto
scaling group only then it's going to
take part in it right only then the auto
scaling is going to count it has part of
it it's not a straight uh procedure you
know when you remove them you know it
doesn't get automatically re-added i've
had worked with some clients so when
their developers were managing their own
environment they had problems adding the
instance back to the auto scaling group
you know irrespective of what they tried
the instance was not getting added to
the auto scaling group and whatever they
fixed that they were provided or
whatever fix that they have provided
were not you know getting encountered in
the auto scaling group so like i said
it's not a straight you know a click
button procedure there are ways we'll
have to do it so how can you add an
existing instance uh to the auto scaling
group there are a few steps that we need
to follow so the first one would be to
under the ec2 instance console right
under the uh instance under actions in
specific you know there's an option
called attach to auto scaling group
right if you have multiple auto scaling
groups in your account or in the region
that you're working in then you're going
to be posted with the different auto
scaling groups that you have in your
account let's say you have five auto
scaling groups for five different
application you know you're going to be
posted with five different auto scaling
groups and then you would select
the auto scaling the appropriate auto
scaling group and attach the instance to
that particular auto scaling group while
adding to the auto scaling group if you
want to change the instance type you and
that's possible as well sometimes when
you want to add the instance back to the
auto scaling group there would be
requirement that you change the instance
type to a better one to a better family
to the better instance type you could do
that at that time and after that you are
or you have completely added the
instance back to the auto scaling group
so it's actually an seven step up
process adding an instance back to the
auto scaling group in an environment
where they're dealing with migrating the
instance or migrating an application or
migrating an instance migrating and vm
into the cloud you know if the project
that you're going to work with deals
with a lot of migrations you could be
posted this question what are the
factors you will consider while
migrating to amazon web services the
first one is cost is it worth
moving the instance to the cloud given
the additional bills and results
features available in the cloud is this
application going to use all of them is
moving into the cloud beneficial to the
application in the first place you know
beneficial to the users who will be
using the application in the first place
so that's a factor to think of so this
actually includes
you know cost of the infrastructure and
the ability to match the demand and
supply transparency is this application
in high demand you know is it going to
be a big loss if the application becomes
unavailable for some time so there are
few things that needs to be considered
before we move the application to the
cloud and then if uh the application
does the application needs to be
provisioned immediately is that an urge
is there an urge to provision the
application immediately that's something
that needs to be considered if the
application requires to go online if the
application needs to hit the market
immediately then we would need to move
it to the cloud because in on-premises
procuring or buying an infrastructure
buying the bandwidth buying the
switchboard you know buying an instance
you know buying their softwares buying
the license related to it it's going to
take time at least like two weeks or so
before you can
bring up an server and launch an
application in it right so the
application cannot wait you know waiting
means uh you know workforce productivity
loss is it so we would want to
immediately launch instances and put
application on top of it in those case
if your application is of that type if
there is urge in making the application
go online as soon as possible then
that's a candidate for moving to the
cloud and if the application or if
the
the software or if the product that
you're launching it requires hardware it
requires an updated hardware all the
time that's not going to be possible in
on premises we try to deal with legacy
infrastructure all the time in on
premises but in the cloud they're
constantly upgrading their hardwares
only then they can keep themselves up
going in the market so they constantly
the cloud providers are constantly
updating their hardware and if you want
to be benefited of your application
wants to be benefited by the constant
upgrading of the hardwares making sure
the hardware is as latest as possible
the software version the licensing is as
latest as possible then that's a
candidate to be moved to the cloud and
if the application does not want to go
through any risk if the application is
very sensitive to failures if the
application is very much tagged to the
revenue of the company and you don't
want to take a chance in
you know seeing the application fail and
you know seeing the revenue drop then
that's a candidate for moving to the
cloud and business uh agility you know
moving to
the cloud at least half of the
responsibility is now taken care by the
provider in this case it's amazon at
least half of the responsibility is
taken care by them like if the hardware
fails amazon makes sure that they're
fixing the hardware immediately and
notifications you know if something
happens you know there are immediate
notifications available that we can set
it up and make ourselves aware that
something has broken and we can
immediately jump in and fix it so you
see there are the responsibility is now
being shared between amazon and us so if
you want to get that benefit for your
application for your organization for
the product that you're launching then
it needs to be moved to the cloud so you
can get that benefit from the cloud the
other question you could get asked is
what is rto and rpo in aws they are
essentially disaster recovery terms when
you're planning for disaster recovery
you cannot avoid planning disaster
recovery without talking about rto and
rpo now what's the rto what's the rpo in
your environment or how do you define
rto how do you define rpo or some
general questions that get asked rto is
recovery time objective rto stands for
the maximum time the company is willing
to wait for the recovery to happen or
for the recovery to finish
when and disaster strikes so rto is uh
in the future right how much time
is it going to take to fix and bring
everything to normal so that's rto on
the other hand rpo is recovery point
objective which is the maximum amount of
data laws your company is willing to
accept as measured in time rpo always
refers to the backups the number of
backups the the frequency of the backups
right because when an outage happens you
can always go back to the latest backup
right and if the latest backup was
before 12 hours you have lost the in
between 12 hours of
data data storage right so rpo is the
acceptable amount if the company wants
less rpo rpo is 1r then you should be
planning on taking backups every one
hour if rpo is 12 hours then you should
be planning on taking backups every 12
hours so that's how rpo and rto you know
helps disaster recovery the fourth
question you could get asked is if you'd
like to transfer huge amount of data
which is the best option among a
snowball snowball edge and snowmobile
again this is a question that gets asked
if the company is dealing with a lot of
data transfer into the cloud or if the
company is dealing with the migrating
data into the cloud i'm talking about a
huge amount of data data in petabytes
snowball and all of the snowball series
deals with the petabyte-sized data
migrations so there are three options
available as of now aws snowball is an
data transport solution for moving high
volume of data into and out of a
specified aws region on the other hand
aws snowball edge as additional
computing functions snowball is simple
storage and movement of data and
snowball edge has a compute function
attached to it snow mobile on the other
hand is an exabyte scale migration
service that allows us to transfer data
up to 100 petabytes that's like 100 000
terabytes so depending on the size of
data that we want to transfer from our
data center to the cloud we can hire we
can rent any of these three services
let's talk about some cloud formation
questions this is a classic question how
is aws cloud formation different from
aws elastic bean stock you know from the
surface they both look like the same you
know you don't go through the console
provisioning resources you don't you
know you don't go through cli and
provision resources both of them
provision resources through click button
right but underneath they are actually
different services they support they aid
different services so knowing that is
going to help you understand this
question a lot better let's talk about
the difference between them and this is
what you will be explaining to the
interviewer or the panelist so the cloud
formation the cloud formation service
helps you describe and provision all the
infrastructure resources in the cloud
environment on the other hand elastic
bean stock provides an simple
environment to which we can deploy and
run application cloud formation gives us
an infrastructure and elastic beanstalk
gives us an small contained environment
in which we can run our application and
the cloud formation supports the
infrastructure needs of many different
types of application like the
enterprise application the legacy
applications and any new modern
application that you want to have in the
cloud on the other hand the elastic bean
stock it's a combination of developer
tools they are tools that helps manage
the life cycle of a single application
so cloud formation in short is managing
the infrastructure as a whole and
elastic bean stock in short is managing
and running an application in the cloud
and if the company that you're getting
hired is using uh cloud formation to
manage their infrastructure using or if
they're using infrastructure or any of
the infrastructure as a code services
then you would definitely face this
question what are the elements of an aws
cloud formation template so it has uh
four or five basic uh elements right and
the template is in the form of json or
in yaml format all right so it has
parameters it has
outputs it has data it has resources and
then the
format or the format version or the file
format version for the cloud formation
template so parameter is nothing but
it actually lets you to specify the type
of ec2 instance that you want the type
of rds that you want all right so ec2 is
an umbrella rds is an umbrella and
parameters within that ec2 and
parameters within that rds are the
specific details of the ec2 or the
specific details of the rds service so
that's what parameters in a cloud
formation template and then the element
of the cloud formation template is
outputs for example if you want to
output the name of an s3 bucket that was
created if you want to output the name
of the ec2 instance if you want to
output the name of some resources that
have been created instead of looking
into the template instead of you know
navigating through in the console and
finding the name of the resource we can
actually have them outputted
in the result section so we can simply
go and look at all the resources created
through the template in the output
section and that's what output values or
output does in the cloud formation
template and then we have resources
resources are nothing but what defines
what are the cloud components or cloud
resources that will be created through
this cloud formation template now ec2 is
a resource rds is a resource and s3
bucket is a resource elastic load
balancer is a resource and not gateway
is a resource vpc is a reserve so you
see all these components are the
resources and the resource section in
the cloud formation defines what are the
aws cloud resources that will be created
through this cloud formation template
and then we have a version a version
actually identifies the capabilities of
the template you know we just need to
make sure that it is of the latest
version type and the latest version is
zero nine zero nine uh 2010 that's the
latest version number you'll be able to
find that on the top of the cloud
formation template and that version
number defines the capabilities of the
cloud formation template so just need to
make sure that it's the latest all the
time still talking about cloud formation
this is another classic question what
happens when one of the resource in a
stack cannot be created successfully
well if
the resource in a stack cannot be
created the cloud formation
automatically rolls back and terminates
all the resources that was created using
the cloud formation template so whatever
resources that were created through the
cloud formation template from the
beginning let's say we have created like
10 resources and the 11th resource is
now failing cloud formation will roll
back and delete all the 10 resources
that were created previously and this is
very useful uh when the cloud formation
cannot you know go forward cloud
formation cannot create additional
resources because we have reached the
elastic
ip limits elastic ip limit per region is
five right and if you have already used
five ips and a cloud formation is trying
to buy
three more ips you know we've hit the
soft limit till we fix that with amazon
cloudformation will not be able to you
know launch additional you know
resources and additional ips so it's
going to cancel and roll back everything
that's true with a missing ec2 ami as
well if an ami is included in the
template and but the ami is not actually
present then cloud formation is going to
search for the mi and because it's not
present it's going to roll back and
delete all the resources that it created
so that's what cloud formation does it
simply rolls back all the resources that
it created i mean if it sees a failure
it would simply roll back all the
resources that it created and this
feature actually simplifies the system
administration and layered solutions
built on top of aws cloud formation so
at any point we know that there are no
orphan resources in the in in our
environment you know because something
did not work or because there was an you
know cloud formation executed some there
are no orphan resources in our account
at any point we can be sure that if
cloud formation is launching a resource
and if it's going to fail and it's going
to come back and delete all the
resources it's created so there are no
orphan resources in our account now
let's talk about some questions in
elastic block store again if the
environment deals with a lot of
automation you could be thrown this
question how can you automate easy to
backup using ebs it's actually a six
step process to automate the ec2 backups
we'll need to write a script to automate
the below steps using aws api and these
are the steps that should be found in
the scripts first to get the list of
instances and then and then the script
that we are writing should be able to
connect to aws using the api and list
the amazon abs volumes that are attached
locally to the instance and then it
needs to list the snapshots of each
volume make sure the snapshots are
present and it needs to assign a
retention period for the snapshot
because over time the snapshots are
going to be
invalid right once you have some 10
latest
snapshots any snapshot that you have
taken before that 10 becomes invalid
because you have captured the latest and
10 snapshot coverage is enough for you
and then the fifth point is to create a
snapshot of each volume create a new
snapshot of each volume and then delete
the old snapshot anytime a new snapshot
gets created the oldest snapshot of the
list needs to go away so we need to
include options we need to include
scripts in our script lines in our
script that make sure that it's deleting
the older snapshots which are older than
the retention period that we are
mentioning another question that you
could see in the interview be it written
interview beat online interview or beat
and telephonic or face-to-face interview
is what's the difference between ebs and
instant store let's talk about ebs first
ebs is kind of permanent storage the
data in it can be restored at a later
point when we save data in ebs the data
lives even after the lifetime of the ec2
instance for example we can stop the
instance and the data is still going to
be present in ebs we can move the ebs
from one instance to another instance
and the data is simply going to be
present there so abs is kind of
permanent storage when compared to
instance on the other hand instance
store is a temporary storage and that
storage is actually physically attached
to the host of the machine ebs is an
external storage an instant store is
locally attached to the instance or
locally attached to the host of the
machine we cannot detach an instant
store from one instance and attach it to
another but we can do that with eba so
that's a big difference one is permanent
data and another one is ebs is permanent
instant store is a volatile data and
instant store with instant store we
won't be able to detach the storage and
attach it to another instance and
another feature of instant store is data
in an instant store is lost if the disk
fails or the instance is stopped or
terminated so instant store is only good
for storing cache data if you want to
store permanent data then we should
think of using ebs and not instant store
while talking about storage on the same
lines this is another classic question
how can you take backups of efs like ebs
and if you can take backup how do you
take that backup the answer is yes we
can take efs to efs backup solution efs
does not support snapshot like ebs efs
does not support snapshot snapshot is
not an option for efs elastic file
system right we can only take backup
from one efs to another efs and this
backup solution is to recover from
unintended changes or deletions of the
efs and this can be automated but any
data that we store in efs can be
automatically replicated to another efs
and once this efs goes down or gets
deleted or data gets deleted or you know
the whole ef is is for some reason
interrupted or deleted we can recover
the data from we can use the other efs
and bring the application to consistency
and to achieve this it's not an
one-step configuration it's a cycle
there are series of steps that's
involved before we can achieve efs to
efs
backup the first thing is to sign in to
the aws management console and under efs
or click on efs to efs restore button
from the services list and from there we
can use the region selector in the
console navigation bar to select the
actual region in which we want to work
on and from there i'll ensure that we
have selected the right template you
know some of the templates would be you
know efs to efs backup granular backups
incremental backups right so there are
some templates the kind of backups that
you want to take do you want to take
grant alert do you want to take
increment backups stuff like that and
then create a name to that solution the
kind of backup that we have created and
finally review all the configurations
that you have done and click on save and
from that point onwards the data is
going to be copied and from that point
onwards any additional data that you put
is going to copy it and replicate it now
you have an efs to efs backup this is
another classic question in companies
which deals with
a data management there are easy options
to create snapshots but deleting
snapshots is
not always an you know click button or
an single step configuration so you
might be facing a question like how do
you auto delete old snapshots and the
procedure is like this now as best
practice we will take snapshots of ebs
volume to s3 all snapshots get stored in
s3 we know that now and we can use aws
ops automator to automatically handle
all snapshots the ops automator service
it allows us to create copy delete ebs
snapshots so there are cloud formation
templates available for aws ops
automator and this automator template
will scan the environment and it would
take snapshots it would you know copy
the snapshot from one region to another
region if you want i know if you're
setting up a dr environment and not only
that based on the retention period that
we
create it's going to delete the
snapshots which are older than the
retention period so life or managing
snapshot is made a lot easier because of
this ops automator cloudformation
template moving into questions and
elastic load balancer this again could
be an uh question in the interview what
are the different types of load
balancers in aws and what's their use
case what's the difference between them
and as of now as we speak there are
three types of load balancers which are
available in aws the first one being
application load balancer just like the
name says the application load balancer
works on the application layer and deals
with the http and https request and it
it also supports part based routing for
example simplylearn.com slash some
webpage simplylearn.com
another website so it's going to direct
the path based on the slash value that
you give in the urls that's path based
routing so it supports that and not only
that it can support a port based colon
8080 colon 8081 or colon 8090 you know
based on that port also it can take a
routing decision and that's what
application load balancer does on the
other hand we have network load balancer
and the network load balancer makes
routing decisions at the transport level
it's faster because it has very less
thing to work on it works on lower osi
layer it works on a lower layer so it
has very less information to work with
than compared with application layer so
comparatively it's a lot faster and it
handles millions of requests per second
and after the load balancer receives the
connection it selects a target group for
the default rule using the flow hash
routing algorithm it does simple routing
right it does not do path-based or
port-based routing it does simple
routing and because of it it's faster
and then we have classic load balancer
which is kind of expiring as we speak
amazon is discouraging people using
classic load balancer but there are
companies which are still using classic
load balancer they are the ones who are
the first one to step in to amazon when
classic load balancer was the first load
balancer or the only load balancer
available at that point so it supports
http https tcp ssl protocol and it has a
fixed relationship between a load
balance report and the container port so
initially we only have classic load
balancer and then um at after some point
amazon said instead of having one load
balancer address all type of traffic
we're going to have two load balances
called as the child from the classic two
load balancer and one is going to
specifically address the application
requirement and one is going to
specifically address the network
requirement and let's call it as
application load balancer and network
load balancer so that's how now we have
two different load balancers talking
about load balancer another classic
question could be what are the different
uses of the various load balancer in aws
elastic load balancing there are three
types of load balancer we just spoke
about it application load balancer is
used if we need a flexible application
management and tls termination and
network load balancer if we require
extreme performance and the load
balancing should happen on based on
static ips for the application and
classic load balancer is an old load
balancer which is for people who are
still running their environment from ec2
classic network now this is an older
version of vpc or this is what was
present before vpc was created easy to
classic network is what was present
before ec2 was created so they are the
three types and they are the use cases
of it let's talk about some of the
security related questions you would
face in the interview when talking about
security and firewall in aws we cannot
avoid discussion talking about waff web
application firewall and you would
definitely see yourself in this
situation where you've been asked how
can you use aws vaf in monitoring your
aws applications waff or web application
firewall protects our web application
from common web exploits and vaf helps
us control which traffic source your
application should be allowed or a block
which traffic from a certain source and
which source or which traffic from a
certain source should be allowed or
blocked your application with waff we
can also create custom rules that blocks
common attack patterns you know if it is
a banking application it has a certain
type of attacks and if it is simple data
management data storage application it
has
i mean content management application it
has a separate type of attack so based
on the application type we can identify
a pattern and create rules that would
actually block that attack based on the
rule that we create and waff can be used
for three cases you know the first one
is allow all requests and then a block
all request and count all requests for a
new policy so it's also an monitoring
and management service which actually
counts all the policies or counts all
the requests that matches a particular
policy that we create and some of the
characteristics we can mention in awsof
are the origin ips and the strings that
appear in the request we can allow block
based on origin ip allow block based on
strings that appear in the request we
can allow block or count based on the
origin country length of the request
yeah we can block and count the presence
of malicious scripts in an connection
now we can count the request headers or
we can allow block a certain request
header and we can count the presence of
a malicious sql code in a connection
that we get and that want to reach our
application still talking about security
what are the different aws im categories
we can control using aws iam we can do
the following one is create and manage
im users and once the user database gets
bigger and bigger we can create and
manage them in groups and in im we can
use it
to manage the security credentials kind
of setting the complexity of the
password you know setting additional
authentications you know like mfa and uh
you know rotating the passwords you know
resetting the password there are a few
things we could do with iam and finally
we can create policies that actually
grants access to aws services and
resources another question you will see
is what are the policies that you can
set for your users password so some of
the policies that we can set for the
user password is at the minimum length
or you know the complexity of the
password by at least having one number
or one special characters in the
password so that's one and then the
requirement of a specific character
types including you know uppercase
lowercase number and non-alphabetic
characters so it becomes very hard for
somebody else to guess what the password
would be and and try to hack them so we
can set
the length of the password we can set
the complexity in the password and then
we can set an automatic expiration of
the password so after a certain time the
user is forced to create a new password
so the password is not still old and
easy to guess in the environment and we
can also set settings like the user
should contact the admin i mean when the
password is about to expire so you know
you can get a hold of how the user is
setting their password is it
having good complexity in it is it
meeting company standards or there are
few things that we can control and set
for the users when the users are setting
or recreating the password another
question that could be posted in an
interview so to understand your
understanding of iem is what's the
difference between an iem role and an im
user let's talk about iem user let's
start small and then go big or let's
start simple and then talk about the
complex one the im user has a permanent
long term credential and it's used to
interact directly with aws services and
on the other hand iem role is an iem
entity that defines a set of permissions
for making aws service request so im
user is an permanent credential and role
are temporary credentials and iem user
has full access to all aws iem
functionalities and with role trusted
entities such as iem users application
or aws services
assume the role so when an im user is
given an
permission you know it sticks within the
iem user but with roles we can give
permissions to applications we can give
permissions to users in the same account
in a different account corporate id we
can give permissions to ec2 s3 rds vpc
and lot more role is wide and im user is
is not so wide you know it's very
constrained only for that i am user
let's talk about managed policies in aws
managed policies there are two types you
know customer managed and amazon managed
so manage policies are i am resources
that express permissions using the iam
policy language and we can create
policies edit them manage them manage
them separately from the im user group
and roles which they are attached to so
they are something that we can do to
managed policies if it is customer
managed and we can now update policy in
one place and the permissions
automatically extend to all the attached
entries so i can have like three
services four services point to a
particular policy and if i edit that
particular policy it's gonna reflect on
those three or four services so anything
that i allow is going to be allowed for
those four services anything that i
denied is going to be denied for uh the
four services imagine what would be
without the i am managed policy will
have to go and specifically allow deny
on those different instances four or
five times depending on the number of
instances that we have so like i said
there are two types of managed policies
one is managed by us which is customer
managed policies and then the other is
managed by aws which is aws managed
policy this question can you give an
example of an iem policy and a policy
summary this is actually to test how
well-versed are you with the aws console
the answer to that question is look at
the following policy this policy is used
to grant access to add update and delete
objects from a specific folder now in
this case name of the folder is example
folder and it's present in a bucket
called example bucket so this is an iam
policy on the other hand the policy
summary is a list of access level
resource and conditions for each service
defined in a policy so iam policy is all
about one particular resource and the
policy summary is all about multiple
resources with iem policy it was only
talking about s3 bucket and one
particular s3 bucket here it talks about
cloud formation template cloud watch
logs ec2 elastic bean stock services
summary summary of resources and the
permissions and policies attached to
them that's what policy summary is all
about another question could be like
this what's the use case of iam and how
does im help your business two important
or primary work of iam is to help us
manage iam users and their access it
provides a secure access to multiple
users to their appropriate aws resources
so that's one it does and the second
thing it does is manage access for
federated users federated users or
non-iam users and through iam we can
actually allow and provide secured
access to resources in our aws account
to our employees without the im user no
they could be authenticated using the
active directory they could be
authenticated using the facebook
credential google credential amazon
credential and a couple of other
credentials third party
identity management right so we could
actually trust them and we could give
them access to our account based on the
trust relationship that we have built
with the other identity of systems right
so two things one is manage users and
their access for manage iam user and
their access in our aws environment and
second is manage access for federated
users who are non-iam users and more
importantly im is a free service and
with that
will only be charged for the use of the
resources not for the im username and
password that we create all right let's
now talk about some of the questions in
route 53.
one classic question that could be asked
in an interview is what is the
difference between latency based routing
and
geodns or jio based dns routing now the
jio based dns routing takes routing
decisions on the basis of the geographic
location of the request and on the other
hand the latency based routing utilizes
latency measurements between networks
and
data centers now latency based routing
is used where you want to give your
customers the lowest latency as possible
so that's when we would use latency
based routing and on the other hand the
geo based routing is when we want to
direct customers to different websites
based on the country they are browsing
from you know you could have you know
two different or three different
websites for the same url you know take
amazon the shopping website for example
when we go to
amazon.com from in the us it directs us
to the us web page where the products
are different the currency is different
right and the flag and and a couple of
other advertisements that shows up are
different and when we go to amazon.com
from india it gets directed to the
amazon.com indian site where again the
currency the product and the
advertisements they're all different
right so depending on the
country they're trying to browse if you
want to direct customers to two or three
different websites we would use a
geo-based routing another use case of
geo based routing is if you have a
compliance that you should handle all
the dns requires sorry if you should
handle all the requests you know from a
country within the country then you
would do geo-based routing now you
wouldn't direct the customer to a server
which is in another country all right
you would direct the customer to a
server which is very local to them
that's another use case of jio based
routing and like i said for latency
based routing the whole goal or aim is
to achieve minimum end user latency if
you are hired for the architect role and
if that requires working lot on the dns
then you could be posted with this
question what is the difference between
domain and a hosted zone a domain is
actually a collection of
data describing a self-contained
administrative and technical unit on the
internet right so for example you know
simplylearn.com is actually a domain on
the other hand hosted zone is actually
an container that holds information
about how you want to route traffic on
the internet to a specific domain for
example
lms.simplylearn. is an hosted zone
whereas simplylearn.com is a domain so
in other words in hosted zone you would
see the domain name plus and a prefix to
it lms is a prefix here ftp is a prefix
mail.simplylearn.com is a prefix so
that's how you would see a prefix in
hosted zones another question
from another classic question from route
53 would be how does amazon drop 53
provide high availability and low
latency the way amazon rav53 provides
high availability and low latency is by
globally distributed dns servers amazon
is a global service and they have dna
services globally any customer doing a
query from different parts of the world
they get to reach an dns server which is
very local to them and that's how it
provides low latency now this is not
true with all the dns providers there
are dns providers who are very local to
a country who are very local to a
continent so they don't they generally
don't provide low latency service right
it's always high latency it's low
latency for local users but anybody
browsing from a different country or a
different continent it's going to be
high latency for them but that's not
again true with amazon amazon is a
globally distributed dns provider it has
dns servers global wide and like i said
it has optimal locations it has got
global servers or in other words it has
got servers around the globe different
parts in the globe and that's how they
are able to provide high availability
and because it's not running on just one
server but on many servers they provide
high availability and low latency if the
environment that you're going to work on
is going to take a lot of configuration
backups environmental backups then you
can expect questions in aws config a
classic question would be how does aws
config work along with aws cloudtrail
aws cloudtrail actually records user api
activity on the account and you know any
http https access or any any sort of
access you know that's made to the cloud
environment that's recorded in the cloud
trail in other words any api calls the
time is recorded the type of call is
recorded and what was the response given
was it a failure was it successful they
also get recorded in cloudtrail it's
actually a log it actually records
the activity in your cloud environment
on the other hand config is an a point
in time configuration details of your
resources for example at a given point
what are all the resources that were
present in my environment what are all
the resources or what are the
configuration in those resources at a
given point they get captured in aws
conflict right so with that information
you can always answer the question what
did my aws resource look like at a given
point in time that question gets
answered when we use aws config on the
other hand with cloudtrail you can
answer the question i mean by looking at
the cloud trail or with the help of
cloudtrail you can easily answer the
question who made an apa call to modify
this resource that's answered by
cloudtrail and with the cloud trail we
can detect if a security group was
incorrectly configured and who did that
configuration let's say there happened
to be a downtime and you want to
identify let's say there happened to be
a downtime and you want to identify who
made that uh change in the environment
you can simply look at cloudtrail and
find out who made the change and if you
want to look at how the environment
looks like before the change you can
always look at aws config can aws
configure or aws config aggregate data
across different aws accounts yes it can
now this question is actually to test
whether you have used aws config or not
i know some of the services are very
local is it some of these services are
availability zone specific some of them
are regional specific and some of them
are
global
services in amazon and though some of
the services are region services you
still can do some changes you know add
some configuration to it and collect
regional data in it for example s3 is a
regional service but still you can
collect logs from all other regions into
an s3 bucket in one particular region
that's possible and cloud trail is and
cloud watch is an regional service but
still you can with some changes to it
with some adding permissions to it you
can always monitor the cloud watch that
belongs to cloudwatch logs that belongs
to other regions you know they're not
global by default but you can do some
changes and make it global similarly aws
config is a service that's a region
based service but still you can make it
act globally you can aggregate
data across a different region and
different accounts in an aws config and
deliver
the updates
from different accounts to one s3 bucket
and can access it from there aws config
also works or integrates seamlessly with
sns topic so you know anytime there is a
change anytime a new data gets collected
you can always notify yourself or notify
a group of people about the new log or
the new config or new edit that happened
in the environment let's look at some of
the database questions you know database
should be running on reserved instances
so whether you know that fact or not the
interviewer wants to understand how well
you know that fact by asking this
question how are reserved instances
different from on-demand db instances
reserved instances and on-demand
instances are exactly the same when it
comes to their function but they only
differ based on how they are
built reserved instances are purchased
for one year or three year reservation
and in return we get a very low
per hour pricing because we're paying
upfront it's generally said that
reserved instance is 75 percentage
cheaper than on-demand instance and
amazon gives you that benefit because
you know you're committing for one year
and sometimes you're paying in advance
for the whole year on the other hand
on-demand instances are built on an
oddly early price talking about auto
scaling how will you understand the
different types of auto scaling the
interviewer might ask this question
which type of scaling would you
recommend for rds and y the two types of
scaling as you would know now
vertical and horizontal and in vertical
scaling we can vertically scale up the
master database with a couple of clicks
all right so that's vertical scaling
vertical scaling is keeping the same
node and making it bigger and bigger if
previously it was running on t2 micro
now we would like to run it on m3 two
times large instance previously it had
one virtual cpu one gigabit now it's
going to have eight virtual cpu and 30
gigabit of ram so that's vertical
scaling on the other hand horizontal
scaling is adding more nodes to it
previously it was running on one vm now
it's going to run on 2 3 10 vms all
right that's horizontal scaling so
database can only be scaled vertically
and there are 18 different types of
instances we can resize our rds to all
right so this is true for ids mysql
postgres sql mariadb oracle microsoft
sql servers there are 18 type of
instances we can vertically scale up to
on the other hand horizontal scaling are
good for replicas so they are read-only
replicas we're not going to touch the
master
database we're not going to touch the
primary database but i can do horizontal
scaling only with amazon aurora and i
can add additional read replicas i can
add up to 15 read replicas for amazon
aurora and up to five read replicas for
rds mysql postgres sql and marie db rds
instances and when we add replica we are
horizontally scaling adding more nodes
right a read-only nodes so that's
horizontal scaling so how do you really
decide between vertical and horizontal
scaling if you're looking in to increase
the storage and the processing capacity
we'll have to do a vertical scaling if
you're looking at increasing the
performance or of the read heavy
database we need to be
looking for horizontal scaling or we
need to be implementing horizontal
scaling in our environment still talking
about database this is another good
question you can expect in the interview
what is the maintenance window in amazon
rds will your db instance be available
during the maintenance event all right
so this is really to test how well you
have understood the sla how well you
have understood the amazon rdas uh the
failover mechanism of amazon rdas stuff
like that so audio's maintenance window
it lets you decide
when a db instance modification a
database engine upgrades or software
patching has to occur and you you
actually get to decide should it happen
at 12 in the night or should it happen
at afternoon should it happen early in
the morning should it happen in the
evening you actually get to decide an
automatic scheduling by amazon is done
only for patches that are security and
durability related sometimes amazon
takes down and does automatic scheduling
uh if you know if there is a need for a
patch update that deals with security
and durability and by default the
maintenance window is is for 30 minutes
and the important point is the db
instance will be available during that
event because you're going to have
primary and secondary right so when that
upgrade happens amazon would shift the
connection to the secondary do the
upgrade and then switch back to the
primary another classic question would
be what are the consistency models in
dynamodb in dynamodb there is eventual
consistency read this eventual
consistency model it actually maximizes
your read throughput and the best part
with eventual consistency is all copies
of data reach
consistency within a second and
sometimes when you write and when you're
you know trying to read immediately
chances that you you would still be
reading the old data that's eventual
consistency on the other hand there is
another consistency model called the
strong consistency or strongly
consistent read where there is going to
be a delay in writing the data you know
making sure the data is written in all
places but it guarantees one thing that
is once you have done a write and then
you're trying to do a read it's going to
make sure that it's going to show you
the updated data not the old data and
you can be guaranteed of it that it is
going to show the updated data and not
the old data that's strongly consistent
still talking about uh database talking
about nosql dynamodb or nosql database
which is
dynamodb and amazon you could be asked
this question what kind of query
functionality does
dynamodb support dynamodb supports get
and put operation dynamodb supports or
dynamodb provides flexible querying by
letting you query on non-primary key
attributes using global secondary index
and local secondary indexes a primary
key can be either a single attribute
partition key or a composite
partition sort key in other words a
dynamodb indexes a composite partition
sort key as a partition key element and
the sort key element and by holding the
partition key you know when doing a
search or when doing a query by holding
the partition key element constant we
can search across the sort key element
to retrieve the other items in that
table and the composite partition sort
key should be a combination of user id
partition and a timestamp so that's what
the composite partition sort key is made
of let's look at some of the multiple
choice questions you know sometimes some
companies would have an a written test
or an mcq type online test before they
call you for at the first level or
before they call you for the second
level so these are some classical
questions that companies asked or
companies ask in their multiple choice
online questions let's look at this
question as a developer using this
pay-per-use service you can send store
and receive messages between software
components which of the following is
being referred here let's look at it
right we have aws step functions amazon
mq amazon simple queue service amazon
simple notification service let's read
the question again as a developer using
this pay-per-use service so the service
that we are looking for is a
pay-per-view service you can send store
and retrieve messages between two
software components kind of like a queue
there so what would be the right answer
it would be amazon simple queue service
now amazon simply queue service is the
one that's used to decouple at the
environment it breaks the tight coupling
and then it introduces decoupling in
that environment by providing a queue or
by inserting a queue between two
software components let's look at this
other question if you would like to host
a real-time audio and video conferencing
application on aws it's an audio and
video conferencing application on aws
this service provides you with a secure
and easy to use application what is this
service let's look at the options they
are amazon chime amazon workspace amazon
mq amazon app stream well you might tend
to look at
amazon app stream because it's real time
and a video conference but it's actually
for a different purpose is actually
amazon chime that lets you create chat
and create a chat board and then
collaborate with the security of the aws
services so it lets you do the audio it
lets you do the video conference all
supported by aws security features it's
actually amazon china let's look at this
question as your company's aw solution
architect you are in charge of designing
thousands of individual jobs which are
similar which of the following service
best serves your requirement aws ec2
auto scaling aws snowball aws fargate
aws batch let's read the question again
as your company's aws solution architect
you are in charge of designing thousands
of individual jobs which are similar it
looks like
it's batch service let's look at the
other options as well aw snowball is
actually an storage uh transport service
ec2 auto scaling is you know in
introducing scalability and elasticity
in the environment and aws far gate is
container services aws batch is the one
is being referred here that actually
runs thousands of individual jobs which
are similar aws batch it's the right
answer but let's look at the other one
you are a machine learning engineer and
you're looking for a service that helps
you build and train machine learning
models in aws which among the following
are we referring to so we have amazon
sage maker and aws deep lens amazon
comprehend aws device farm let's read
the question again you are a machine
learning engineer and you're looking for
a service that helps you build and train
machine learning models in aws which
among the following are referred here
the answer is sage maker it provides
every developer and data scientist with
the ability to build train and deploy
mission learning models quickly that's
what sagemaker does now for you to be
familiar with you know the the products
i would recommend you to you know simply
go through the
product description you know there's one
page available on amazon that explains
all the products a quick neat and simple
now that really helps you to be very
familiar with you know what the product
is all about and what it is capable of
you know is it a db service is it a
machine learning service or is it a
monitoring service is it a developer
service stuff like that so get that
information get that details before you
attend an interview and that should
really help to answer or face such
questions with a great confidence so the
answer is amazon sagemaker because
that's the one that provides developers
and a data scientist the ability to
build a train and deploy machine
learning models quickly as possible all
right let's look at this one let's say
that you are working for your company's
id team and you are designated to adjust
the capacity of the aws resource based
on the incoming application and network
traffic how do you do it so what's the
service that's actually helps us to
adjust the capacity of the aws resource
based on the incoming application let's
look at it amazon vpc amazon iam amazon
inspector amazon elastic load balancing
amazon vpc is a networking service
amazon iam is an username password
authentication amazon inspector is a
service that actually does security
audit in our environment and amazon
elastic load balancer is a service that
helps in scalability that's in one way
you know indirectly that helps in
increasing the availability of the
application right and monitoring it
monitoring you know how much requests
are coming in through the elastic load
balancer we can actually adjust the
environment that's running behind it so
the answer is going to be amazon elastic
load balancer all right let's look at
this question this cross platform video
game development engine that supports pc
xbox playstation ios and android
platforms allows developers to build and
host their games on amazon's servers so
we have amazon game lift amazon green
grass amazon lumber yard amazon sumerian
let's read the question again this
cross-platform video game development
engine that supports pc xbox playstation
ios and android platforms allows
developers to build and host their games
on amazon servers the answer is amazon
lumberyard this lumberyard is an free
aaa gaming engine deeply integrated with
aws and twitch with full source this
lumbar yard provides a growing set of
tools that helps you create and highest
game quality applications and they
connect to a lot of games and vast
compute and storage in the cloud so it's
that service they are referring to let's
look at this question you are the
project manager of your company's cloud
architect team you are required to
visualize understand and manage your aws
cost and usage over time which of the
following service will be the best fit
for this we have aws budgets we have aws
cost explorer we have amazon work mail
we have amazon connect and the answer is
going to be cost explorer now cost
explorer is an option in the amazon
console that
helps you to visualize and understand
and even manage the aws cost over time
who's spending more who's spending less
and what is the trend what is the
projected cost for the coming month all
these can be visualized in aws cost
explorer let's look at this question you
are a chief cloud architect at your
company and how can you automatically
monitor and adjust computer resources to
ensure maximum performance and
efficiency of all scalable resources so
we have a cloud formation as a service
we have aws aurora as a solution we have
aws auto scaling and amazon api gateway
let's read the question again you're the
chief cloud architect at your company
how can you automatically monitor and
adjust computer resources how can you
automatically monitor and adjust
computer resources to ensure maximum
performance and efficiency of all
scalable resources this is an easy
question to answer the answer is auto
scaling right that's a basic service and
solution architect
course is it auto scaling is the service
that helps us to easily adjust monitor
and ensure the maximum performance and
efficiency of all scalable resources it
does that by automatically scaling the
environment to handle the inputs let's
look at this question as a database
administrator you will use a service
that is used to set up and manage
databases such as mysql maya db and
postgres sql which service are we
referring to amazon aurora amazon
elastic cache aws rds aws database
migration service amazon arora is
amazon's flavor of
the rds service and elastic cache is is
the caching service provided by amazon
they are not full-fledged database and
database migration service just like the
name says it helps to migrate the
database from on-premises to the cloud
and from one database flavor to another
database flavor amazon rds is the
service is the console is the service is
the umbrella service that helps us to
set up manage databases like mysql money
db and postgres sql it's amazon rds
let's look at this last question a part
of your marketing work requires you to
push messages to onto google facebook
windows and apple through apis or aws
management console you will use the
following service so the options are aws
cloudtrail aws config amazon chime aws
simple notification service it says a
part of your marketing work requires you
to push messages it's dealing with
pushing messages to google facebook
windows and apple through apis or aws
management console you will use the
following service it's simple
notification service simple notification
service is an message pushing a service
and sqs is pulling similarly sns is
pushing right here it talks about a
pushing system that pushes messages to
google facebook windows and apple
through api and it's going to be a
simple notification system or a simple
notification service i would like to
welcome you to this azure interview
preparation session
knowing azure is one thing having worked
on azure is another thing and being able
to answer interview questions in azure
is a totally different thing although
one helps the other it's still different
skills and our aim through this video is
to prepare you with common product and
scenario based interview questions
so why wait let's get started a common
cloud interview question is what's the
difference between sas pass and is we
all know that a software as a service is
thin client model of software
provisioning where client in this case
usually is simply a web browser
providing the point of access to
software's running on the servers now
sas is the most familiar form of cloud
service for customers sas moves the task
of managing software and its deployment
to third-party services meaning the
vendor actually gets to manage all that
so
sas is software as a service involving
applications being consumed and used by
organization so it's generally using an
application and usually organizations
pay for their use of this particular
application now some examples of sas
would include office 365. salesforce is
another very good example of sas and a
lot of google apps and storage solutions
like box and dropbox are a very good
example of software as a service talking
about platform as a service or pass it
actually functions at the lower level
than sas now typically it provides a
platform on which software can be
developed and deployed now here we
develop the software we deploy the
software now pass actually provides an
abstract of much of the work dealing
with servers and giving client an
environment in which the operating
system and the server software and the
hardwares and the network are managed
and taken care in other words with a
platform as a service all the things
that i've mentioned like the servers the
server software the hardware everything
is managed by the provider and we can
focus on business side of the
scalability and we can focus on
application development of our product
or the service so in short platform as a
service is a service that enables
developers to build and work with
applications without even having to
worry about the infrastructure or
management of the underlying hosting
environments and some examples of uh
pass in azure is
sql and azure storage talking about
infrastructure as a service i as now
this is moving down the stack even
further now we get to the fundamental
building block of the cloud service
which is infrastructure as a service is
now is is fully of highly automated
scalable computer resources is is full
of storage is full of the network
capability that's what is is now is
clients have direct access to the
servers and storage just as they would
to do traditional servers but in this
case it's going to be in the cloud in
this case it's going to be more scalable
so is is very similar to what you would
do in your on-premises physical data
center but when we talk about is we get
to do everything but it's stored in the
cloud so if we need to build a
definition around is is or
infrastructure as a service provides
users with components it provides
components it does not give us a built
environment it simply provides a
component such as operating system
networking capabilities and a lot more
now this is a paid for based on the
usage and can be used to host
applications in other words this is pay
as you go type the more you use the more
you pay the less you use the less you
pay and some of the examples of is in
azure is a virtual machine that's a
great example for is and v-nets for
networking that's another good example
for is in azure another common question
in azure interview is what are the
instant types offered by azure the main
intention of this question is how well
have you understood the different
offerings in azure and how well are you
trained to pick the right offering for
the right service now one size does not
fit all and thereof there are a lot of
services in azure that under the carpet
it does the same thing but depending on
how different your requirement is we'll
have to pick the appropriate server so
this actually this question what are the
different instant types offered by azure
it's to test how well have you used the
product and services available in azure
and how well have you applied them for
the given requirement you should be
provisioning more you should be
provisioning less at the same time so
it's kind of matching the right service
to the right requirement so what are the
instant types offered by azure as you
see in the list we have general purpose
compute optimized memory optimized
storage optimized gpu virtual machines
and high performance compute virtual
machines now answering just the names
won't be enough in an interview you'll
have to go further and explain why and
in what scenario you would use general
purpose and what are the use cases what
type of servers is a good fit for a
general purpose and what type is a good
fit for compute optimized so on and so
forth and that's exactly what we're
going to do now so the general purpose
vms you know they provide a balanced cpu
to memory ratio and it's very good for
testing very good for a development
environment very good for small and
medium databases and also for low to
medium traffic web servers and some of
the use cases are like we said test
servers low traffic web servers
small to medium databases some
enterprise great applications it's also
good for relational database it's also
good for servers used for in-memory
caching it's also good for some small
analytic database very good for micro
services and if you're trying to build a
proof of concept for an idea that you
just have or just parked this is another
good server for doing proof of concepts
because you're not going to send actual
traffic to it i just want to show that
you know your idea works so general
purpose server is a very good use case
for those scenarios and the largest
instance size we can get in general
purpose is standard d64 v3 which comes
with 256 gigabit of memory and 1600
gigabit of ssd temporary storage on the
other hand compute optimized vms have an
a high cpu to memory ratio and are very
good for medium traffic web servers very
good for batch processing servers very
good for application servers now because
it's computer optimized and compute
means a cpu it's an excellent choice for
workloads that demand faster cpu but
does not need as much memory or
temporary storage virtual cpu some of
the workloads that run very well on
computer optimized are analytic
workloads gaming servers require more
cpu they run really well batch
processing are some of the applications
that can be placed in computer optimized
and by doing that we get the actual
benefit of the compute optimized
instance and the largest instance size
or the largest instance size type is
standard f72s v2 and here we get
144 gigabit of memory and
576 gigabit of ssd temporary storage in
compute optimized vms in the same lines
memory optimized to vm they offer high
memory to cpu ratio and that are great
for databases databases require more
memory so it's a great fit for database
and it's a great fit for medium to
large scale caches applications that
require in-memory analytics so this
memory optimized memories more so it's
very good for in-memory analytics
applications and the largest instant
size we get here is standard
m128m and look at the
gigabit of memory it's 3892
gigabit of memory and
look at the temporary storage it's uh
336 a gigabit of temporary storage on
the same lines storage optimized now i
guess i don't have to explain to you
what storage optimized is used for you
might have easily guessed looking at the
flow yes storage optimized vm offer high
disk throughput and io and are very
ideal for big data
sql nosql databases data warehousing
servers large transactional databases
and lot more and some of the examples of
the applications that can be launched on
storage optimized are cassandra mongodb
cloudera redis these are some familiar
applications that can get benefited when
we run them on storage optimized and one
difference between storage optimized and
the other servers are they are generally
optimized to use the local disk on the
node attached directly to the vm rather
than using an durable disk which is
actually in a remote
disk space now what does this allow this
allows for greater input outputs per
second or throughput for the workload so
that's what we get a greater throughput
at greater input outputs per second is
what we get when we use storage
optimized and the largest instance size
available in storage optimized is
standard l32s and
the memory is 256 gigabit and look at
the temporary storage it's a
5630 gigabit of temporary storage
gpu type vms easy to guess gpu optimized
vms are specialized virtual machines
available with
multiple gpus attached to them now these
sizes are designed for or these vms are
designed for compute intensive graphic
intensive visualization workloads that
require a lot of
graphical processing unit attached to it
so in short these are virtual machines
that specialize in heavy graphic
rendering and video editing it also
helps with model training and
interferencing with the standard nd
nd24rs which has
448 gigabit of memory and 2948
gigabit of temporary storage and the
last but not the least but the best last
but the best is high performance compute
or azure h series virtual machines now
they are the latest in high performance
computing vms and are aimed to handle
workloads like batch processing analytic
molecular modeling and fluid dynamics a
lot of complicated applications in this
vm and this is the fastest and powerful
cpu virtual machine with the optional
high throughput interfaces and the
largest instance size that's available
is a standard l32s which comes with 224
gigabit of memory and 200 gigabit of ssd
temporary storage and a third common
question is what are the deployment
environments offered by azure there are
two main deployment environments one is
the staging environment and the other
one is the production environment now in
staging environment let's talk about
staging first so when you're deploying
your web app or web app on linux you can
deploy them to a separate slot instead
of the default production slot when
running them in standard premium or
isolated app service plan tiers now the
deployments slots are actually live app
with their own host name and at a later
point that the staging environment can
be swapped with the production
environment so why do we need and
staging environment what are the benefit
of it so the benefit of deploying our
application to a non-production or
staging environment it provides a
platform to validate changes to our
application before it can be made live
in the production environment and in the
staging environment the app can be
identified using the azure's global
unique identifier also called as the
guid url and it's very very similar to
the production url except that it has a
custom name in front of it that
identifies it as the staging environment
and for production environment this is
the live
production environment that's serving
customers request that serving the
customer content now it can be slightly
different from the staging environment
in a way that the url that's used to
identify the production environment
that's more often dns friendly name like
the name of the actual service dot cloud
app.net that way it differs in case of
staging environment you have an custom
name right before it so the custom name
and then the cloudapp.net but in this
case you get the
direct service name as the name of the
url so this is live production
environment which receives and handles
and serves customer traffic another
commonly asked question in azure is what
are the advantages of scaling in azure
the actual thought behind the question
is to see
how much have you understood scaling how
much have you seen and how much have you
applied the scaling effect in the
production environment and have received
benefits in return so let's talk about
it advantages of scaling in azure some
of the advantages are we get the maximum
application performance now auto scaling
is a built-in feature for the cloud
services be it
aws azure
google and couple of other cloud service
providers it's a built-in feature for a
cloud service a cloud service should be
auto scalable and that includes mobile
services virtual machines and
when we run our applications
on mobile services or virtual machines
the website actually gets the best
performance during
the change in the demand again a
different applications
might require different performance
needs for examples for some apps the
performance measured based on memory and
another a good example is the
fluctuating demand for example you could
have a web app that handles millions of
requests during the day and literally
nothing at the night and auto scaling
this environment auto scaling any of
these environment will automatically
scale or fatten your environment so to
receive the all the incoming traffic and
during lean period it actually gets
slimmer and slimmer so to help you with
the cost so it actually maximizes the
performance that's what auto scaling
does and like we said auto scaling
scales up and scales down based on
demand it not only scales up but also
scales down so to help you with the cost
and if you know the particular pattern
in which the application is going to
receive traffic then we can very well go
ahead and schedule scaling to our
application or schedule scaling that
infrastructure based on time if we
already know that monday to friday
that's the traffic that i would get and
it's a constant one it's not a public
facing but you know it's an internal
application so i know all the 500 users
or the thousand or the 5000 users who
will be using it so at any given point
it's just 5000 users it's not going to
go beyond that and during saturday and
sunday literally nobody's going to be in
office so no load at all so in that case
i pretty much know how the pattern is
going to be i can go for scheduled
scaling if i know at the pattern and
auto scaling like i said not only helps
with keeping the application highly
available it also helps with the cost
effectiveness of our infrastructure so
anytime there's a vm or a group of vms
running on less cpu auto scaling is
going to actually get the environment
slimmer and slimmer so we're not
unnecessarily running any resources and
paying for it if you're being
interviewed for the infrasight in azure
this is another common question that
gets asked how are windows active
directory and azure active directory
different let's talk about the windows
active directory first the non-cloud
windows active directory was the service
was released along with windows 2000
server edition and this active directory
is essentially a database that helps
organizations to organize the users
organize the computers and a lot more it
provides authentication and
authorization to the applications not
only to the applications but also to
file servers to printers and a lot of
other on-premises resources that's what
the basic non-cloud active directory
does on the other hand the azure active
directory is not designed to manage
web-based services the azure active
directory on the other hand was designed
to support web-based services that use
rest api interfaces for office
365 salesforce.com etc unlike the plain
active directory this uses a completely
different protocol so protocol wise it's
different and the services that it
support is quite different now besides
that it also has couple of other
differences as well and let's look at
them so the actual active directory or
the windows actual directory is a
directory service that facilitates
working with interconnected complex and
different network resources in a very
unified manner on the other hand azure
active directory is microsoft's
multi-tenant cloud-based directory and
identity management service and the
windows active directory has five layers
to store data to store user details and
to issue the management certifications
on the other hand azure active directory
integrates or compresses the five layers
into just two layers here windows active
directory works with on-premises servers
like applications file servers and
printers etc on the other hand azure
active directory it works on web-based
services that use restful interfaces if
you're being hired for the development
environment or for the cloud devops
support environment or even for the
production support environment you might
find yourself being asked this question
what are the types of queues offered by
azure now azure supports two types of
queue mechanisms the storage cube and
the service bus queue let's talk about
storage queue first now the storage
queue which are part of azure storage
infrastructure it provides a simple rest
based
interface simple rest based get put and
peak interface it provides reliable
persistent messaging within and between
other services it follows the pub sub
model or pub sub messaging
infrastructure and it's best suited for
users that need to store more than 80
gigabit of messages in the queue it can
provide a logs for all the transactions
executed against the user's queue so
that's what we get with storage queue
and on the other hand service bus queue
the service bus cues are built on top of
broader messaging infrastructure and
they are designed to integrate
applications and applications component
that can span multiple communication
protocols so that way it differs so this
is good for applications and components
that may span multiple communication
protocols and even different totally
different network environments so in
short these service buses or the service
bus queues in azure are part of azure's
messaging infrastructure and they
integrate applications or application
components that can actually span
multiple different protocols and
multiple different network environments
it also provides and first and first out
style for delivery and the user's queue
size has to remain under 80 gigabit
another familiar question is what are
the advantages of azure resource manager
now this resource manager helps us to
manage the usage of the application
resources this question is actually to
test how well have you tested how well
have you used resource manager and have
gotten the benefit of it this question
actually tests how easy it has become
after the introduction of resource
manager compared to
when doing deployments or when
provisioning resources without the
resource manager so let's get into the
answers for the question what are the
advantages of azure resource manager the
in chart resource manager is called arm
so the arm helps deploy manage and
monitor all the resources for an
application a solution or a group so all
the interconnected application all the
interconnected services can be monitored
as group using resource manager and
users can be granted to access to
resources that they require within a
resource manager so in an account i can
have like 10 different resources created
by resource manager or a resource group
created by resource managers and i can
allow deny connection to those services
or only to those services based on
whether the user should be accessing one
and not accessing the other so that way
it becomes easy to give access to a
group of application it helps in getting
billing details for the group of
resources now which group is using more
which group is using less and which
group has contributed more to this
month's bill stuff like that so those
details can be obtained using azure zos
manager and provisioning resources is
made much easier with the help of this
resource manager another question is how
has integrating hybrid cloud been useful
for azure well with the use of hybrid
cloud we get the best of both the worlds
so what's hybrid cloud it's nothing but
a combining the public cloud and the
private cloud and allowing data and
applications to be shared between them
so whenever the compute or the
processing demand fluctuates hybrid
cloud computing gives businesses the
ability to seamlessly scale their
on-premises infrastructure in the public
cloud and handle any kind of uh
overflow in the requirement or overflow
in handling the application so it really
helps it helps it boost the productivity
of our on-premises application so with
the hybrid cloud we get a greater
efficiency with combination of azure
services devops processes and tools for
the application running in on-premises
and by having an hybrid cloud
environment users can take advantage of
a constantly updated azure service and
other aws marketplace
applications for their on-premises
environment and the other benefit is
with hybrid cloud environment we can
simply deploy applications regardless of
its locations in case of on-premises
we'll have to worry about the location
but when we expand our on-premises
environment in the cloud and they can or
we can pick any of the locations and
simply deploy it in them and this
enables the applications to be created
at a greater speed what's federating in
azure sql now this question is very
specific about sql how can we scale the
sql database now this is a very good
question or a valid question or an
important question in the interview
because
many customers or companies have
not been able to meet the user demand
because they could not scale out the
databases the theory of scaling out or
adding servers to accommodate the
increased workloads and traffic
is not hard to understand but the
implications can be very complicated the
implications can be very expensive we're
well aware of scaling the web servers
that's very common but how do we scale
the database so microsoft provides the
tools and technologies so we can scale
out the database in the cloud and that's
what is called sql or
federation in azure sql so the way we
scale out the sql database is by sharing
sharding the database so sharing
actually enables users to take
advantages of the resources in the cloud
not only that it allows users to have
their own database or a shared database
amongst each other because we're
creating a highly available database
because we're having shards in a
database it actually reduces the
possibility of a single point of failure
for our database and
more importantly because we're sharing
because we're using federation and azure
sql it provides and cost effective
scaling of our databases by using cloud
resources or by using billing only for
the cloud resources that we have used so
no pre-provisioning no over provisioning
it provisions the right amount and we
pay the right amount let's talk about
this one what are the different types of
storage offered by azure now the
different types of storage offered by
azure are as you already know and as you
can see they are azure blob storages
table storages file storage and queue
storage so let's expand one after the
other now blob storage are nothing but a
massive scalable object storage and
that's very good for storing text and
binary data and azure blob storage is a
microsoft object storage solution for
the cloud a lot of storage is optimized
for storing massive massive amount of
unstructured data that can be in form of
text or or in form of binary data so in
short blob storage enables users to
store unstructured data and those data
can be in the format of pictures music
video files and lot more and it stores
them along with their metadata and
another advantage or another feature
benefit that we get from blob storage is
when object is changed it is verified to
ensure it is of the latest version
number one and number two it provides
maximum flexibility to optimize the
user's storage needs and this
unstructured data is available to
customers through an url or an rest
based object storage so they are the
benefits that come along with the blob
storage table storage on the other hand
is an a nosql store for schema-less
storage of secured data now this azure
table storage is a service that stores
structured nosql data in the cloud and
because this table is schema-less it's
very easy to save your data it's very
easy to adapt your data as the need for
your application grows and this table
storage is very fast and cost effective
for many type of applications so some of
the some of the type of data that we can
store is table storage is good for
flexible databases like user data for
web applications address book storage
device information storage and if you
want to store metadata this is a very
good use case to store them in azure
table storage azure files is another
storage here it's an managed file share
for cloud or on-premises
deployment so file storage provides the
file sharing capabilities accessible by
the server messaging block protocol and
this can be accessed from the cloud and
this can be accessed from on-premises as
well now here in file storage the data
is protected by smb
3.0 and https protocols and the more
important thing is azure takes care of
managing hardware and the operating
system deployments for azure file
storage so this additional file storage
can be used when we want to burst the
storage capacity in on premises so
on-premises the primary and cloud is the
secondary or the extended on-premises
storage so it actually improves the
on-premises performance and capabilities
for our on-premises data center and then
we have queues azure queues it's a
messaging store for reliable messaging
between the application components so we
spoke a little about this uh in the
previous question so the azure queue
storage is a service for storing a large
amount of messages that can be accessed
from anywhere in the world via http or
https protocol in here
the a single message can be up to 64
kilobits in size and in a queue we can
have millions of messages and the limit
can actually
go up if we have not reached the limit
of the storage account so it's millions
and millions of requests that can be
stored in the storage queue or the queue
storage so the queue storage in chart
provides message queueing for large
workloads and it enables users to build
flexible applications and separate
the functions one from another so one
failing doesn't affect the other
application which is running healthy and
this q storage it ensures the
application is scalable and less prone
to individual component failures because
they are decoupled separate now it also
helps in monitoring the queue which
ensures the customers demands are met so
queue is a great place to monitor or a
great component to monitor so we
understand how much peak have we reached
for a particular application service or
a container
what is text analysis api in azure
machine learning now a text analysis is
actually an cloud based analytics api
and it provides an advanced natural
language processing over the raw text
and it has got
four main functions like the sentiment
analysis or and the key phrase analysis
language uh deduction and few other
things now what do you mean by sentiment
analysis now sentiment analysis is from
the logs from the comments from the text
comments that we receive do an analysis
and find out whether that's a positive
or a negative statement now if it is a
the api the api returns and sentiment
score between 0 and 1 and 1 is positive
and 0 is negative and then in text
analysis we have
a key phrase extraction which is it will
automatically extract the key phrase to
uh quickly identify the main points in
that
key phrase for example if you're
analyzing an text which says the food
was delicious and there were wonderful
stuff then the api returns the main
talking points of that phrase like food
food is the main talking point and
wonderful stuffs that was a main talking
point so that's another feature that
this text analysis has and then we have
language deduction in text analysis but
irrespective of what you paste it can
try to gauge and try to align it to the
120 or up to 120 languages that it
supports so i can simply take text from
the internet and i can paste it and text
analysis software is going to identify
the language and then can run phrase and
sentiment analysis on those texts right
so in short text analysis is an api a
set of web services that can be used for
text analysis it can be used to analyze
unstructured statement sentiment
analysis key phrase extraction and lot
more and the results are generally
between 0 and 1 and 1 being positive and
0 being the negative sentiment there is
no much training or in other words this
is not as complicated as couple of other
text analysis softwares are available in
the market we can simply paste we can
simply upload the text and we can call
the service and it runs a sentiment
analysis on it all by itself let's look
at this question what are the advantages
of azure queue storage if you're going
to work in a development environment if
you're going to work on an environment
that
embraces devops this could be a question
what are the advantages of azure queue
storage now azure queue storage is built
to flexibly operate the applications and
separate the functions between the
applications that run large workloads so
when we design applications for scale
these applications can be decoupled so
that they can scale independently you
know and thing happening on an
application is not dependent on another
application and anything happens to an
section of the application will not
affect the other application because
they are now decoupled and connected
through the queue storage so the queue
storage gives us asynchronous message
queuing for communication between the
applications irrespective of whether
they are running in the cloud or whether
they are running in desktop or whether
they are running on premises or on
mobile devices so in short this queue
storage enables message queueing for
large workloads in a simple and cost
effective and a durable manner talking
about the advantages advantages is it
provides rich client libraries for java
android c plus plus php ruby and lot
other services getting added during
every new release from azure and the
main advantage again is it enables users
to build flexible apps and separate the
functions for
bigger or greater durability again
introduction of cues into our
application it ensures our users
applications are scalable and less prone
to individual component failures meaning
one component failing is not going to
take the whole application down right if
one component fails it's just that
component that stays fails the rest are
healthy and the rest are going to
function it also helps us to monitor the
queues and ensure the servers aren't
overhelmed by sudden traffic bursts so
how much do i have in the cube kind of
determines
the traffic for my application and if
the queue is more i can always go and
auto scale my environment and the queue
is less i can always go and shrink or
make my environment thinner so we can
save cost and anytime there is more data
in the queue i can auto scale monitor
the metric and do auto scaling based on
that metric so the environment knows
that there are more data's coming in i
need to expand myself to handle that
much amount of data this is a very
common question what are the two kinds
of azure web service roles now a service
role is a set of managed and load
balanced virtual machines that work to
perform some tasks and based on
what it's going to run on top of it is
it going to run a web service or is it
going to run worker service defines what
kind of roles that gets attached or that
goes on this virtual machines so we have
two types web role and worker roles the
web role is a cloud service role that's
configured to run web applications
developed on programming languages
technologies and majorly they support
iis internet information service and
they support asp.net php windows
communication foundation and so on so
that's web roles and these web roles it
automatically deploys and hosts
application through the user's iis
internet information service on the
other hand worker roles are roles that
runs applications and service level
tasks which generally do not require iis
so is is actually the differentiating
factor so in worker roles is not
installed by default the worker roles
are mainly used to perform supporting
background process along with web roles
and do tasks automatically compressing
or uploading the images running scripts
and
or doing some changes in the database
getting new messages from the queue and
processing a lot more you know the work
the applications are the work that does
not require ies that's what this
worker role does again the main
difference between the web role and the
worker role is that the web role
automatically deploys and hosts your
application through is whereas the
worker role does not use iis and runs
our application as standalone this is
another classic question what is azure
service fabric so azure service fabric
is actually a distributed system
platform that makes it easy to pack
deploy and manage scalable and reliable
microservices and containers now service
fabric also addresses some of the
significant challenges in developing and
managing cloud native applications and
the problem that it addresses and fixes
is now developers and administrators can
avoid complex infrastructure problems
and focus on implementing mission
critical and demanding workloads that
can be scaled and that can be managed
through the console or from the single
place in short service fabric provides a
platform that makes the process of
developing microservices and managing
application life cycle lot easier and
the advantages of service fabric is that
now we can produce application with
faster time to market because all the
worry about the infrastructure is taken
away from us we don't have to design an
infrastructure all that we need to worry
about is simply the application and the
application life cycle again the
advantage is it supports
windows it supports linux not only that
it supports servers on-premises and in
the cloud with service fabric we can
scale up our environment to even
thousand machines in just a single
command or if there is an immediate need
for a thousand machines i can
immediately scale them up 2 000 machines
that's possible with service fabric now
let's look at this question you can
expect this question if the customer is
running hybrid environment meaning
having some of the applications and
on-premises and running some of the
applications from the cloud and for some
reason when classifying the application
that goes to the cloud and that stays on
premises they have decided to keep the
database in-house so in that environment
a lot of customers do that so in that
environment this is a classic and a
scenario based question a client wants
the front end of their application to be
hosted on azure in the cloud and wants
the database to be hosted in on-premises
for security reasons or to have full
control on their databases how do we go
about suggesting a solution for this
customer the ideal solution in this
scenario is to use
the v-net based point-to-site vpn
solution so all the front-end
applications will be in the cloud and
they'll be hosted in a v-net and from
the we net they'll be connecting to the
database through and point to site vpn
so the traffic and the writings and the
leads are not coming through the
internet but through a point to site vpn
link that's connecting the azure vnet
and the on-premises environment and this
model or this approach or this solution
is best suited for scenarios where there
are only a limited number of resource
that needs to be connected
between on-premises and the cloud this
is a very common question what's azure
traffic manager of course we no more
running applications on a single server
we no more running applications on or
from a single environment right the same
application is being run from multiple
environments within azure and it can be
running from azure and on-premise as
well so multiple environments between
azure and on-premises a lot of customers
have such environment and if you are
facing an interview with such customer
this could be an ideal question what is
azure traffic manager now the azure
traffic manager is a dns based
traffic load balancer that actually
enables us to distribute traffic between
services across azure global regions and
by doing this it provides a good
availability and a good responsiveness
to the application and this traffic
manager it uses dns to direct client
requests to the most appropriate service
endpoint based on the traffic routing
logic and the health of the endpoints
that it maintains so in short this
traffic manager is a load balancer that
enables users to provide high
availability and responsiveness by
distributing traffic in an optimal
manner across the azure when we run the
same application in different regions so
some of the advantages or some of the
use cases of using azure traffic manager
is it provides multiple automatic
failover options it also helps with
reduced downtime it also helps with the
distribution of user traffic across
multiple locations so one location is
not overloaded and then it helps with
users knowing from where our customers
are getting connected from that's
another big use case with azure traffic
manager let's look at this question
right this is an ideal question now
there are group of servers connected
together within an virtual network and
now we need to
move them or create a separation between
them how do you go about achieving it so
the question goes like this you need to
isolate network traffic among vms in a
subnet which is part of a virtual
network with little downtime and impact
on the user so that's the given scenario
and the best way we can do it is create
a new virtual network and move all the
vms in that subnet to the new virtual
network now this feature is not possible
with a lot of other cloud service
providers like aws and a lot of other
providers now in those environments we
might need to shut down we might need to
stop the vm create a new vm based on the
image and it's an hefty process but here
in azure i can simply move the vms from
one subnet to another virtual network
without needing for any additional
security like the network security group
i can simply isolate them if i need to
by creating a simple new virtual network
and moving the servers to the new
virtual network look at this one this is
another common question with respect to
azure what is public private and hybrid
cloud so this is really to test how well
have you understood the different cloud
offerings in the market public private
and hybrid or at least the three basic
and hybrid cloud now the public cloud is
the most common way of deploying cloud
computing applications and
it has resources like servers storage
and are owned and operated by third
party cloud service providers like
microsoft azure microsoft azure is a
very good example of public cloud so
here every component that the user is
using is running only on azure that's
public cloud right let me talk to you
about some of the advantages of public
cloud some of the advantages is low cost
because there's no need to purchase
hardware or software and we pay only for
the services that we use in public cloud
and there is literally no maintenance
because
the service provider maintains the
environment for us and with public cloud
we have nearly unlimited scalability
meaning we can get resources on demand
and can meet our business requirements
on demand and the public clouds are very
highly reliable because they have a vast
network of servers and they ensure that
our application does not fail so there
are some advantages of public cloud
let's talk about private cloud now
private cloud consists of compute
resources used extensively by one
business or one organization now this
private cloud can be physically located
at our organizations on-site data center
or it can be hosted by a third-party
service provider whichever the case the
private cloud services and
infrastructure are always maintained on
a private network and they're maintained
on hardware and software that are
dedicated solely for one organization or
solely for your organization so in short
private cloud in azure is azure services
being run within an on-premises data
center or on-premises data center used
by the user to host systems or
applications and some of the advantages
some of the advantages is it gives more
security resources are not shared with
others so a higher level of control and
security over our resource and
application is possible and then we have
hybrid cloud now hybrid cloud is the
best of both worlds so it combines the
features of both public and private
cloud and some of the user components
are being run on azure and others within
on-premises data center so they kind of
share the resources in other words they
kind of share the application half of
the application would be running in on
premises and half of them would be in
the cloud and they would be working in
harmony to support the application and
the business need so that's hybrid cloud
this is one another good example
question that wants to test how well you
pick services or how well have you
understood the azure products and
services and are picking the right
service for the need so the question
would go like this what kind of storage
is best suited to handle unstructured
data
there are a lot of storage options
available and the requirement here is
what or which one would you choose for
unstructured data the answer for that
question is blob storage because blob
storage is designed to support
unstructured data it works in this way
it places the data into different tiers
based on how often they are accessed
different tier means different
performance different performance means
different cost associated with it so a
lot of add-on advantages will be get
when we use blob storage for
unstructured data in addition to it any
type of unstructured data can be stored
in blob storage this is not true with
couple of other storage options that we
have in azure only with blob storage we
can store any type of unstructured data
and the data integrity is maintained
every time an object is changed in the
blob storage and the best part is the
blob storage helps increase applications
performance and reduces the bandwidth
consumption and reduces the bandwidth
consumption for that application so they
are the benefits that we get for block
storage and blob storage are the ones
that are well suited for unstructured
data and that's what your answer should
be it's really an five-step process and
if you've worked and if we have done
some labs some basic labs with azure you
can easily answer this question so it's
a five step process first step is to log
into the azure the second one is to
create an
resource resource or a resource manager
and within the resource manager you will
be selecting the resource and then pick
the offering system do you want windows
or linux and within windows what's the
flavor you want or within linux what's
the flavor you want so decide on it and
then
entering the relevant information
relevant information like the
name of the
instance or the vm that we're going to
launch and the password the url that
goes with it and couple of other
relevant information that goes gets
itself attached with the
vm and then select the size of the
virtual machine different size different
uh
types available for the kind of
application and for the intensity of the
application that will be running on top
of it so select the virtual select the
size of the virtual machine review
everything whether they're good or not
if there are any changes required go
back and edit them and then come back
and launch and your vm is there for you
to start working within like three or
four minutes not even five minutes
within three or four minutes it gets
ready and you can start working on it so
it's a quick and it's a five step
process and you should be able to answer
it easily if you have done a few labs
in azure let's now look at some
scenario-based question you've been
posed with a scenario so we thought
through it and we picked some common
scenario based question that are being
asked in interview and i thought we'll
present it for you with the answers with
explanation so you can get benefited
through it so let's look at this
question you're asked to make sure your
virtual machines are able to communicate
securely with each other to ensure
security or to have good amount of
security what would you do and the
correct and the best answer for this
would be using virtual network in azure
which enables us to communicate with the
internet securely which enables us to
communicate with the on-premises data
center in a secure fashion so the
advantage of using virtual network is
users can create their own private
network users can pick their own private
ip ranges users can create their own
subnet users can create their own
routing between those two subnets a lot
more goes into that virtual network so
it's very customizable and the users are
provided with an isolated and highly
secure environment for applications it's
completely isolated from other customers
it's completely isolated from other
applications that are running in other
virtual network that we own so within
our account we can have multiple virtual
networks and one application running on
a virtual machine is completely isolated
from other applications running on other
virtual machines and of course all
traffic stays within the azure network
as your virtual machine or within the
azure network depending on how you set
up the routing if you have set up a
routing to go or reach the internet it's
going to go otherwise it's going to stay
within azure if you have set up routing
to reach on-premises then it's going to
go and reach on-premises otherwise it's
not going to go and reach on-premises
it's going to stay within the azure and
it also allows users to design their own
network like we already discussed
picking up ips picking routing you know
picking subnets you know how many
servers should be present in that
particular subnet or how many servers
should that subnet accommodate the size
of the subnet the ip ranges the netting
the masking of ips creating of vpn all
that's possible with the virtual network
so it really allows users to design
their own network and using virtual
machine is how we secure applications in
the cloud let's look at this other
scenario how do you ensure that every
time a user logs in they are not asked
to re-enter the password as part of
authentication so you really don't want
your users to re-enter the password
every time they log in to a different
application well all the applications
have their authentication mechanism in
place all of them wants to authenticate
the user before they log in ensuring the
user does not log in every time does not
mean that wiping away all the
authentication and authorization that's
present in that application you still
need that in place but how do you make
the user hassle free
so they're not asked to re-enter the
password or the same password again and
again let's look at the options
available the first one is to enable
microsoft account authentication well
it's not going to fix because with that
the user will still need to re-enter the
username and password at deploy express
route it's not going to fix either
because express route is a network level
service that connects on-premises to the
cloud so that has got nothing to do with
prompting or not prompting for password
and then we have a setup vpn between
on-premises data center and azure set up
80 domain controller in vm and implement
integrated windows authentication well
you can use the same username and
password for on-premises and the cloud
but this setup the the vpn and the ad
controller setup it's not going to stop
you asking for repeated passwords so
this is all about
using the same password in on premises
and in the cloud and this has got
nothing to do with
not prompting the user to re-enter the
password all right that's same password
is different from not prompting the user
to re-enter the password they are two
different scenarios so
that is also out of the equation and the
last one is configure ad sync to use
single sign-on that's the right one so
when we configure the ad to use a single
sign on then it's going it's not going
to ask for the username and password
every time we access an application
because we have logged in and that login
is going to stay active for like 24
hours or so depending on how you
configure it and within that time you
can access a lot of other applications
and it's not going to ask for the
username and password because you
already have a single signed on and you
have signed in using the right
credentials let's look at this one you
need to ensure that virtual machines
remain available while migrating to
azure what would be the appropriate
service to use right let's look at the
options traffic manager traffic manager
is
is literally a dna service and then
let's look at the other one update
domains it again has to do with traffic
manager updating the url so now the
traffic manager gets updated and then
starts sending requests to that
particular url it's gonna take some
downtime because when we update the url
they will have to be populated to all
different places and it takes time so
within that time any user trying to
access it's going to fail and then we
have express route and cloud services
express route could be the in fact it's
the right answer because express route
it's an extension of our on-premises and
cloud environment and in this question
it really comes out from a customer
who's having an hybrid environment so
they have applications running in
on-premises they have applications
running in the cloud and they want to
have a way to migrate applications from
on-premises to the cloud in other words
kind of do a cut over between
on-premises and the cloud and this
express route is a service that connects
between on-premises and the cloud so
when you do the cut over the traffic is
now sent to the cloud instead of being
handled in on-premises in fact the
services and the application is getting
down are getting shut down in on
premises so the request will come in the
same pattern instead of they being
handled in on-premises they are now
routed to the cloud using express route
and the api calls get addressed or the
the queries gets answered in the cloud
through the express route service look
at this question you are an
administrator for a website called web
game and you are required to validate
and deploy changes made to your website
by your development team with minimum
downtime so the real question is how do
you validate the deployment changes
that's made by the development team
let's look at the options create a new
linked resource create a staging
environment for the site enable remote
debugging on the website and then create
a new website well why would you want to
create a new website just to validate
the changes and doing a remote debugging
is not going to help because debugging
only captures logs of the changes
happening it does not do anything with
validating the changes create a staging
environment could be or is the right
answer because when we have staging
environments anything that we run on
production can be run on staging
environment and any failures that would
happen in production if we simply run it
in production can be captured when we
run the application in the staging
environment so that way staging
environment is a very helpful and useful
service and that way i can catch
any errors in other words i can validate
the changes that were done by my
development team before i move it to
production and that reduces the downtime
in the production environment look at
this one last question that we have for
you it's
a standard tier application is used
across the world and uses azure website
standard tier it uses large amount of
image files so you can get it this could
be an e-commerce website which has a lot
of pictures in it and this is causing
the application to load slow how can we
handle this situation let's look at the
options given configure blob storage
with custom domain well this application
has pictures but the pictures only the
pictures is not all that the application
has all right so configuring blob
storage might not help this could be an
very interactive website and that can't
be run from blob storage let's look at
the other options configure azure
website auto scaling to increase
instances at high loads now it's the
picture that's causing issues for the
website it's not the cpu or it's not the
memory unavailable memory not enough
that's causing the application to be
slow so we need to identify what's
causing the application to be slow so
it's not the cpu it's not the memory so
configure azure for auto scaling is not
gonna help and then what are the other
options let's see configure azure cdn to
cache all responses from the
applications web endpoint a cdn could be
the right answer but look at that it
says a cdn to cache all responses from
the applications web endpoint cdn is not
designed for that though it can do it
that's not the best way to use cdn to
capture all responses from the
application's web endpoint the proper
design for cdn would be to cache the
frequently used ones in other words
cache the static content which are
photos videos logos and pictures and lot
more static content that never changes
let's look at the last option configure
azure cdn to cache site images and
content stored in azure blob storage
absolutely correct so here we will have
to redesign the application to store the
pictures high quality lazy loading or
slow loading pictures because of the
high quality and the bigger size so
store them in cdn and then the content
let it be stored in azure blob storage
that's the right way of designing the
application and if we do it this
application is going to run faster or
the application is going to respond
faster to the users thanks guys with
that we've reached the end of this
complete cloud computing course i hope
you enjoyed this video do like and share
it thank you for watching and stay tuned
for more from simply learn
[Music]
you